barely scheduled to be in session at
this moment chief justice rehnquist will
soon be coming to the podium to oversee
today's
session of the united states senate live
here on c-span 2 it will re-air in its
entirety on our companion network on
c-span beginning at 8 p.m eastern time
also we'll be taking your phone calls
during breaks today and also at the end
of today's session so as the debate
unfolds today as you've reached an
opinion on whether or not you are for
acquittal or conviction of the president
of the united states on these two
articles of impeachment give us a call a
little bit later today in those breaks
and also when today's session is over
next here on c-span 2 live gavel to
gavel coverage of the continuing
impeachment trial of the president of
the united states
now
uh
[Music]
but senators rise please
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment
the chaplain will offer a prayer
gracious god these days here in the
senate are filled with crucial issues
differences on solutions
and eventually a vital vote in this
impeachment trial
we begin this day session with the
question
that you asked king solomon
ask what shall i give you
we empathize with solomon's response
he asked for an understanding heart
we are moved by the more precise
translation of the hebrew words
for understanding heart meaning a
hearing heart
solomon wanted to hear a word from you
lord
for the perplexities that he faced
he longed for the gift of wisdom
so that he could have answers and
directions for his people
we are moved by your response
see
i have given you a wise
and listening heart
i pray for nothing less as your answer
for the women and men of this senate
help them to listen to your guidance
and grant them wisdom for their
decisions
all through our history as a nation
you have made good men and women great
when they humbled themselves
confessed their need for your wisdom
and listened intently to you
speak
lord we need to hear
your voice
we are listening
amen amen
the senators will be seated
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton
president of the united states
if there's no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
the majority leader is recognized
thank you mr chief justice
if i could take just a moment to outline
how the proceedings will go this
afternoon i think that would answer any
questions that senators may have
we will of course continue the
consideration of articles of impeachment
i'm not aware of any objections made
during the depositions which require
motions to resolve therefore i believe
the house managers are prepared to go
forward with a motion
that would have three parts the first
would allow for the introduction of the
depositions into evidence the second
would call monica lewinsky as a witness
and the third part would allow for a
presentation period by the parties for
not to extend six hours
this motion would be debated by the
house managers and the white house
council for not to exceed uh two hours
in addition it's my understanding that
senator daschle intends to offer a
motion that uh would provide for going
directly to the articles of impeachment
for a vote
will allow for closing arguments final
deliberations and then the motions on
the two articles
having said that uh mr chief justice in
order for the managers to prepare debate
for the motions i ask at adam's consent
that house managers and the white house
counsel be allowed to make reference to
oral depositions during their debate on
pending motions
is there any objection
uh it's in the absence of objection it's
so ordered consequently four votes then
uh would occur in the 4 p.m time frame
today with respect to these uh four
motions uh we will take uh at least one
break uh maybe two between now and then
and that will determine exactly when
that series of votes would occur and
once we begin the process of offering
and debating the motions uh you know
we'll make a determination uh as exactly
when those breaks would occur in
addition uh
if the motion for additional
presentation time is agreed to by the
senate would be my intention to adjourn
the trial
after today's deliberations over until
saturday for the parties to make their
uh preparations then to present their uh
presentation of evidence on saturday
the trial would then resume on monday at
12 noon for the closing arguments of the
parties again i would remind all my
colleagues to please remain standing at
their desks when the chief justice uh
enters the chamber and leaves the
chamber i thank my colleagues for their
attention and i believe we're ready to
proceed mr chief justice
the chair recognized mr manager mccollum
the clerk will read the motion
ocean of the united states house of
representatives for the admission of
evidence the appearance of witnesses and
the presentation of evidence
now comes the united states house of
representatives by and through its duly
authorized managers and respectfully
submits to the united states senate its
motion for the admission of evidence the
appearance of witnesses and the
presentation of evidence in connection
with the impeachment trial of william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states
the house moves that the transcriptions
and videotapes of the oral depositions
taken pursuant to senate resolution 30
from the point that each witness is
sworn to testify under oath to the end
of any direct response to the last
question posed by a party be admitted
into evidence
the house further moves
that the senate authorize and issue a
subpoena for the appearance of monica s
lewinsky before the senate for a period
of time not to exceed eight hours and in
connection with the examination of that
witness the house request that either
party be able to examine the witness as
if that witness were declared adverse
that counsel for the president and
counsel for the house managers
be able to participate in the
examination of that witness and that the
house be entitled to reserve a portion
of its examination time to re-examine
the witness following any examination by
the president
the house further moves that the parties
be permitted to present before the
senate
for a period of time not to exceed a
total of six hours equally divided
all or portions of the parts of the
videotapes of the oral depositions
of monica s lewinsky vernon e jordan jr
and sydney blumenthal admitted into
evidence and that the house be entitled
to reserve a portion of its presentation
time
the chair recognizes the majority chief
justice i understand that defending
motion is divisible and as is my right i
ask the motion be divided in the
following matter the paragraph first
paragraph to consider division one the
second paragraph be considered division
two the final paragraph to be considered
division three
uh the the motion uh it will be divided
in the manner indicated by the majority
of the volume justice i suggest the
absence of a car
the clerk will call the roll mr abraham
one
yes
mr chief justice
the chair recognized the majority leader
i asked the consent that the quorum call
be dispensed with
is there any objection and
in the absence of objection mr chief
justice uh identified this as the first
paragraph to be considered division one
actually that should be the second
paragraph would be division one third
paragraph division two and the uh fourth
paragraph would be uh division three
i want that clarification also
uh so that both sides will understand
the motion there's one motion
but we've divided into three parts so
there will only be two hours equally
divided one on each side not
two hours equally divided on each one of
the three divisions we had one uh
clarification i believe we have cleared
up and i believe now we're ready to hear
from the managers mr chief very well the
chair recognized mr manager mccollum
chief justice
as the first one up here today i have to
fiddle with the microphone i guess it
started like testing and i apologize
mr chief justice and members of the
senate what we have presented to you
today is a three-part motion as mr lot
has described it and as you heard read
to you
we would like very much as we always
have to have all of the witnesses that
we want presented here live as we would
normally have in a trial as the house
has always believed that it should have
we came before you a few days ago
recognizing the reality of that
and went forward with your procedures to
request
not five not six not twelve but three
witnesses be deposed so that we might be
able to in the discovery process you've
allowed us to gain the depositions of
those three witnesses
today we're before you with motions
first to enter those depositions and the
video recordings of those depositions
into evidence formally for your
consideration because they've now been
accomplished
secondly to request that you provide us
with the opportunity to examine monica
witness lewinsky live here as a witness
on the floor of the senate
and for you to allow us to present the
other two depositions to you in some
format and if you do not allow us the
permission to have ms lewinsky live here
to examine as a witness to allow us to
present any or all portions of the
depositions of all three of them
now
i think that it's imminently fair that
we be allowed to present at least one
witness live to you the central witness
in the cast of this entire proceeding
and that's monica lewinsky i'm not here
to argue all of that my principle
discussion with you is going to be on
the part dealing with just admitting
these into evidence and then my
colleagues mr bryant and mr hutchinson
and mr rogan are going to present some
complimentary discussion about the
entire motion as we go through this
but in the context of all of this i
think we have to recognize a couple of
things one is that live witnesses are
preferable
whether you have depositions or not
these were discovery depositions we
would have liked to have asked for all
of them to be live but we're recognizing
reality by coming down to one today and
the reasons are fairly straightforward
some of you have had the privilege and
i'm sure you've availed yourself the
opportunity to look at the videotapes of
these depositions and you see that they
are indeed what most depositions are
they are discovery they have long pauses
in them they're not at all like it would
be in a trial itself you don't have the
opportunity to fully see or explore with
a witness the demeanor the temperament
the spontaneity all of those things that
you normally get with an exchange you
have the camera simply focused on the
witness you don't get to have the
interaction you get in a courtroom and
remember again that we're dealing here
first with your determining whether or
not the president committed the crimes
of perjury and obstruction of justice
and then the question of whether or not
he should be removed from office so i
believe we believe as house managers
that you should at least let us have
monica lewinsky here live for both of
those reasons
i also want to make comments
specifically about just admitting these
into evidence there are two obvious
reasons why
beyond the question of whether the
witness a witness should appear alive or
whether we should use portions of them
in whatever fashion to present to you
that they certainly should be part of
the record
that seems self-evident it is part of
what you
gave us as the procedure to do
and it would seem to me that it should
be a mere formality for me to ask but i
cannot assume anything we certainly do
not that we let these depositions into
evidence and there are two reasons why
one is the historical basis for this
there has to be a record
not only for you but for the public and
for history
of the entire proceeding
there is evidence in these depositions
that needs to be a part of the official
record and that evidence is not just the
cold transcript but it's also the
videotape with all of the limited albeit
not satisfactory portion of it that you
can see it observed especially if you
were to conclude we weren't going to
have any live witness here or we're not
going to allow us to present these
depositions you certainly should allow
the depositions to be part of the record
and the videotape part of it it's
evidence it's to be examined it seems
self-evident but the second point is as
you're going to hear more from my
colleagues in just a moment there is new
evidence in these depositions there's
new factual record information that
needs to be here for you to decide the
guilt or innocence question on the purge
and obstruction of justice charges one
illustration
i will give you and i'm sure my
colleagues will give you plenty more one
of them deals with the gift question
we've talked about it a lot out here if
you recall with with regard to the
question of the gifts the issue is did
the president
obstruct justice did he
decide in the jones case in the jones
court as a part of his course of conduct
of trying to keep from the court the
nature of his relationship with monica
lewinsky to keep the gifts hidden
there is new information
in the deposition
relative to what happened on the day
those gifts were supposedly exchanged
between monica lewinsky
and betty curry about the telephone
calls again i'm not going into the
details of that i'll leave that for my
colleagues to do who took the
depositions and can tell you about them
the point is there you could enumerate
and they will new evidence
there is significant relevant new
evidence from the burden vernon jordan
deposition and from the sydney
blumenthal deposition so just on the
record alone just to put the depositions
into record
there can be nothing complete about this
trial if we don't at least do that at
least do that and so with that in mind
having said that and urged you to do
that
i will yield to mr bryant
at this point in time to manager brian
mr chief justice
distinguished colleagues and senators
i would
encourage each of you to consider
calling monica lewinsky
as the one live witnesses witness in
this proceeding
miss lewinsky continues to be
in her own way an impressive witness
as i spoke to you earlier
she does have a story to tell
after all no one knows more about the
majority of the allegations against the
president other than of course president
himself
at her deposition
she appeared to be a different monica
lewinsky than the monica lewinsky with
whom i had met a week earlier
unlike before she was not open to
discussion
or fully responsive to fair inquiry
she didn't volunteer her story
she didn't tell her story
rather she was in a
very guarded in each response and almost
protective
her words were carefully chosen and
relatively few
at times the concepts that she discussed
had the familiar ring of another key
witness to these proceedings
such as it wasn't a lie
or wasn't false it was misleading or
incomplete
truth is what one believes it is and may
be different for different people
truth depends on the circumstances
as we progressed through her deposition
monday i felt more and more like one of
the characters in the classic movie
witness for the prosecution
i was charles lawton
miss lewinsky was marlena dietrich
and the president was tyrone power
and if you're familiar with this movie
you'll understand
and if you aren't you should see the
movie
however there was and there still
remains truth in her testimony sometimes
though
just like the president
and now ms lewinsky it is the literal
truth only
the most restricted and stretched
definition one can reach
and we all know that the law frowns upon
the manipulations such as this to avoid
telling the complete truth
two her testimony is clearly tinted
some might even say tainted
by a mixture of her continued admiration
for the president
her desire to protect him
and her own personal views of right and
wrong
and she was well represented in the
deposition by some of washington's
finest defense attorneys who had
thoroughly prepared her for all
questions as they should have
as well as being present throughout the
deposition to a sister
in fact the senator in charge of this
particular deposition had to warn these
council not to coach and not to whisper
to her while she was attempting to
answer the questions
if you've seen this deposition
you've witnessed an effective effort by
a loyal supporter of the president to
provide the very minimum of truth in
order to be consistent with her own
grand jury testimony
which is legally necessary for her to
fulfill
the terms of her immunity agreement
on the perjury article of impeachment
she reaffirmed the specific facts which
happened between her and the president
on more than one occasion including
november 15 1995 their first encounter
when the president's conduct fit
squarely within
the four corners of the term sexual
relationship as defined in the jones
lawsuit
and this is in opposition to the
president's own sworn testimony of
denial
but this is one of the clearest examples
of the president's guilt of this charge
of perjury
that's not about this twisted definition
that the president assigned to the term
sexual
relations rather it's his word against
her word as to whether this specific
conduct occurred
even under his own reading of this
definition he agrees that that specific
conduct if it occurred would
make him guilty of sexual relations
within that definition but he simply
says i did not do that
she says you did do that
a he said she said case
but this is why it's important for you
to be able to see ms lewinsky in person
in the deposition you will
observe her as having to affirm her
prior testimony she had to affirm her
prior testimony because that was what
was in the grand jury
and because of this she could not back
away at all on her testimony and she
couldn't bend it here or there and she
couldn't shade it in the president's
favor
so what you have is a person whom you
may well conclude is still wanting to
help the president having to admit
to testimony that would do damage to the
president a very difficult situation for
her
but yet this same difficulty
lends this portion of her testimony
great credibility
with respect to the other article of
impeachment on obstruction of justice
her credibility is again bolstered by
her reluctance to do legal harm to this
president
in the end though she does admit that he
called her early one morning in december
of 1997
actually at two o'clock in the morning
and told her that she was on the witness
list and he told her that she might be
able to file an affidavit to avoid
testifying and he told her that she
could always use the story that he was
she was bringing papers to him or coming
up to see miss curry
now we know that she did not carry
papers to him on these visits other than
personal private notes from her to him
and miss lewinsky indicated
in the deposition that she didn't carry
him official papers although she did
pass along this cover story of carrying
papers
to her attorney mr carter
she testified also that she discussed
the draft affidavit with mr jordan
changes were made
she offered the president the
opportunity to review it he declined and
according to ms lewinsky he never
suggested any way that she could file a
truthful affidavit sufficient to skirt
avoid having to testify
this in spite of his answer to this
senate where he told you that he might
have had a way for her to
file a truthful affidavit
and still avoid testifying in the jones
case
yes you can parse the words and you can
use legal gymnastics but you cannot get
around
the filing of the false affidavit in an
effort to avoid appearing in the jones
case
and possibly providing damaging
testimony against the president
mrs lewinsky
confirmed positively
that miss curry initiated the telephone
call to her on december 28 1997 stating
words and this is about the gift
the gifts i understand you have
something for me
then ms curry drove over to ms
lewinsky's home and picked up the box of
gifts
now remember this occurred
on the heels of miss lewinsky's
conversation with the president that
very morning
about what she might do with the gifts
now the only the only explanation that
the president
is that the president is directly
involved
himself in the obstruction of justice by
telling miss curry
who otherwise knew nothing about this
earlier conversation
to retrieve these items from his curry
from miss lewinsky
miss lewinsky said there was no doubt
that miss curry initiated the call to
retrieve the gifts and also recall that
the president's testimony from his side
was that this conversation occurred
earlier in the day with miss lewinsky
but that he had told her
that he she would have to turn over
whatsoever whatever gifts that she had
now with with that advice from the
president it would be totally illogical
for ms lewinsky to have then called miss
curry that same day and asked her to
come pick up and hold these gifts
by calling ms curry miss lewinsky would
have been going against the direct
instruction of the president to
surrender any and all gifts
the facts
the logic
and common sense tell us all that the
president's version is not true and that
he obstructed justice here
miss lewinsky also testified at the
deposition about the job at revlon in
obtaining a job offer within two days of
signing the affidavit
she also denied that she was a stalker
as the president had described her in a
conversation with mr blumenthal in
january of 1998
she also denied that she threatened the
president or attempted to threaten the
president into having an affair
she denied that that he rebuffed her on
the occasion of their first encounter on
november 15 1995 again all false
statements that the president made to mr
blumenthal about her with knowledge that
mr blumenthal would be testifying in a
grand jury thereby obstructing justice
now the former lawyers and judges among
us are familiar with what is called the
best evidence rule
stated simply the court always prefers
the best available evidence
to be used
in person testimony is better than a
video deposition which itself is better
than the written transcript of a
deposition
when all three forms of testimony are
available
as they are in this situation the court
will most often require the witness to
testify in person
over the video deposition or over the
written transcript the definite
deposition
in closing i know we all want to work
within the senate rules
and we all want to ensure that these
proceedings
are concluded in a constitutional
fashion
by the end of next week
it is with this in mind that we propose
that ms lewinsky be called as a live
witness the only person called to
testify in person
and further that we use the two
depositions the video depositions of mr
jordan and mr blumenthal in lieu of
their personal attendance
in the event the senate does not call
miss lewinsky we also ask that we be
permitted to use all portions of her
deposition just as we would the other
two depositions
finally several senators have sent out a
letter to the president inviting him to
come here and to provide his testimony
if he so chooses
in the event he should accept
ms lewinsky likewise should be afforded
the same opportunity they continue to be
the two most important and essential
witnesses witnesses
for you and the american people
to hear in order to finally to finally
resolve this matter
permit us all to return to our districts
and you to your states
and tell our constituents
that we considered the full
and the complete case
including live witnesses and in your
case major votes accordingly
at this time i would yield to my
colleague from arkansas mr hutching
the chair recognizes mr manager
hutchinson
thank you mr chief justice
ladies and gentlemen the senate uh
in an effort to be helpful i've asked
the pages to distribute
to you some exhibits that i'll be
referring to
as i consider the testimony that we are
presenting to you
there's two aspects to
an impeachment trial there's the
truth-seeking responsibility
which is the trial in my judgment and
then there is the conclusion the
judgment the verdict
the conviction or the acquittal
and if you look at those two phases of a
trial the latter is totally your
responsibility we leave that completely
in your judgment
but the
first responsibility of the fact-finding
of the true seeking endeavor i feel some
responsibility in that regard and that's
hopefully our presentation is helpful in
seeking the truth and i know as mr
bryant mentioned that we all want to
bring this matter to conclusion
we want to
see the end of the story we want to have
a final chapter in this national
drama
and i understand that and agree with
that but let's not because we're in a
hurry to get to the judgment phase let's
not let that detract let's not let that
short change nor diminish the importance
of the presentation and consideration of
the facts and that's what i think is is
very important as we consider this
motion that's before us
now it's my responsibility to
talk about mr vernon jordan and the need
for your consideration
of his testimony
that we have simply we have recently
deposed i depose mr vernon jordan jr and
i would recommend that that be received
in evidence as part of the senate record
i took this deposition under the able
guidance of senator thompson and senator
dodd the questioning took place uh over
almost three hours
with numerous
and extraneous objections behalf of the
president's lawyers most of which were
resolved
i believe that the testimony of mr
jordan goes to the
key element in the obstruction of
justice article and even though it's
just one element that we're dealing with
it is a very important element because
it goes to the connection between the
job search the benefit provided to a
witness and the solicited false
testimony from that witness
i believe the testimony of mr jordan is
dramatic
in that it shows the control and
direction of the president of the united
states in the effort to obstruct justice
i believe the testimony of mr jordan
provides new evidence
supporting
the charges of instruction and verifying
the credibility of miss lewinsky
the testimony in addition is the most
clear discussion of the facts reflecting
mr jordan's actions in behalf of the
president and the president's direction
and control of the activities of mr
jordan and therefore they support the
allegations under the articles of
impeachment now let me make the case for
you
if you have the president of the united
states personally directing the effort
to obtain a job for miss lewinsky which
is a benefit to a witness and
simultaneously miss lewinsky is under
subpoena as a witness in the case and
thirdly in addition the president is
suggesting
means
to that witness to avoid truthful
testimony as evidenced by the december
17 conversation and the suggestion of
the affidavit the conclusion is that you
have a corrupt attempt to impede the
administration of justice and the
seeking of truth and the facts in the
civil rights case
now let me go to the testimony of mr
jordan
and
has that been distributed now good
and let me uh give a caveat here
particularly to uh my colleagues the the
counselors for the president that this
uh summary of the portions of the
testimony mr jordan are based upon my
handwritten notes
and so please don't blow it up in a
chart
if there is some discrepancy i believe
this is in good faith accurate
but i did not have a copy of the
transcript i was required to go to a
senate chamber and actually take notes
in order to prepare this but there's a
number of areas that i think are
relevant and are new information and are
very important for your consideration
but let me just touch upon five areas
the first one is the job search and mr
jordan be an agent of the president
and
in the deposition
mr jordan testified that there is no
question but that through betty curry i
was acting on behalf of the president to
get miss lewinsky a job he goes on to
say i interpreted the request referring
from betty curry as a request from the
president
and then he testified but there was no
question that he asked me to help
referring to the president and that he
asked others to help and i think that is
clear from everybody's grand jury
testimony
and so
the question is to whether the
information the request came from betty
curry or whether it came directly from
the president there is no question but
that mr jordan was acting at the request
of the president of the united states
and no one else
in fact he goes on to say that the fact
is i was running the job search not miss
lewinsky and therefore the companies
that she brought or listed were not of
interest to me i knew where i would need
to call and this is very important
there's been reference well he was
simply
getting a job referral making a referral
for
a routine employment interview by this
person miss lewinsky but in fact it's
clear that mr jordan knew who he wanted
to contact he was running the job search
as he testified to
and then he testified question you're
acting behalf of the president when
you're trying to get miss lewinsky a job
and you were in control of the job
search the answer is yes
and now
so that's one area and it's important to
establish that he was an agent for the
president secondly
there was the witness list that came out
december 5th
the president knew about it at the
latest on december 6th
and yet he had two meetings with mr
jordan december 7th and on december 11th
and in neither one of those meetings was
it disclosed to mr jordan that monica
lewinsky was a witness and i'm referring
to the second page of the exhibits i've
handed from you uh then which mr jordan
testified to that effect
question and on either of these
conversations i have referenced that you
had with the president after the witness
list came out
your conversation on december 7th and
your conversation sometime after the
11th did the president tell you that
miss monica lewinsky was on the witness
list in the jones case answer he did not
question would you have expected the
president to tell you if he had reason
to believe that miss lewinsky would be
called as a witness in the paula jones
case answer that would have been helpful
question so it would have been helpful
and it was something you would have
expected answer yes
and even though it would have been
helpful he would have expected the
president to tell him that information
it was not disclosed to him and the the
materiality the relevance of that is
that you have the president controlling
a job search knowing that this is a
witness in which we're trying to provide
a benefit for and yet the person that
he's directing to get the job
for miss lewinsky he fails to tell
mr jordan a key fact that she is in fact
a witness an adverse witness in that
case
and so i think that's an important area
of his testimony the third area keeping
the president informed very clear
testimony
about the development of the job search
the lewinsky affidavit that was being
prepared and the fact that it was signed
on the third page that i provided to you
mr jordan's testimony i was keeping him
the president informed about what was
going on and so i told him
he goes on further to say he referring
to the president was obviously
interested in it
and then
the question i believe was
what did you tell the president when the
affidavit was signed and his answer mr
president she signed the affidavit she
signed the affidavit and so was there
enter
any connection between the job benefit
that was provided and the affidavit that
was signed in reference to her testimony
clearly it was something the president
not only directed the job search but he
was clearly interested obviously
concerned receiving regular reports
about the affidavit
and then the fourth area is the
information at the park hyatt
that was developed
now to lay the stage for this and i'll
do this very briefly if you look at page
four you see the previous testimony of
mr jordan before the grand jury in march
and at that time the question was asked
to him did you ever have breakfast or
any meal for that matter with monica
lewinsky at the park hyatt his answer
was no
it was not equivocable
it was indutibly no
and
it was further asked
you know he testified i have never had
breakfast with monica lewinsky
and then on page five he goes on in the
may 28th
grand jury testimony did you at any time
have any kind of a meal at the park
height with monica lewinsky his answer
is no and so that sets the stage because
in ms lewinsky's testimony as evidenced
by page six of your exhibits she
testified in august after the last time
mr jordan testified very clearly about
this meeting on december 31st at the
park hyatt with mr jordan where they had
breakfast
and
the discussion was about linda tripp and
then this question the discussion went
to the notes
from the president and she said
no it was notes from the present from me
to the president and mr jordan told her
according to her testimony go home and
make sure they're not there
that is ms lewinsky's testimony it was
important to ask mr jordan about this
and i assumed that we would of course
get simply a denial sticking with the
previous grand jury testimony that
unequivocally no that meeting never
happened we never had breakfast at the
hyatt on page seven you'll notice that
miss lewinsky and her testimony
specifically identified even what they
had for breakfast
and so the investigation required us to
go out and get the receipt at the park
hyatt which is page eight and the
receipt showed that there was a charge
on december 31st by mr jordan
that included every item for breakfast
that corroborated the testimony of ms
lewinsky as to her memory as the omelet
they had for breakfast
and so
it's tightening here the evidence is
becoming more clear unequivocable that
that this meeting occurred and so we had
to ask this to mr jordan and this is
page nine
and of course i presented
the park hyatt receipt i presented the
testimony of miss lewinsky and his
testimony which is page nine it is clear
based on the evidence here that i was at
the park height on december 31st so i do
not deny despite my testimony before the
grand jury that on december 31st that i
was there with ms lewinsky but i did
testify before the grand jury that i did
not remember having a breakfast with her
on that date and that was the truth
but what amazed me was as you go through
the questions with him all of a sudden
he remembered the breakfast but all of a
sudden he remembered the conversation
in which he before said it never
happened at all and his testimony was
when asked about the notes i am certain
that miss lewinsky talked to me about
the notes
and so i think there's a number of
relevant points here first of all you
reflect back on the testimony ms
lewinsky in this same deposition
when she was asked the question
getting mr jordan's approval was
basically the same as getting the
president's approval her answer yes
and so
that's how mr lewinsky viewed this
and this is what was told to her at this
meeting on park hyatt and it goes to the
credibility it goes to what happened it
goes to the obstruction of justice it is
extraordinarily relevant it is new
information it is what was developed
because this senate granted us the
opportunity to take this further
deposition of mr jordan and the other
witnesses
and there's other you know the fifth
point is that it goes to
the testimony goes the interconnection
between the job
help and the testimony that was being
solicited
from miss lewinsky and so why is the
presentation necessary some of you might
even think well thank you very much for
that explanation you've given to us now
we have all the facts let's go on and
vote
well
i do think that there is some first of
all this is not all there's much more
there i just have a moment to develop a
portion of mr jordan's testimony that i
believe is helpful but secondly it tells
the story it's never been told before
now i went and saw the videotape and i
was underwhelmed by my questioning
because it's just not the same i thought
we had a dynamic exchange
but then i saw it on videotape and i'm
nowhere to be found
you get to look at mr jordan a
distinguished gentleman but it's still
helpful not withstanding the difficulty
of a video presentation and i would
respectfully request this body to
develop the facts fully to hear the
testimony of mr jordan to allow him to
explain this it tells a story start to
finish on this one aspect
of obstruction of justice that is
critical to your determination and so
i would ask your concurrence in the
approval of the motion that's been
offered to you at this time i'd yield to
manager rogan
the chair recognizes mr manager rogan
members of the senate
yesterday along with mr manager graham
i had the privilege of conducting the
deposition of sydney blumenthal
assistant to the president
that deposition was presided over by the
senior senator from pennsylvania and the
junior senator from north carolina and
on behalf of the house managers and i'm
also sure white house counsel we thank
them for the able job that they did
this deposition
must be played
for members of the united states senate
and if one senator
has failed to personally sit through
this deposition
and every deposition
that senator is not equipped
to render a verdict on the impeachment
trial of the president of the united
states
now i will address very briefly
just a couple of the reasons why i
believe mr blumenthal's deposition
warrants being played before this body
but to do it it needs to be put
in perspective
remember what the president of the
united states testified to
on the day he was sworn in as a witness
before the grand jury
he said that in dealing with his aides
he knew
that there was a potential that they
could become witnesses before the grand
jury
and that is why
he told them the truth
that is the president's own word the
truth
mr blumenthal's deposition
paints a totally different picture
and gives a terribly different
interpretation
of what the president was doing in
passing along false stories
to his aides now we've been treated to a
number of euphemisms by the
distinguished white house counsel during
this presentation as to what the
president was doing during his grand
jury
they have described his testimony
as
maddening they've described his
testimony as misleading and unfortunate
but the one thing they've never
described it as
is a lie mr blumenthal
gave a totally different take on that
because he testified under oath
that upon reflection he believes the
president
was not maddening to him
the president lied to him
and he testified so for very good reason
remember sidney blumenthal testified
three times before the grand jury in
1998 he testified in february and twice
in june
but that testimony was in a vacuum
because each time he testified before
the grand jury we were still in a
national state of at least
presumptorially believing that the
president had told the truth the
president had made an emphatic denial as
to the monica lewinsky story there was
no physical evidence presented to the
fbi lab at the time mr blumenthal
testified
and monica lewinsky was not cooperating
with the grand jury
so we know that certain questions were
not asked of him during his grand jury
testimony
because of the stat of the status of the
facts as we thought they were
but mr blumenthal shed some incredible
new light
on the testimony that we received
yesterday from him
he said first of all
after i was subpoenaed
but before i testified before the grand
jury
once in february and twice in june
with the president knowing he was about
to become a witness before the grand
jury a criminal grand jury investigation
the president never came to him
and said
mr blumenthal before you go and provide
information in a criminal grand jury
investigation
i need to recant the false stories i
told you about my relationship with
monica lewinsky
and he testified about those false
stories
he corroborated his own testimony from
earlier proceedings you will recall from
the record
that the day the monica lewinsky story
broke in the national press
mr blumenthal was called to the oval
office by the president the door was
closed they were alone and this is what
the president told sydney blumenthal
about the revelations that were breaking
that day
on the national press wire
he said that monica lewinsky came at me
and made a sexual demand on me
the president said he rebuffed her he
said i've gone down that road before
i've caused pain for a lot of people i'm
not going to do that again
the president said monica lewinsky
threatened him
she said she would tell people they had
an affair
that she was known as the stalker among
her colleagues
and that she hated it and if she had an
affair or said she had an affair then
she wouldn't be the stalker anymore and
the testimony goes on you're all
familiar with it at this point
the president of the united states
allowed his aide
to appear three times before a federal
grand jury conducting a criminal
investigation and never once did the
president of the united states
inform that aid before providing that
information to the investigatory body
never once asked the aide or told the
aide that that was false information
mr blumenthal's testimony demonstrates
that the president of the united states
used a white house aid
as a conduit for false information
before the grand jury
in a criminal investigation
i just want to make one other brief
point before i close this presentation
because i think it needs to be said i am
in no position to lecture any of the
distinguished members of this body
on what the founders intended in
drafting the constitution i believe all
of us in this room have an abiding
respect for that but there are a couple
of points that need to be made
i believe there is a reason
the founders drafted a document
that allows us the opportunity in every
trial proceeding in america to confront
and cross-examine live witnesses it is
because that gives the trier effect the
opportunity to gauge the credibility and
the demeanor of the witnesses
we've discussed that at length during
these proceedings but one thing we
haven't discussed and one thing that i
think is important not from the house
manager's perspective but from the
perspective of history and the history
that will be written on the ultimate
verdict in this case
and that is the idea of open trials
there is a reason why
the founders look to scance on the
concept of secret trials and close
trials there is a reason why in every
courtroom across the land
trials are open they are open it is an
open process the light of truth is
allowed to be shown on the courtroom and
from the courtroom
because we don't trust the credibility
of a verdict if it's done in secret
what will be the verdict on this
proceeding
if the judgment of this body is based
upon testimony and witnesses
on videotapes
locked in a room somewhere
available only to the triers of fact
without the public being privy
to what was made available
ladies and gentlemen of the senate i
would urge you not for the sake of the
managers and not for the sake of the
presentation of the case but for the
sake of this body and for the verdict of
history that will be written
to please allow
this to be a public trial
in the real sense
if the witnesses will not be brought
here live before the senate please allow
the doors of the senate to be open so
that the testimony upon which each of
you must base your verdict
will be made available not only to all
100 senators but will be made available
to those
who will make the ultimate judgment as
to the appropriateness of the verdict
the american people mr chief justice at
this time i yield to mr manager graham
the chair recognizes mr manager graham
mr chief justice how much time do we
ever make
uh you've consumed 37 minutes and you
your colleagues have yeah
uh ladies and gentlemen senate uh not a
whole lot dad but i would like to
recognize this thought that we've
learned a great deal in these
depositions and thank you for letting us
have them
we didn't get everything we wanted i
think that's a fair statement but who
does in life
but we do appreciate you giving us the
opportunity
to
explore the testimony of these witnesses
because i think it will be helpful in
setting the historical record straight
mr blumenthal to his credit said the
president of the united states lied to
him
the president of the united states did
lie to him the president of the united
states in his grand jury testimony
denied ever lying to an aide
that will be historically significant
and should be legally significant
mr blumenthal to his credit
said that the president of the united
states tried to paint himself as a
victim
of miss lewinsky
that will be legally and historically
relevant and it will mean a lot in our
arguments and it will be something you
should consider
this has been a good exercise thank you
very much for letting us depose these
witnesses
i was not at the other two depositions
but i was at mr blumenthal's deposition
and i can assure you we know more now
about what the truth is than before we
started this process
and i hope at the end of the day it is
our desire to get to the truth that
guides us all
we're asking for one live witness miss
lewinsky
and let me tell you i know how difficult
it is to want this to go on giving where
everybody at is in the country
trust me i want this to end as much as
you do
however
there's a signal we're going to send if
we don't watch it
we're going to make the independent
council report the impeachment trial and
i'm not so sure that's what the statute
was written for
the key difference between the house and
the senate is that the white house never
disputed the facts
over in the house
they never disputed the facts they
called 15 witnesses to talk about
process
and about the interpretations
that you would want to put on those
facts
in their presentation to the senate
everything is in dispute
is totally a different ballgame here
that's why we need witnesses ladies and
gentlemen to clarify who said what
who's being honest who's not
and what really did happen
in this sordid tale
miss lewinsky
comes before us
because the allegations
arise
that the president of the united states
with an intern had an inappropriate
workplace sexual relationship
that was discovered in a lawsuit where
he was a defendant
this was not us or anyone else trying to
look into the president's private life
for political reasons or any other
reason
it was a defendant in a lawsuit
asking to look at the behavior of that
defendant in the workplace
something that goes on every day in
courtrooms throughout the country
and is it uncomfortable
yes it is uncomfortable if you've ever
tried a sexual
harassment case an assault case or a
rape case it is very much uncomfortable
to have to listen to these things
but the reason
that people
are asked to do what you're asked to do
by the house managers
is that the folks that are involved
represent themselves
much better than lawyers talking about
what happened
and if you find it uncomfortable listen
to miss lewinsky
think how juries feel
think how the victims feel
think how somebody like miss jones must
feel not to be able to tell the story of
the person they're suing
that is a
signal that's going to be sent here
that would be a devastatingly bad signal
if we can't stomach it
if we can't stomach to listen to
inappropriate sexual conduct why do we
put that burden on anyone else
give us this witness
we will do it in a professional manner
we will focus on the obstruction
we will try to do it in a way not to
demean the senate we'll try to do it
away not to demean miss lewinsky we'll
try to do it in a way to get to the
truth
please give us a chance to present our
case in a persuasive fashion
because unlike the house everything is
in dispute here
thank you very much
the house managers reserve the balance
of their time
the chair recognizes counsel for the
president mr craig
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
i've divided my presentation into three
parts that fortunately correspond to the
three parts of the motion that is before
you today
i'd like first to argue against
admitting videotape
evidence into the record of this trial
secondly i'd like to argue against
calling live witnesses
to this trial
and thirdly i'd like to argue against
the proposed presentation
of videotape and deposition testimony
for saturday
i sound rather negative i don't mean to
be negative
but
we don't find much to recommend the
three proposals that the house managers
have brought before you today
let me begin by saying that we support
the idea
of admitting written transcripts of the
deposition testimony of these three
witnesses into the record of this trial
but we believe that it would be a
terrible mistake
and wholly redundant
to put the videotape testimony into that
record as well
particularly if that means
releasing any of this videotaped
material to the public
we can only call the senate attention to
section 206
of senate resolution 30
which instructs the secretary of the
senate quote to maintain the videotaped
and transcribed records of the
depositions
as confidential proceedings of this
means
releasing any of this videotaped
material to the public
we can only call the senate attention to
section 206
of senate resolution 30
which instructs the secretary of the
senate quote to maintain the videotaped
and transcribed records of the
depositions
as confidential proceedings of the
senate that was the intention of the
senate
when they first passed when you first
passed senate resolution 30.
if this decision is proposed today will
result in overruling that rule
if there is any risk or danger of a
wholesale unconditional and unlimited
release of these videotapes the public
through the national media
just as was done by the house of
representatives
when it released all the star materials
we think it's a bad idea
in retrospect most people believe that
it was a mistake for the house to
release those materials then
and those materials included
videotapes of grand jury testimony
and we believe it would be a mistake for
the senate
at the request of the house managers
to do the same
same thing with these videotape
materials now
to release these videotapes generally to
the public
which will happen if they're put into
the record inevitably
will surely cause consternation among
those members of the public particularly
parents
who do not choose to spend one more
moment
much less hours and even days thinking
about the president's relationship with
monica lewinsky
and explaining it yet again to their
children
placing these videotapes into the formal
record of this trial will be one step
closer to releasing the tapes to the
public for immediate broadcast
and if that release occurs it will
produce an avalanche of unwelcome
deposition testimony
into the public domain
the videotape testimony of ms lewinsky
mr jordan and mr blumenthal will be
forced hour after hour
unbidden and uninvited into the living
rooms and family rooms of the nation
make no mistake about what will happen
we've seen it before
we can expect to see the networks play
these tapes wall-to-wall non-stop and
without interruption over the airwaves
and as i say this would be a repeat of
what happened
when the case first came to the house of
representatives
for the senate to decide to include the
videotapes of this deposition testimony
as opposed to the written transcripts
in the formal record of this trial
would have the same effect
and could result in this kind of release
the pictures the voices and the words on
these tapes
would flow directly
and irreversibly
into the life of the nation
in addition these videotapes will no
doubt be added edited and excerpted and
cut and spliced
and the materials will not be only
overused they will also be inevitably
abused
to take advantage of these witnesses i
submit to you in this way is wrong
whether in the context of a grand jury
proceeding where confidentiality is
promised or whether testifying under
subpoena
in an impeachment trial in the senate
it's unfair to the witnesses
unfair to the public
unfair to the senate
and we submit unfair to the president as
well
we do not object to the release of the
written transcripts of this testimony we
re we support that release
and we believe that that satisfies any
reasonable requirement for public access
to the information
the public's right to know and to
understand what is happening in this
impeachment trial
would be respected
but we should learn a lesson from
america's experience in the house of
representatives
more is not always
better
it is not right wise nor right for the
house or the senate
to perform the function of a mere
conveyor belt simply and automatically
transmitting unfiltered evidence into
the public
domain it is not
wise or right to suspend judgment and
turnover for public viewing
the video at videotaped testimony of
private witnesses who are forced to
appear and to testify under compulsion
and it is simply wrong to release
videotapes of such testimony for cable
news networks
or for friends or foes to use as they
want and this i submit is profoundly
unfair to the witnesses
one can only ask who really benefits
from this kind of practice
is it really in the public interest
for the senate to issue and serve a
subpoena on private individuals like
monica lewinsky or vernon jordan to
summon these citizens before the senate
to compel their testimony before video
cameras
and then to take
that
videotape testimony
without any consideration or thought
about the legitimate personal concerns
or interests of those witnesses
to release those videotapes of that
testimony to the national media
is it really in ms lewinsky's interest
to do this
is it in the interest of her family or
of her future is it fair to mr jordan
or to his family to subject him to this
kind of treatment
is it really in the senate's interest
is it in the interest of the
constitution or the presidency or the
american people
to have videotape of monica lewinsky
readily available for all the world to
see and to hear
and what about those individuals
who are in fact truly innocent but who
will surely suffer
if these videotapes are released
released to the public
for permanent residence in the public
domain
what about the members of the
president's immediate family
how can the senate contemplate releasing
ms lewinsky's videotape testimony
discussing her relationship with the
president
without giving at least some thought to
the impact that this might have on the
members of the family
you can be sure that the release of this
testimony
and of this videotape
will only add to the agony to the
embarrassment and to the humiliation
and i only hope that those who purport
to be concerned
about the moral damage that can be
attributed to the president's conduct in
the president's example
are equally mindful of the hurt that
will be inflicted on innocent people
by the mere broadcasting of these
videotapes
and their existence in perpetuity
in the public record
and the public domain
we think it has been perfectly
appropriate and no doubt helpful to many
senators and staffers
to be able to watch the deposition
testimony of these three witnesses on
videotape as part of the senate trial
proceeding but that function has now
been satisfied
there is no need for these tapes to be
broadcast to the public
and the public knows better than anyone
it is for that precise reason one
suspects
that three quarters of those polled
according to a survey reported in
yesterday's new york times
oppose releasing the videotaped
testimony of ms lewinsky mr jordan and
mr blumenthal to the public
i would urge you do not vote to place
these materials into the record of this
trial
without giving careful consideration to
these interests and to these concerns
these are not just the interests and
concerns of the president
and the members of his family
they are not just the interests and
concerns of these three witnesses
and the members of their families
i think they're also the interests and
concerns of the american people as well
the bottom line ladies and gentlemen of
the senate is simple
you do not need these videotapes
released to do your constitutional duty
and the people we all work for
do not want these video tapes released
either
please draw the line
now as for the issue of witnesses
we believe that there is no useful
purpose served by calling live witnesses
to testify before the senate in this
trial
live witnesses will not advance the
factual record
we have known the facts for many months
nor will live witnesses give us new
insight into the witnesses themselves
sydney blumenthal's
fourth appearance
vernon jordan's seventh appearance
and monica lewinsky's 23rd appearance
told us really very little that was new
i take issue with the presentation of
the managers
why should we expect mr blumenthal's
fifth appearance mr jordan's eighth
appearance
and ms lewinsky's 24th appearance to add
anything more
live witnesses will simply not serve the
interests of fairness
they will not serve the interests of the
american people
and they will not serve the interests of
the senate
in fact live witness live testimony from
these three individuals or from miss
lewinsky alone
will be worse than an exercise in
redundancy it will be an exercise in
excess
it will only postpone the end of the
trial that nobody wants anymore
and no one wants to prolong any longer
there's every reason finally and at long
last to bring the trial to a close
and calling live witnesses i submit will
not be quick and it will not be easy
it will prevent the senate
from keeping its pledge to bring this
trial to a conclusion
by february 12 by february 12th
because live witnesses are unnecessary
to the resolution of this matter
perhaps the most important question for
the senate to consider and to resolve
for itself
is whether calling live witnesses might
in fact
tarnish the senate as an institution
this is a question that only you can
resolve the members of the senate you
certainly need not take instruction from
me or from any of us at this table on
that subject but the question is worth
asking
will the public's respect for the senate
and for the members of this body be
enhanced by calling live witnesses
does the senate really feel a need
or an obligation or some requirement to
bring ms lewinsky
to sit here and to testify in the well
of this historic chamber
now the managers first argued that live
witnesses were necessary to resolve
conflicts and testimony
that the only way to reconcile
disparities and differences in testimony
was to bring in live witnesses
today we know that is not true you gave
the managers an opportunity to resolve
those conflicts and to find new facts
but most of the critical conflicts that
existed a week ago still exist today
calling monica lewinsky to testify a
fourth a 24th time
is not likely to resolve those conflicts
then we were told that we must look into
the eyes of the witnesses and observe
their demeanor
to make a judgment as to credibility
but you now have had the opportunity to
observe almost every major witness as he
or she testifies
precious little is left the imagination
or the guesswork or the questions of
credibility
and you certainly have a better chance
of observing demeanor through the
videotape than you do with a witness
sitting on the floor of the senate
we are now given a third reason why live
witnesses are absolutely necessary for
this trial to go forward
that is quote to validate unquote the
testimony of these witnesses
according to mr manager hai the
depositions have been successful but
quote what we need now is to validate
the record that already exists under
oath
about obstruction of justice and perjury
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
we on this side
of the house have never challenged that
record we have always agreed
that the witnesses said what the record
says they said
and that record needs no further
validation
through the live testimony
of individual witnesses
those of us who have made a career
out of being lawyers and trying cases
probably understand better than anyone
else why the house managers are so
adamant
in their desire to call live witnesses
it keeps the door open if only for a few
more days
as mr kendall observed last week like mr
micawber from david copperfield they
hope against hope that something may
turn up as an abstract proposition the
importance of live witnesses cannot be
disputed they are important to
prosecutors who are trying to make a
case
they are important to defense lawyers
who are trying to defend the case
trial lawyers know better than anyone
that live witnesses can make all the
difference in a trial there's just no
disputing that point
but that abstract question
is not the real live question that the
senate has before today the issue before
the senate today is different it is more
specific specifically
whether these three witnesses
each one of whom has testified on
multiple occasions under oath before the
federal grand jury
or been interviewed on multiple
occasions by lawyers and law enforcement
officers
would have anything whatsoever to add to
this trial
if they were to appear before you in
person
the answer to that question
is clearly no
the answer is no
not because miss lewinsky has already
been interviewed so many times and has
testified so many times
not because she was just interviewed
a few weekends ago and not because she
appeared and answered the house
manager's questions under oath for many
hours just four days ago the answer is
no because if you watch the video
videotape of her testimony and if you
look at the videotape of the testimony
of mr jordan and mr blumenthal you
realize and you know deep in your bones
that calling these witnesses to testify
personally before you in the senate
in detail
would simply be a massive waste
of this senate's time
you already know the facts
you have already read what they have had
to say on many different occasions and
you've already seen and read their most
recent testimony under oath
it simply can no longer be credibly
argued that you need testimony from
these witnesses to flesh out the factual
record or to resolve conflicts or to
fill in the evidentiary gaps or to look
the witnesses in the eyes and assess
their credibility
all that has been done many times before
by many lawyers before and by many law
enforcement officers many months ago
and then it was done just recently again
by house managers as they took
deposition testimony last week
the senate has given the managers every
opportunity to persuade the senate and
the nation to see this case
the same way they see it
and the managers have run a vigorous and
energetic campaign aimed at capturing
the senate and a changing american
public opinion
how many trials do you know of where the
prosecutors base their case
on a multi-million dollar criminal
investigation
involving multiple interrogations of
witnesses
producing sixty thousand pages of
documents generating nineteen boxes of
evidence
where the prosecutors are allowed to go
back to those witnesses again and again
and again in an effort maybe somehow
maybe some way
to make their case
cover the same territory present the
same present the same evidence hour
after hour
in fact
in our view
the senate has indulged the managers
and despite the misgivings of many
senators
the senate has leaned over backwards to
accommodate the managers
we believe it is time for the senate to
say
it's time to vote
given the state of the record compiled
by the office of independent counsel
given the discovery that has already
been given
to the managers
the evidence is as it is
and it's not likely to change in any
significant way
the moment of truth can no longer be
avoided
and the senate should move to make his
decision
president clinton is not guilty of
having committed high crimes and
misdemeanors
he should not be removed from office
the senate must act now to end this
impeachment trial finally and for all
time
now finally as to the proposed
proceeding for saturday
senate resolution 30 gives the house
managers and white house counsel
an opportunity to quote make a
presentation to the senate
employing all or portions of the
videotape of the deposition testimony
and the final portion of the motion
involves a request that the parties be
permitted to present before the senate
for a period of time not to exceed a
total of six hours equally divided
all
or portions of the parts of the
videotapes
of the oral depositions of ms lewinsky
mr jordan
and sidney blumenthal
that have been admitted into evidence
we are convinced
that such a presentation would provide
no new information to the senate
and would only serve
to delay this trial
and further burden the service of the
senate
we also believe that there's a potential
for unfairness
that lurks in the process of excerpting
and presenting portions of videotape
testimony out of context
we remain committed to the notion that
to be fair to all sides
the videotapes if they're used must be
shown in their entirety are shown not at
all
and above all we do not believe
these videotapes should be released
to the public in any form which would of
course occur if they were used in as
part of the presentation on saturday
senators have themselves been reviewing
the videotape deposition testimony of
the three witnesses at great length and
in great detail
over the past four days
it appears to us that the senate has
been very conscientious in carrying out
this assignment
and within a matter of days senators
will listen to final arguments from each
side
is there really a need for an
intermediate stage
involving
the playing of videotape testimony of
the very same evidence
after being conscientious and reviewing
the videotape testimony and reading the
transcripts of that testimony
should senators now be required to sit
and watch and listen to more of the same
such an exercise would only be
cumulative and causes us to ask what the
point would be
we just don't think that additional
presentations of the same evidence
that senators have been reviewing over
the past few days will be that helpful
to the process
presumably the house managers seek to
present
a collection
of snippets
the greatest hits from the def
deposition testimony of ms lewinsky mr
jordan
and mr blumenthal
this would be unfortunate because it
would require a full response from the
white house presumably our own
collection
of snippets aimed at putting the
managers
excerpts into some kind of
context
this would be a duel
of snippets
and excerpts
and presumably each side in the course
of the presentation
would conduct a guided tour for the
senate through that evidence although i
must say that the language of the motion
leaves that open to some doubt
the language of the motion provides no
opportunity for argument
no opportunity for explanation
and simply talks about
playing a total of six hours equally
divided all or portions of the parts of
the videotapes
is this the kind of way
that your time is best used in this
enterprise enterprise
we fully understand the house manager's
desire and we even share it
to highlight and explain the importance
of certain testimony
that came out of the depositions of the
past few days but in truth
there are no bombshells in that
testimony there is no dynamite
there are no explosions
we believe that highlighting explaining
and calling attention to those parts of
that testimony that is important can be
done with the transcripts
and the transcripts more than satisfy
the requirement
that we see or the need
to conduct that function or to carry out
that function that's what ordinary
lawyers do
when they're trying cases or arguing in
front of a jury
to the extent that the managers wish to
call attention to various aspects of the
testimony we think they'll have ample
time to do so in the course of their
final argument
traditionally that is the time to do
that during closing argument
the time for advocates in a trial to
marshal their evidence to summarize and
to comment on that evidence and to allow
the managers to go through the
deposition testimony first
would be tantamount to giving the
managers two closing arguments
uh in
summary
mr chief justice i have a parliamentary
a point of parliamentary inquiry that i
would like to address to the chair
having to do with the first
paragraph the first section of the
proposed motion submitted by the house
managers is there any way that the
senate
can deal first with the question that
the first question be bifurcated is
there any way that the senate can
bifurcate this first question
and that a separate vote be taken
first on including the transcripts of
the deposition testimony in the record
of the trial
and second on whether the videotapes
should also be included in the record
for that
a preemptive motion to that effect could
be made by any senator
thank you
mr chief justice uh the majority i have
consent that we take a 15-minute recess
and i think maybe we can address this
question during that recess
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
as the senate standing in this short
recess on the third fiction thank you
very much
silver spring maryland yes i'm for
acquittal we all know mr clinton lied
but we don't care as a parent it's my
responsibility to teach my children
morals i'm not looking for to mr clinton
to teach them that
mr chief justice i believe uh
that there's time remaining uh
for
uh
arguments by the white house counsel and
then a conclusion by the house managers
uh after that uh i will make an attempt
to explain
uh to the senate exactly what is in the
motions because there seemed to be some
degree of question about that and then
we'd be prepared to have a series of
votes at that time i still believe that
we should be able to start that around
four o'clock
i yield boy
uh the chair recognized mr craig
since we've completed our presentation
thank you
the house managers have 19 minutes
remaining chair recognize mr bryan
mr chief justice i will respond briefly
and then be followed by mr manager
mccollum who will be followed by mr
manager hutchinson let me talk first
quickly about mr craig's first argument
about
disagreeing on the admission of the
video depositions
he cited the house proceedings and we
want to be clear as to
the our belief of our position in the
house in this process as the accusatory
accusatory branch of the government of
the
of this process
and i think that's the case because we
vote by majority vote
we chose to bring forward the case that
we felt just established the allegations
of impeachment
there was no conflict of evidence
brought forward from those house
proceedings this evidence was not
challenged until we came to this body
the appropriate body for resolving the
evidence and and trying the case as you
will
and that's evidenced by the
constitutional requirement that that you
must
vote for conviction based on two-thirds
of your body
but the actual conflict was not
presented until we arrived here in the
senate and by allowing us to have this
procedure of taking depositions we have
focused more clearly on resolving those
particular conflicts
i might add also
in response to mr craig's statement that
this star report was released out to the
public and and as a result of that there
may be danger here in releasing these
video depositions but let me tell you
about the house vote on the star report
seventy percent of the democrats
supported the release of those documents
one hundred percent of the democrat
leadership in the house supported the
release of those documents so it was not
just one party over the other party that
threw these out to the public it was a
decision that was a bipartisan decision
on the part of the house
and i might add that is not our interest
in in doing this with video depositions
we're open to your process
but we we must conclude by those who
would argue that perhaps you should open
your debate
to the public we we don't see the
consistency in trying to take a very
important part of the evidence in this
case
and and not opening that to the public
so we are we are at your wishes it's
it's our desire to make the presentation
using all our portions of these video
depositions and to to use those as fully
as we would any other evidence and with
that said i would ask mr manager
mccullum to follow me the chair
recognized mr manager mccollum thank you
very much mr chief justice
if you listen to the white house counsel
the simple fact is they don't want
a public display in any form of any
testimony here in front of the senate
they don't want the public to have an
opportunity to have a public trial
now maybe an impeachment trial is not
exactly the same as any other trial but
in the history of the senate it has been
a basically open process except for the
voting it has been an opportunity for
witnesses to come before you it's been
an opportunity for people to be heard
it's been an opportunity for the public
to hear the people who want to speak
white house counsel didn't just say we
don't want live witnesses here they said
we don't want you to be able to admit
even into evidence the videotape that
might become public
and we don't want you to be able to show
any portion or all even of the
videotapes of the depositions that have
been taken
now if a republican had gotten up and
said that
we'd have probably gotten hung on some
political pattern for that
the reality is the public has a business
here this is a trial
i would suggest and submit to you we
need you need the opportunity to hear
these witnesses
one way or the other preferably monica
lewinsky live
we need to bring closure to this matter
how can the public come to closure
how can those who feel so emotionally as
we know they do around the country come
to closure on this which we need for
them to do as much as you need to
resolve and we need to have you resolve
the questions before you
how can they come to closure how can we
all come to closure without an
opportunity for the public to
participate in one way or another in
seeing the credibility
judging the witnesses judging the truth
of this
let me uh remind you there is nothing in
these depositions that contains any
salacious material
so it's been constrained
very delicately
nothing at all
that would be offensive to anybody
in addition
think about this for a minute when it
comes to calling monica lewinsky live
when it comes to letting the depositions
be presented
if you
believe that the president did not
break the law we're not talking about
whether he should be removed from office
if you believe he did not break the law
that he did not commit the crimes of
perjury and obstruction of justice
that means
you must have concluded
that monica lewinsky is not telling the
truth
when she said
about the false affidavit i knew what he
meant
when she said about the concealment of
the gifts
betty call me
when she says about the nature of the
relationship it began the night we met
and many other things
you i would submit my colleagues in the
senate have a moral obligation
to allow monica lewinsky to come here
and be judged on her credibility not
just by you but by the public by all of
us as a live witness
and certainly barring that you have an
obligation to have the credibility on
the issues of guilt or innocence of
these crimes be judged
by everybody at the very least by the
presentation of these videos in a public
open format here in the senate before
everybody and i think it's a powerful
question you have to resolve and i'd
submit one last point for those of you
who do believe
the president is guilty of these crimes
you have an obligation
to let the showing of these depositions
or the presentation preferably of monica
lewinsky live to be here so those who
maybe don't think the same way you do
have an opportunity for that credibility
to be judged only if the witness is
present can they be judged that way the
most remarkable thing about the white
house presentation may have been just a
moment ago the admission
that normally in trials this is exactly
what happens
and i present to you the suggestion this
is exactly what should happen here today
and yield to manager hutchins
the chair recognizes manager hutchinson
thank you mr chief justice very briefly
i was asked to respond to the last
argument by the council for the
president regard to their objections on
the evidentiary presentation
of six hours under the motion which
would be i believe on saturday
after six days of opening statement
in this trial and after two days of
question and answers
and then we had i believe two days of
motion arguments you've heard from all
the lawyers more than you ever wanted to
hear
and i don't think that it is too much to
ask for six hours of discussion of the
evidentiary record that was developed
from the deposition testimony i think
that's reasonable
it's been argued that well
you know it's going to be snippets it's
going to be a battle of snippets
it's
if this motion is passed would be
introduced into evidence and then each
side will have an opportunity to discuss
that evidence to contrast it with other
individuals testimony and to
present it in a fashion that is most
understandable it is equally divided
therefore both sides can present
the case that is how it is traditionally
done there's nothing unusual about that
and certainly
the white house defense lawyers will be
very
vigilant in making sure that it is
fairly uh presented there was objection
that's made and this is overlapping a
little bit as to the
public release the video our motion
really goes to introducing into evidence
it is up to you as to how that evidence
is handled customarily in a trial when
something's entered into evidence there
that is uh released but there was
concern expressed about the witnesses
about mr jordan and the fact that he is
uh he has testified and now it would be
made public i recall uh the white house
defense lawyers on this screen over here
put mr jordan's video
up there for the world to see
i believe they also brought in other
witnesses in video
that was put out there for the whole
world to see and so i think it's a
little bit late to come in and say that
that should not be subject uh to public
discussion
and so i think that
uh
the motion that is presented is
reasonable that is fair they say that
there's nothing of dynamite or there's
nothing explosive well then if that's
the case there should not be any
objection to a discussion and a fair
plain of that evidence but in fact
much of this is new because it was not
developed after the president made his
grand jury appearance
many of these witnesses testified early
they were not able to
testify again after the president's
grand jury testimony and so i think
there's new areas that have certainly
been developed and with that mr chief
justice i yield back
will the house managers yield back
the chair recognize the majority leader
mr chief justice uh then all time has
been yielded back on both sides
[Music]
we had expected that this would take a
little bit longer
i missed chief justice i believe that it
would be
of interest to to the senators that we
give just a brief explanation of the
motions i believe senator daschle may
have an additional motion that he would
like to offer so uh so that we can make
sure he's had the time to prepare that
and how we would uh
go into the voting procedure i observe
the absence of court
the clerk will call the roll
mr abraham
mr akaka
we're going to take this opportunity as
the senate in a quorum call to again
open our phone lines
202-624-1111 is the line if you are for
acquittal of the president 202 64 11 15.
you've decided you are for conviction
we're not sure how long this quorum call
may last it may only be a few moments
but we'll have an opportunity to get in
as many calls as we can at the time when
the senators come back they'll be
talking about a motion by house managers
that has three parts one would admit
depositions into evidence the second
part would have monica lewinsky appear
on the senate floor as a witness and the
third is regarding the presentation of
evidence including showing segments of
the videotaped depositions from earlier
in the week chicago good afternoon
yes i'm for acquittal explain to us why
because i think that president clinton
should not be removed because he lied
about a sexual affair
i think the republicans have been after
him for years
and i think it's ridiculous to remove a
president for lying about a sexual
affair
next call is it pronounced
turton south dakota
yes oh good afternoon hi
tell us why you're for conviction why am
for conviction
because the president
lied to everyone
and he's supposed to set a good example
for our children for the american people
and i think he is a scumbag illiterate
again a reminder if you are on hold when
the senate comes back in we invite you
to join us in other breaks
and we aren't sure how long the quorum
call will last san diego good afternoon
good afternoon
i'm calling for acquittal yes tell us
why
i because i think the
republicans have been on a vendetta to
get clinton since he's been in office
they've tried everything they could they
spent millions of dollars trying it
finally on some illegal really
technicality into his personal life they
got this
stupid thing which has no business
being on television in the first place
i also think that uh
linda tripp is an equal with larry flint
if not worse
and i think that i think the republicans
have really done themselves a
great disservice
by pulling this whole thing off thank
you
milton delaware yes um for conviction
and i'd like to point out for those who
say that it's
a republican vendetta
it's to their disadvantage
to
convict
because it gives mr gore the
advantage of incumbency in 2000
also
it's not about a sex case
it's because
paula jones
rights in her case
were
changed by what he did
and
what
might have been different in that case
had this been originally in
also
i feel that he uh
he's dropping a bomb on saturn for lion
and doesn't he deserve at least removal
for lyon
long beach california yes sir i'm
calling for acquittal
and i'd like to know where all these
die-harded republicans were
when the
they had the contrast for reagan and
bush line read my lips that he lied like
hell to the
nation
and also
oliver north getting away with it i'm
really surprised that these people
are taking this thing so seriously like
that and it to me it's nothing but a sex
problem which it should be nothing but
in the presence between him and his
family and nobody else unless the first
one that has no sin cast the stone
lady lake florida good afternoon good
afternoon
i'm for conviction
and
my reasoning is i feel like the morality
of the country is is far greater than
letting this man get by
with uh all these other
senators and the people running for
president what are they going to be able
to do
and i think it's in the good of the
country to be convicted
thanks florida as you call in on these
two lines remember this isn't a poll per
se we're not only interested in what you
think but why you've reached your
conclusions
houston
good afternoon
good afternoon
i'm calling from houston and i you do
not have an undecided line but that is
why i was calling in
we have not had cable until just
recently only because we couldn't get
anything on the regular um national
networks
and i haven't seen enough
or hurt enough yet to be completely
convinced either way and i would like to
see the live witnesses
i just feel like that that way i could
decide one way or the other
and i thank you very much i i do want to
say one thing
that we were able um
you know to watch all of the nixon
proceedings because they were televised
and they were televised on all the
national networks if you recall
and
so we were better informed and i don't
know why that's been handled the way it
has this time
thanks houston very much detroit good
afternoon
hello
i'm very much for conviction we're a
country of laws and uh if president
clinton is allowed to get away with this
we will no longer be a country of laws
uh the ordinary citizens are
expected to mr biden live within the
laws of this country but president
clinton has gotten away with this way
back to arkansas and i'm very very upset
to think that he might get away with
this and we really demand to know the
truth
so he he prevented paula jones from
having her case told
and
now he
feels that he should have the right to
defend himself but that is not true
youngstown ohio
good afternoon
and in my opinion
the only facts
the house of representatives can come up
with
is that you do not need proof to impeach
a president
all you need is for the majority to
stick together
and then they call it nonpartisan
when any representative
says he doesn't care what the majority
of his constituents wants
then i think they are the ones that
should be removed
and bumpers when he says that
if something
is not about money and it usually is
then you have house manager hudson
when he says something is nonpartisan
it usually is
pounding mill virginia hi there hi i've
been trying ever since this stupid thing
started
uh to get a hold of you you know uh the
the trouble with the people of this
country they blame the uh police
department you know the law they blame
the government for everything that goes
wrong but yet they'll turn their backs
to something that needs to be
uh taken care of
uh when they lie
that's a crime because he done it under
oath and he is no better than i am
and uh i feel like the people of this
country ought to open their eyes i'm a
democrat but i feel like the republicans
are getting a raw deal from everybody in
the country that's calling and putting
them down they're doing a
good job to put their jobs on the line
for us
brighton colorado hello hi you're taking
my call
uh i don't i think the case should be
either voted for acquittal or dismiss
the case for lack of evidence
first of all the president didn't lie to
me and my wife we have the same
definition of sexual relations as he
said when he said he did not have
sexual relations with that women
and also a survey was done with college
students i think in 1990 or 91
and they did not define sexual relations
except the way the president did and
also monica has the same definition
so to me it was not a lie to the people
and there are there are people that it's
more about hate than it is sex
and it's more about hate than anything
else they're about 24 to 29 of the
people that hate bill clinton and they
hate hillary clinton and they've been
out to get them or harassed them or
embarrassed them since 1992.
thanks colorado san antonio
uh yes
am i on yes ma'am
yes i'm for conviction
i really do wish america would wake up
and listen
and read the paper and listen to the
television and read everything so
carefully
this man is a liar
he's a definite liar
and he should be he he should be
convicted
i
i just can't express it
enough
midland michigan hello i'm coming from
midland michigan my name's helen and uh
i heard everybody calling in to equip
the president and i agree with them but
one question i have never heard
that anybody asked why did paul jones
wait until
one day before the seven years
was up to file her case
and on the line for conviction kissimmee
florida
yes
i
they keep saying this some people keep
saying this is about sex if it was about
sex let me tell you something they
should hang him in the courtyard
i started working
when
we women were treated like dogs
somehow someway
in this old age we've reached the stage
where they're not we're not treated that
way anymore this is put us back don't
kid yourself girls
your children and you are going to have
to pay for this
and
if the republicans would go ahead and
say
okay we're going to vote to put you out
of office
they say that it's going to be against
you
vote your conscience man have the guts
to stand up there and say this is it
we're going to put you out
it may
it just may backfire on you
thank you florida for your points
wheeling illinois
hello hi
uh i'm for acquittal because i believe
the whole thing is not about clinton but
i think it's it's the right-wing
takeover of america look at heights
group like barr and some of the other
guys these are guys that spoke for in in
nazi groups these guys are the real
traitors not clinton
we gotta have to get rid of these
traitors
san antonio yes i'm for conviction
i feel that um
law of the land says that perjury is a
felony not only do i think
clinton should be
impeached
after he's impeached and out of office i
think he should be taken to court
and the appropriate sentence should be
passed
thank you texas the senate in a quorum
call after hearing
about an hour from each side an hour
from the house managers in an hour from
the president's council on a motion by
house managers that's in three parts the
first would enter depositions as
evidence and those definitions are the
transcripts of course and the video
tapes the second part of this would be
to call monica lewinsky to testify on
the senate floor and the third part
would be to present portions of the
taped depositions as part of the
presentation of evidence in a six hour
period that would come up later that
both sides would have the six hours and
the ability to use portions of those
tape depositions there will be at least
three votes on these three measures
we're also expecting another vote this
afternoon senator daschle expected to
offer a motion to go straight to the
articles of impeachment for an up or
down vote that all coming up this
afternoon here on c-span 2.
and we may have time as this quorum call
continues for another
call or two denver good afternoon hello
my name's chris um the problem with
senators returned to their desk
well it's probably not a bad thing but
but it's very different from the court
yes yes it is
the chair recognizes the majority
leader mr chief justice uh i asked and
sent the quorum call be dispensed with
in the absence of an objection it's so
ordered
mr chief justice just very briefly i
believe that uh
daschle or
one of his senators will have
a peremptory motion that they would
offer and then uh it would be read
by the clerk
and then uh following and then a vote uh
on that
and then a vote on
the three divisions that have been
identified to three motions
or three votes of the one motion and
then i believe senator daschle would
also have a motion that would go
straight to
debate and closing arguments and a vote
on the articles of impeachment is that
correct recitation
i appreciate the senator yielding
as i understand it senator murray's
motion
will relate to the third motion
which would
which is as i understand it the motion
that allows for video excerpts to be
used her motion would restrict both
managers to
transcripts
written transcripts so i'm not sure in
which order her motion should be
offered but uh since it relates to the
third one perhaps it would be in concert
with that motion
so mr chief justice then we would vote
on the uh the first paragraph the second
paragraph and then there would be a
motion at that point by senator murray
then a vote on that and a vote then on
the third division and then a vote on
the article's impeachment itself
okay
the the question is on the
division one
uh should the clerk read the division
read the thing the clerk will read the
division one
the house news that the transcriptions
and videotapes of the oral depositions
taken pursuant to senate resolution 30
from the point that each witness is
sworn to testify under oath to the end
of any direct response to the last
question posed by a party be admitted
into evidence
the yeas and nasa required the clerk
will call the roll mr abraham
mr abraham i
mr akaka
mr allard
mr allard
i mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft i
mr bacchus
mr bacchus
i
mr bai
mr bai
i mr bennett
mr bennett
i mr biden
mr bengamon
mr bingaman i
[Music]
mr bond
mr bond
i
this is boxer
this is boxer
i mr bro
mr bro
i mr brownback
mr brownback aye mr bryan
mr brian
i mr bunning
mr bunning aye mr burns
mr burns i mr
bird mr bird
i mr campbell
mr campbell
i mr chafee
mr chafee
i
mr cleland
mr cochrane
mr cochrane
i
miss collins
ms collins i mr conrad
mr conrad i mr coverdell
mr coverdell
i mr craig
mr craig
i mr crapo
mr crapo
i mr daschle
mr daschle
i mr dewine
mr dewine
i mr dodd
mr dodd
i mr domenici
mr domenici
i mr dorgan
mr dorgan
aye mr durbin
mr durbin
aye mr edwards
mr edwards
aye mr enzi
mr nz
i
mr feingold
mr feingold
i mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein i
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald i mr frist
mr frist
i mr gorton
mr gorton
i mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida
i
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas i mr grahams of
minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota aye mr grassley
mr grassley aye mr gregg
mr greg
aye mr hagel
mr hagel i mr harkin
mr harkin
i
mr hatch
mr hatch
aye mr helms
mr helms i mr hollings
mr hollings aye mr hutchinson of
arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
i
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas
i mr enhoff
mr inhofe i mr inouye
mr in no way i mr jeffers
mr jeffords i mr johnson
mr johnson i mr kennedy
mr kennedy i mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska i mr kerry of
massachusetts
mr cole
mr cole
i mr kyle
mr kyle
i miss landrieu
ms landrieu
i mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg aye mr leahy
mr leahy aye mr
levin mr levin i mr lieberman
mr lieberman i mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln aye mr
lott mr lot i mr luger
mr luger i mr mack
mr mack i mr mccain
mr mccain
i mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell i miss mikulski
ms mikulski aye mr moynihan
mr moynihan
i mr murkowski
mr murkowski
i mrs murray
mrs murray
i mr nichols
mr nichols
i mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada i mr rob
mr rob
i mr roberts
mr roberts aye mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller i mr roth
mr roth
i mr santorum
mr santorum
i
mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes aye mr schumer
mr schumer
aye mr sessions
mr sessions
aye mr shelby
mr shelby
i mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire i mr smith of
oregon
mr smith of oregon i miss snow
ms snow
i
mr specter
mr specter i
mr stevens
mr stevens i mr thomas
mr thomas i mr thompson
mr thompson aye mr thurman
mr thurmand i
mr torricelli
mr torricelli
i mr voinovich
mr voinovich
i mr warner
mr warner
i mr wellstone
mr wellstone i mr wyden
mr wyden i
mr akaka
mr akaka
i
mr kerry of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts
i
mr biden
mr biden i
so
mr cleland mr cleland
i
so
[Music]
okay
okay on this vote the a's are 100 the
nays are zero division one of the motion
is agreed to
the next vote will be on division two of
the motion the clerk will read the mo to
read division two of the motion division
two the house further moves that the
senate authorized and issue a subpoena
for the appearance
of monica s lewinsky before the senate
for a period of time not to exceed eight
hours and in connection with that the
examination of that witness the house
request that either party be able to
examine the witness as if the witness
were declared adverse that counsel for
the president and counsel for the house
managers be able to participate in the
examination of that witness
and that the house be entitled to
reserve a portion of its examination
time to re-examine the witness following
any examination by the president
the yeas and nays are automatic the
clerk will call the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham aye
mr akaka
mr akaka
no
mr allard
mr allard
no
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft
i
mr baucus
mr baucus no
mr bai
mr bai
no
mr bennett
mr bennett
no
mr biden
mr biden no
mr bingaman
mr bingaman no
mr bond
mr bond
i
mrs boxer
mrs boxer
no
mr bro
mr bro
no
mr brownback
mr brownback no
mr brian
mr brian no
mr bunny
mr bunning i
mr burns
mr burns i
mr bird
mr bird no
mr campbell
mr campbell no mr chafee
mr chafee
no
mr cleland
mr cleland no mr cochran
mr cochran
aye
ms collins
ms collins no
mr conrad
mr conrad no mr coverdale
mr coverdale no
mr craig
mr craig i
mr crapo
mr crapo aye mr daschle
mr daschle no
mr dewine
mr
i
mr dodd
mr dodd no
mr domenici
mr domenici no mr dorgan
mr dorgan no
mr durbin
mr durbin no mr edwards
mr edwards no
mr enzi
mr nz
no
mr feingold
mr feingold no
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein no
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald i
mr frist
mr frist i
mr gorton
mr gorton no
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida no mr graham of
texas
mr graham of texas i
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota aye mr
grassley mr grassley no
mr greg
mr greg
no
mr hegel
mr hegel i mr harkin
mr harkin no mr hatch
mr hatch aye
mr helms
mr helms i
mr hollings
mr hollings
no mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas aye
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas no mr inhofe
inhofe i
mr in nowhere
mr in no way
no
mr jeffords
mr jeffords no
mr johnson
mr johnson no
mr kennedy
mr kerry of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska no
mr carey of massachusetts mr kerry of
massachusetts no mr cole
mr cole no
mr kyle
mr kyle
aye
ms landrieu
ms landrieu no
mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg no mr leahy
mr leahy
no mr
levin mr eleven no mr lieberman
mr lieberman no
mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln no
mr lot
mr lot
i
mr luger
mr luger i mr mack
mr mack aye mr mccain
mr mccain i
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell aye
ms mikulski
ms mikulski
no mr moynihan
mr moynihan no
mr murkowski
mr murkowski
i
mrs murray
mrs murray
no
mr nichols
mr nichols aye mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island no mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada no mr robb
mr robb no
mr roberts
mr roberts no
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller no
mr roth
mr roth no
mr santorum
mr santorum
i mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes
no
mr schumer
mr schumer no
mr sessions
mr sessions no
mr shelby
mr shelby no
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire
aye mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon no
ms snow
ms snow no
mr spector
mr spector
i
mr stevens
mr stevens no mr thomas
mr thomas no mr thompson
mr thompson
i
mr thurman
mr thurman
no
mr torricelli
torricelli no
mr vornovich
mr vornovich no mr warner
mr warner no mr wellstone
mr wellstone no mr wyden
mr wyden no
mr kennedy
mr kennedy
oh
so
the senate will be in order
on this vote the yeas are 30 the nays
are 70. division two of the motion is
not agreed to
the chair recognizes the senator from
washington is murray
mr chief justice i send a substitute for
division three to the desk
the clerk will report
the senator from washington mrs murray
moves that the following shall be
substituted the senate will be in order
that the following shall be substituted
for division three
a move that the parties be permitted to
present before the senate for a period
of time not to exceed a total of six
hours equally divided all portions
all or portions of the parts of the
written transcriptions of the
depositions of monica s lewinsky bernie
jordan jr and sidney blumenthal
on this on this motion
no we already is is that
well the parliamentary advises me that
there are two hours of argument on this
motion
who who's the proponent uh
yes
chief justice i'd ask you consent that
the emotions be yielded or the time to
yield it back
without objection it's so ordered
uh should the the i i think the the
clerk should read division three having
read the the proposed substitute
the house further moves that the parties
be permitted to present before the
senate for a period of time not to
exceed a total of six hours equally
divided all or portions of the parts of
the videotapes of the oral depositions
of monica s lewinsky vernon e jordan jr
and sydney blumenthal admitted into
evidence and that the house be entitled
to reserve a portion of its presentation
time
we'll read the substitute again
i move that the parties be permitted to
present before the senate for a period
of time not to exceed a total of six
hours equally divided
all or portions of the parts of the
written transcriptions of the
depositions of monica s lewinsky vernon
e jordan jr and sydney blumenthal
the yeas and nays are automatic the
question is on the substitute
the clerk will call the roll mr abraham
mr abraham no
mr akaka
mr akaka i
mr allard
mr allard no mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft
no mr bacchus
mr baucus no
mr bai
mr bai
no
mr bennett
mr bennett
no
mr biden
mr biden i
mr bingaman
mr bingaman
i
mr bond
mr bond
no
mrs boxer
this is boxer i
mr bro
mr bro
no
mr brownback
mr brownback
no
mr brian
mr brian
no mr bunning
mr bunning
no
mr burns
mr burns no
mr bird
mr bird
no
mr campbell
mr campbell aye
mr chafee
mr chafee
no
mr cleland
mr cleland
no
mr cochran
mr cochran
no
ms collins
ms collins
no mr conrad
mr conrad i
mr coverdell
mr coverdell
no
mr craig
mr craig
no mr crapo
mr crapo
no mr daschle
mr daschle i
mr dewine
mr dewine
no mr dodd
mr dodd
i mr domenici
mr domenici
no mr dorgan
mr dorgan
aye mr
durbin mr durbin
no
mr edwards
mr edwards
no
mr enzi
mr enzi
no
mr feingold
mr feingold no
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein no
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald no
mr frist
mr frist
no mr gorton
mr gorton no
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida no
mr graham of texas
mr graham of texas no mr grahams of
minnesota
mr grahams of minnesota no
mr grassley
mr grassley no mr greg
mr greg
no mr hegel
mr hegel
no
mr harkin
mr harkin i mr hatch
mr hatch
no mr helms
mr helms no
mr hollings
mr hollings no
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas
no
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutcherson of texas
no
mr enhoff
mr enhoff
no
mr
mr
inoa
no way
i mr jeffords
mr jeffords no
mr johnson
mr johnson
i mr kennedy
mr kennedy
i
mr carey of nebraska
mr kerry of nebraska
i
mr carey of massachusetts
mr cole
mr cole
no
mr kyle
mr kyle
no
ms landrieu
ms landrieu i mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg aye
mr leahy
mr leahy
no mr levin
mr levin i mr lieberman
mr lieberman
no mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln
i mr lot
mr lot no mr luger
mr luger no mr mack
mr mack
no
mr mccain
mr mccain
no mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell
no ms mikulski
ms mikulski
i mr moynihan
mr moynihan
no
mr murkowski
mr murkowski
no mrs murray
mrs murray
i mr nichols
mr nichols no mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada aye mr rob
mr rob
aye mr roberts
mr roberts
no mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller i mr roth
mr roth
no mr santorum
mr santorum
no mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes aye mr schumer
mr schumer
no mr sessions
mr sessions
no mr shelby
mr shelby no mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire no mr smith of
oregon
mr smith of oregon no
ms snow
ms snow
i
mr specter
mr specter
no mr stevens
mr stevens no mr thomas
mr thomas
no mr thompson
mr thompson
no mr thurman
mr thurmand no mr torricelli
mr torricelli
aye mr vojnovich
mr voynovich
no mr
warner mr warner
no mr wellstone
mr wellstone
no mr wyden
mr wyden
no mr kerry of massachusetts
mr carey of massachusetts
no
[Music]
on this vote the yeaser 27 the nays are
73 and the motion is not agreed to
the vote is now on division three of the
motion the clerk will read division
three
division three the house further moves
that the parties be permitted to present
before the senate for a period of time
not to exceed a total of six hours
equally divided all or portions of the
parts of the videotapes of the oral
depositions of monica s lewinsky vernon
e jordan jr
and sydney blumenthal admitted into
evidence and that the house be entitled
to reserve a portion of its presentation
time
the a's and nays are automatic the clerk
will call the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham aye
mr akaka
mr akaka no
mr allard
mr allard
i mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft i mr baucus
mr baucus no
mr bai
mr bai
no mr bennett
mr bennett aye mr biden
mr biden no
mr bingaman
mr bingaman no mr bond
mr bond i
mrs boxer
mrs boxer no
mr bro
mr bro
i
mr brownback
mr brownback
i
mr brian
mr brian i
mr bunning
mr bunning i
mr burns
mr burns aye
mr bird
mr bird i
mr campbell
mr campbell aye
mr chafee
mr chafee aye
mr cleland
mr cleland no
mr cochran
mr cochran aye
ms collins
ms collins i
mr conrad
mr conrad no mr coverdale
mr coverdale aye mr craig
mr craig
i mr crapo
mr crapo aye mr daschle
mr daschle no mr dewine
mr dewan
aye mr dodd
mr dodd no mr domenici
mr domenici aye mr
mr dorgan no mr durbin
mr durbin no mr edwards
mr edwards no mr enzi
mr nz i mr feingold
mr feingold i
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein i
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald i
mr frist
mr frist i
mr gorton
mr gorton aye
mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida no mr graham of
texas
mr graham of texas aye mr grahams of
minnesota
mr graham's of minnesota aye mr grassley
mr grassley aye mr greg
mr greg aye mr hagel aye
mr hagel aye mr harkin
mr harkin no
mr hatch
mr hatch aye
mr helms
mr helms i
mr hollins
mr hollings i
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas i mrs
hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas i mr inhofe
mr inhofe aye mr inouye
mr in no way no mr jeffords
mr jeffords no mr johnson
mr johnson no mr kennedy
mr kennedy no mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska no mr carey of
massachusetts
mr
cole mr cole
no
mr kyle
mr kyle aye
ms landrieu
ms landrieu no mr lautenberg
lautenberg no
mr leahy
mr leahy no mr levin
mr levin no mr lieberman
mr lieberman i
mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln no
mr lot
mr lot i mr luger
mr luger i mr mack
mr mack i
mr mccain
mr mccain i mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell i miss mikulski
ms mikulski no mr moynihan
mr moynihan i
mr murkowski
mr murkowski
aye mrs murray
mrs murray no mr nichols
mr nichols i
mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island no
mr reed of nevada
mr reed of nevada no
mr robb
mr rob no mr roberts
mr roberts i
mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller no mr roth
mr roth
i
mr santorum
mr santorum
aye mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes no mr schumer
mr schumer no
mr sessions
mr sessions
aye mr shelby
mr shelby aye mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire i
mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon i miss snow
miss snow
no
mr specter
mr specter i
mr stevens
mr stevens i mr thomas
mr thomas i
mr thompson
mr thompson i
mr thurman
mr thurman i mr torricelli
mr torricelli no
mr voinovich
mr vornovich
aye mr warner
mr warner aye mr wellstone
mr wellstone i mr wyden
mr wyden i
mr kerry of massachusetts
mr kerry of massachusetts no
mr chief justice
the chair recognizes the senator from
california i um voted in error i wish to
change my vote to a no
very
in the well of objection it is so
ordered
mrs feinstein no
on this vote the yeas are 62
the nays are 38
division 3 of the motion is agreed to
yeah
the chair recognized the minority leader
the clerk will report the motion
[Applause]
the center of south dakota mr daschle
news that the senate now proceed to
closing arguments that there be two
hours for the white house council
followed by two hours for the house
managers and that at the conclusion of
this time the senate proceed to vote on
each of the articles without intervening
action motion or debate except for
deliberations if so decided by the
senate as chief justice the the minority
leader i ask unnamed consent that all
time be yielded back
in the absence of objection it is so
ordered
the yeas and nays are automatic the
clerk will call the roll
mr abraham
no
mr akaka
mr akaka aye mr allard
mr allard
no mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft
no mr bacchus
mr bacchus i
mr bai
mr bai
i
mr bennett
mr bennett
the senate will be in order
mr bennett no
mr biden
biden i
mr bengamon
mr bingaman
aye mr bond
mr bond
no
mrs boxer
mrs boxer i mr bro
mr bro
i
mr brownback
mr brownback
no
mr brian
mr brian
aye mr bunning
mr bunning
no mr burns
mr burns
no
mr bird
mr bird
aye mr campbell
mr campbell
no mr chafee
mr chafee
no mr cleland
mr cleland i
mr cochran
mr cochrane
no ms collins
ms collins no mr conrad
mr conrad i
mr coverdell
mr coverdell
no mr craig
mr craig
no mr crapo
mr crapo
no mr daschle
mr daschle
i mr dewine
mr dewine
no mr dodd
mr dodd
i mr domenici
mr domenici
no mr dorgan
mr dorgan aye mr durbin
mr durbin aye mr edwards
mr edwards i mr nz
mr nz
no mr feingold
mr feingold
no
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
i
mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald no mr frist
mr frist
no mr gorton
gorton
no mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida i mr graham of
texas
mr graham of texas no mr grahams of
minnesota
mr grams of minnesota no mr grassley
mr grassley no mr greg
mr greg
no mr hegel
mr hegel no mr harkin
mr harkin i
mr hatch
mr hatch no mr helms
mr helms no mr hollings
mr hollings i mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas no
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas no
mr inhofe
mr enhoff
no mr inoa
mr
i
noah
jeffords
mr jeffords no mr johnson
mr johnson aye mr kennedy
mr kennedy i mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska
aye mr kerry
dr mcconnell
mr mcconnell no ms mikulski
ms mikulski i mr moynihan
mr moynihan i
mr murkowski
mr murkowski no
mrs murray
this is murray
i mr nichols
mr nichols no mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada
i mr rob
mr rob
i mr roberts
mr roberts no mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller i
mr roth
mr roth no mr santorum
mr santorum no mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes aye
mr schumer
mr schumer i mr sessions
mr sessions no
mr shelby
mr shelby
no mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire
no mr smith of oregon
mr smith of oregon
no
ms snow
ms snow
no
mr specter
mr specter
no mr stevens
mr stevens no mr thomas
mr thomas
no mr thompson
mr thompson
no mr thurman
mr thurmond
no mr torricelli
mr torricelli
i mr voinovich
mr voynovich no mr warner
mr warner
no mr wellstone
mr wellstone
i mr wyden
mr wyden
i
on this vote the yeas are 44 the nays
are 56 and the motion is not agreed to
the chair uh the chair recognized the
majority leader uh mischief justice i
believe that was uh the last of the
motions that had been uh offered i'm
ready to go to the closing uh script
unless there's some other motion
pending or to be offered
just a moment to consult
my as chief justice for indulgence for
just a couple of minutes to consult with
my colleagues mr chief justice uh i
deserve the absence of a quorum
the clerk will call the role
mr abraham
foreign
oh
[Music]
mr akaka
mr allard
on this the 13th day of the impeachment
trial of the president of the united
states the senate just completed a
series of five votes the next steps in
this process the first of those five was
whether or not to admit the depositions
into evidence that was both transcripts
and the videotape and that passed 100 to
nothing unanimously
the next vote was whether or not to call
monica lewinsky to the senate floor to
be a witness there and that failed the
vote was 30 to 70.
then there were two votes that had to do
with the presentation of the uh evidence
from the uh from the um
depositions and there was a motion to
present the transcripts only that failed
27 to 73 and then the next motion was to
present the transcripts including the
video that passed 62-38
this series of five votes concluded with
a motion by senate democratic leader tom
daschle to proceed directly to closing
debate that failed on virtually a
party-line vote of 44-56
as this quorum call continues we're
expecting the senate once they're back
in session to be there just for a short
time as you heard senator lott say he
referred to his concluding script to
conclude things for the day and senate
will be out of session
for the rest of today once today's
session is over not in session on friday
back for six hours on saturday for those
closing arguments three hours by each
side by the house managers and the
president's council we don't know how
long this quorum call will last while it
isn't
is taking a quorum call we'll take your
phone calls and when the session is over
we'll continue with your calls we're
curious on what decision you've reached
whether you're for acquittal or for
conviction the area code is 202 and 624
11 11 is the number if you're for
acquittal and 624-1115
if you decided you are for conviction if
you're on hold when the senate comes
back stick with us we'll be back to your
calls momentarily rice washington good
afternoon
hi um i'm for acquittal
and um i i really think that it's all a
sexual thing um
and i really don't believe anyone should
be prosecuted for being a sexual person
um
i don't think that we we have a
politician in office who hasn't
compromised him or herself in one way or
the other
while they're in office
and
i don't think i'd want a leader who
could not
tell a lie i mean the things that a
leader has to do
to to lead a country
um
i don't think i would have the strength
to do it or have the strength of
convictions to do it
um i i just really think they ought to
just go ahead and vote to get this over
with and put it behind us and let's move
on
phoenix good afternoon good afternoon
um
i'm for conviction for three reasons
first of all despite claims by the white
house counsel to the contrary nothing in
the record refutes the house manager's
argument
that the evidence already in the record
and reasonable inference drawn from it
proved the president to be guilty of the
crimes outlined in the article's
impeachment
secondly
any argument that perjury and
obstruction of justice by the president
do not justify his removal from office
is blasted
any violation of federal law is a crime
against the united states and therefore
is a high crime and misdemeanor
and thirdly regardless of the repeated
cries by the president's supporters to
listen to the will of the american
people
this country is a constitutional
republic not a democracy would senators
return to their desks
the senate will be in order
let's chief justice uh the majority has
the quorum call be dispensed with
and without objection it's so ordered
that's chief justice i believe that the
uh it is in order for the white house
council to offer motion at this point uh
and uh if they wish to do so then i
believe uh they could and then we would
vote on that motion
uh the chair recognizes uh mr white
house counsel ruff thank you mr chief
justice mr majority leader uh
i'd like to hand up to the desk
a brief motion dealing with the
presentation of videotape
evidence on saturday pursuant to the
motion that has just been voted on by uh
the senate and if i may i hand it up to
the clerk
the clerk will read the motion
no later than 2 p.m on friday february
5th 1999
the managers shall provide written
notice to counsel for the president
indicating the precise page and line
designations of any video excerpts from
the depositions of monica lewinsky
vernon jordan or sydney blumenthal
that they plan to use during their
three-hour presentation on saturday or
during their closing or argument
yeah they're two hours equally divided
on the motion
mr chief justice we won't use uh but a
small percentage of that and i'll turn
the matter off i made to my colleague mr
kendall the chair recognizes mr counsel
kendall
thank you mr chief justice
ladies and gentlemen the senate house
managers i'll be brief this is simply a
procedural motion which i think will
make for a fairer
hearing and a more efficient use of the
senate's time on
uh saturday
fascinating though these depositions are
i don't think there's any need to
reflect inflict them on you repeatedly
what we're asking in this motion is
simply a procedure that would be normal
in a civil trial and that is by a fair
time tomorrow for the house managers to
designate the
the uh portions of the three depositions
that they intend to use that will allow
us not to repeat those portions and it
will give us some fair chance to
organize our responsive presentation
the burden is on the house managers
this is not an extensive uh
set of transcripts i think it can be
easily done
you've all many of you watched the
depositions this week read the
transcript so i think if we can simply
have this designation by two o'clock
tomorrow it will enable a saturday to
perhaps be a shorter proceeding
council for house managers
chair recognized mr manager rogan mr
chief justice thank you i will imitate
my colleague at the bar mr kendall's
brevity if not his eloquence
i would simply suggest that this is
somewhat of a unique opportunity
that council is inviting the house
managers to engage in to give
council notice of page and line
transcripts
for the presentation of evidence that
we're going to make it is our
prerogative to put on our evidence it is
white house council's opportunity to put
on their evidence and asking us to
choreograph that for them
and with them is something that i am
unfamiliar with except for one time
i remember during my days as a judge in
california that a similar request was
made to me and a law clerk
pointed out to me language from one of
the late great justices of the
california supreme court otto kaus
apparently a similar request was made to
justice kaus to do the same thing in the
case and justice kaus looked at the
lawyer making the request and he said
i believe the appropriate legal response
to your request
is that it is none of your damn business
what the other side is going to put on
with that mr chief justice we'll yield
back the balance of our time
mr mr candle
now
that philosophy might want to be
emulated at some point by the drafters
of the federal civil rules but it is not
in every federal uh civil trial this
procedure is is followed the designation
identifying and designating of
deposition experts
excerpts again i think it will make for
a fair and more efficient proceeding i
don't think trial by surprise has a
place here thank you
very well the what the vote is on the mo
on the motion
the the vote is on the motion the clerk
will read the motion
mr ruff moves that no later the senate
will be in order
no later than 2 pm on friday february
5th 1999
the manager shall provide written notice
to counsel for the president indicating
the precise page and line designations
of any video excerpts from the
depositions of monica lewinsky vernon
jordan or sydney blumenthal
that they plan to use during their
three-hour presentation on saturday or
during their closing argument mr chief
justice may we have order in the senate
yes i fully agree with you
would the clerk read that again let the
clerk read them and let the senate
remain in order
mr council rough moves that
no later than 2 p.m on friday february
5th 1999
the manager shall provide written notice
to counsel for the president
indicating the precise page and line
designations of any video excerpts from
the depositions of monica lewinsky
vernon jordan or sydney blumenthal
that they plan to use during their three
hour presentation on saturday or during
their closing argument
the yeas and nasir automatic the clerk
will call the roll
mr abraham
mr abraham no
mr akaka
mr akaka i
mr allard
mr allard no
mr ashcroft
mr ashcroft no
mr baucus
mr baucus
aye
we'll restore order to the gallery
and restore it go ahead
mr bye
mr bai
i
mr bennett
mr bennett no
mr biden
mr biden aye
mr bingaman
mr bingaman aye
mr bond
mr bond no
mrs boxer
mrs boxer i mr bro
mr bro
mr brownback
mr brownback no mr brian
mr brian i mr bunny
mr bunning no
mr burns
mr burns no
mr bird
mr bird i
mr campbell
mr campbell
no mr chafee
mr chafee no mr cleland
mr cleland i mr cochrane
mr cochrane no
ms collins
ms collins no mr conrad
mr conrad i
mr coverdale
mr coverdale no
mr craig
mr craig no mr crapo
mr crapo no mr daschle
mr daschle i mr dewine
mr dewine no mr dodd
mr dodd i mr domenici
mr dominici no mr dorgan
mr dorgan i mr durbin
mr durbin aye mr edwards
mr edwards i mr enzi
mr nz no mr feingold
mr feingold i
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein i mr fitzgerald
mr fitzgerald no
mr frist
mr frist
no mr gorton
mr gorton no mr graham of florida
mr graham of florida aye mr graham of
texas mr graham of texas no
mr grahams of minnesota
mr grams of minnesota no mr grassley
mr grassley no mr greg
mr greg
no mr hegel
mr hegel no mr harkin
mr harkin
i mr hatch
mr hatch no mr helms
mr helms no
mr hollins
mr hollings i
mr hutchinson of arkansas
mr hutchinson of arkansas no
mrs hutchison of texas
mrs hutchison of texas no mr inhofe
mr inhofe no
mr in no way
mr noa i
mr jeffords
mr jeffords aye mr johnson
mr johnson aye mr kennedy
mr kennedy i mr carey of nebraska
mr carey of nebraska i mr carey of
massachusetts
mr carey of massachusetts aye mr cole
mr cole i mr kyle
mr kyle no
ms landrieu
ms landrieu i mr lautenberg
mr lautenberg aye mr leahy
mr leahy aye mr levin
mr levin i mr lieberman
mr lieberman i miss mrs lincoln
mrs lincoln i
mr lot
mr lot no mr luger
mr luger no
mr mack
mr mack
no mr mccain
mr mccain no
mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell no
ms mikulski
ms mikulski
i mr moynihan
mr moynihan i mr murkowski
mr murkowski no
mrs murray
mrs murray i
mr nichols
mr nichols no mr reed of rhode island
mr reed of rhode island i mr reed of
nevada
mr reed of nevada aye mr robb
mr rob i mr roberts
mr roberts no mr rockefeller
mr rockefeller i
mr roth
mr roth no mr santorum
mr santorum no mr sarbanes
mr sarbanes aye
mr schumer
mr schumer aye mr sessions
mr sessions no mr shelby
mr shelby no
mr smith of new hampshire
mr smith of new hampshire no mr smith of
oregon mr smith of oregon no
miss snow
ms snow
no
mr spector
mr spector no
mr stevens
mr stevens no mr thomas
mr thomas no mr thompson
mr thompson no mr thurman
mr thurman no
mr torcelli
mr torselli
i
mr vornovich
mr voynovich no
mr warner
mr warner no
mr wellstone
mr wellstone i
mr wyden
mr wyden
i
so
on this vote the yeas are 46 the nays
are 54 and the motion is not agreed to
chief justice chair recognize the
majority now that completes all the
motions and therefore i ask unanimous
consent that when the senate completes
its business today it stands in
adjournment until 10 a.m on saturday
february 6
and at 10 am on saturday immediately
following the prayer the senate resume
consideration of the article's
impeachment i further asked consent that
on saturday there be six hours equally
divided between the house managers and
white house counsel for presentations i
further ask consent that following those
presentations on saturday the senate
then adjourn until 1 pm on monday
february the 8th i finally asked consent
that on monday immediately following the
prayer the senate resumed consideration
of the articles of impeachment and there
be six hours equally divided between the
house managers and the white house
council for final arguments
yes it's reserving the right to
object i shall not could i
ask the
distinguished leader
we've had exhibits
handed out today to be printed the
congressional record referring to
depositions which i understand in rule
26 are still
are still confidential
i will ask consent that the uh the
transcripts of the depositions uh be
printed in the record of today's date
the
exhibits were handed out today in debate
uh where they handed out
under the rule 26 or they believe we
we asked that uh we got approval that uh
that they'd be used in the oil
presentations at the beginning of the
session today
objections mr
i'd simply like to ask the majority
leader
is there an assumption that that if
white house counsel were to want
sufficient time on saturday
in order to be able to present
video
testimony countering whatever surprise
video may or may not be surprised would
they have that time to be able to
provide that on saturday not to carry
over but merely if they wanted to choose
to to do that on saturday
i'm not sure i understand the question
except that we will come in at 10
and we will have six hours easily
divided and i presume that the the the
house would
make a presentation first and then the
senate and close and
they would have there would be time
during that six hour period
for the white house to use it as they
see fit are you asking that there would
be some sort of break so that they would
be able to consider that
uh
clearly the the purpose of the trial and
the purpose of this effort is to have a
hair fair presentation of evidence
the senate now having denied notice to
white house counsel
of what areas may be the subject of
video
it might be that the voice of the
witness themselves is the best response
to whatever it is that the house were to
present
if they were to decide on saturday
there's a unanimous consent request
pending well mr chief justice uh if i
could uh be heard just uh briefly
further in behalf of my unanimous
consent and and briefly in response to
the question uh we have all worked hard
and been over back to try to be fair and
i'm sure that uh if there's something
that would be needed on saturday would
be carefully considered by both sides mr
chief justice
i suggest the absence of a quorum
the majority leader has the floor
mr chief justice uh i
i believe that uh it would be
appropriate if we could go ahead and get
this unanimous consent request we'll
continue to work with both sides to try
to make sure that there's a
uh a fair uh way to proceed on saturday
uh
we'll have the balance of today and
tomorrow to work on that and so i would
like to renew my unanimous consent
request mr of justice deserving the
right to object may i inquire of the
majority leader if
that saturday time
schedule gives both parties adequate
time to prepare for the presentation of
the evidence
have they
have they
both sides agreed that they will be
prepared
mr chief justice says best i could
respond to that i would say that
hopefully both sides have more than
adequate time allocated on saturday and
we were one of the reasons why we are
doing it this way saturday instead of
tomorrow so both sides will have an
opportunity to review everything and
hopefully communicate with each other
and uh do that during the day friday so
that an orderly uh presentation could be
made on both sides on saturday i believe
that we're we're
seeking a problem here where there may
not be one uh but if one developed
certainly we would take that
consideration i renew my request their
objection
in the absence of objection is so
ordered now mischief justice i as
consent that those parts of the
transcripts of the depositions admitted
into evidence be printed in the
congressional record today's date i
further asked consent that the
deposition transcripts of monica
lewinsky vernon jordan and sydney
blumenthal and the videotapes thereof be
immediately released to the managers
on the part of the house and the council
to the president for the purpose of
preparing their presentations provided
however that such copies shall remain at
all times under the supervision of the
sergeant-at-arms to ensure compliance
with the confidentiality provisions of s
res 30.
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
under the order just granted then the
senate will meet again as a court of
impeachment on saturday on saturday the
senate will hear the presentations from
the house managers and the white house
council for not to exceed six hours
those presentations after those
presentations the senate will resume its
business on monday for six hours
beginning at 1 pm i now ask the senate
standing german under previous order and
ask that all senators remain at their
desk until the chief justice department
changes
in the absence
in the absence of objection it's so
ordered
the 13th day of the impeachment trial of
the president of the united states has
now concluded the senate back in session
this saturday at 10 a.m eastern time
this is an opportunity once again for
you to give us a
hold their debate what their arguments
are what their rationales are
so far the democrats have lost both
those fights
mainly because republicans have insisted
on keeping it private um
on this new fight which is to open the
deliberations the three days or so worth
of deliberations that will probably
start next week there are some
republicans who have joined with
democrats um
senator kay bailey hutchinson of texas
center arlen specter of pennsylvania um
senator chuck hagel of nebraska they've
all lent their support to the idea of
opening the proceedings
if i was betting i would bet no it'll
still be closed because i think there
are enough
republicans who feel that they are
acting as jurors and that they would
like to conduct their deliberations in
private as our viewers can see the
senators the managers and the
president's councils still arriving on
the senate floor let me close with vince
morris with this uh tell us where the
idea of censure stands and what role new
york senator moynihan is playing in that
um well the senator from new york
carries a lot of weight
um senator moynihan
was asked by the minority leader tom
daschle to look at an idea he's putting
together a censure proposal with several
other senators senator moynihan had
initially broached the idea of
interrupting the trial and taking up the
censure proposal while the trial was
still going on perhaps recessing it for
a few hours or doing it in the morning
the trial doesn't start till 1 pm each
day
except on saturdays when it starts at 10
but senator moynihan's idea for
interrupting a trial has not gone
anywhere most of the senators say they
think it's a distraction if they take up
censure at all
they seem to think that it's best dealt
with after the trial is over once
there's been a vote up or down on the
two articles of impeachment
so i think that's what we're likely to
see vince morris of the new york post
thanks it's a busy day for you too
thanks for taking a few minutes for us
sure lou thank you
our coverage today here on c-span 2 will
include your calls during breaks and
also at the end of today's session and
you can also follow the impeachment
trial on our website that's cspan.org
the letter c dash
s-p-a-s-p-a-n span.org
and next here on c-span 2 live gavel to
gavel coverage of the continuing
impeachment trial of the president
so
so
the senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will offer a
prayer
mr chief justice
it's with profound sadness
that we express our grief over the loss
of
our legislative clerk
our scott bates
who along with his wife ricky ellison
bates last evening
was struck by a car while walking across
lee highway
in arlington
mrs bates remains in serious condition
and needs our prayers throughout this
day
let us pray
o eternal god our heavenly father
who loves us within everlasting love and
transforms the darkness of the valley of
the shadow of death into bright hope
the senate family of members and staff
call on you for strength
comfort and courage
a tragic death has taken from us a
beloved friend
an admired fellow worker
a faithful senate employee for over 30
years
in the quietness we can hear his voice
call the role
read proposed legislation
and most of all express his caring
friendship to us all
thank you for scott's commitment to
excellence
and his dedication to the work of the
senate
regardless of long sessions or arduous
debate
we intercede for him
but especially now for his wife
for her complete healing
and recovery
and hold those wonderful children in
your loving arms
lisa laurie and paul
we remember with gratitude lisa and
laurie's outstanding service as pages
here in the senate
help them and their brother paul
to know that their dad whom they love so
deeply is with you
he trusted you in this life and now
lives with you forever
traumatic as was his physical death
it was but a transition in his eternal
life
now lord bless the senate
as it turns to the work of this day
cognizant of the shortness of time
and the length of eternity
for all of us
in the sure hope of the resurrection
and eternal life
amen
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation
hear ye hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the senate
of the united states is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the house of
representatives against william
jefferson clinton president of the
united states
the majority leader is recognized
mr chief justice
our senate family grieves today and our
hearts are really uh heavy
as a result of the tragic loss of scott
bates
senators come and senators go
but scott
has been a fixture in this great chamber
for 30 years
in the last eight years as our
legislative clerk
his familiar voice
was a pillar
of our continuity and tradition
he was not just a co-worker
he was a friend really a great guy
even as we conduct our business today
we will be grieving
but those who knew him well know that
that is exactly what he would want us to
do
to continue with the work of the senate
to which he devoted his life
he was an example of public service at
its finest
never claiming the spotlight
never seeking a headline
but always working for the good of this
institution
and for the country we are here to serve
we pray for the recovery of his wife
ricky
we ask that the lord keep her and their
three children always in his care
before i ask for a moment of silence by
the senate i yield to senator daschle
for his comments minority leaders
recognized i thank the majority leader
and i thank
our chaplain for his gracious prayer
the presence of
scott bates in that chair
and in our lives is something most of us
have counted on
each
and every day
as the majority leader so eloquently
spoke he
scott served the senate
our country
and each of us so admirably
for the last
30 years
who can forget that resonant voice
who can forget the call of the role
who can forget
the authority with which
he articulated each of our names
the answer is no one
when scott began his service
senator mansfield was the majority
leader
and senator hugh scott the minority
leader
ever since that time
scott was an integral part of the
history created in this chamber
and certainly an integral part of our
senate family
he grew up with small town values active
in his church and the boy scouts
he loved politics in school and served
as a page in both the house and the
senate the arkansas legislature
scott's love of politics came naturally
for him
his father actually served as a member
of the arkansas state legislature
in 1970 he came as a summer intern for
senator
john mcclellan in the bill clerk's
office
began his work for us
in 1973.
today
we send our thoughts and our prayers to
his wife ricky who remains in the
hospital
and to their three children lisa laurie
and paul
and his family in arkansas
who are now dealing with this tragic
loss
as chief justice i now ask that all
senators rise
and let's observe a moment of silence
for our friend scott bates
thank you mr chief judges
the chief justice under the order for
today there will be six hour
presentation
equally divided between the house
managers and the white house council
it would be our intention to have a
break
at noon to allow around noon so we'll
have an opportunity for lunch and also
it may be necessary to have one break
brief break before that time
following today's presentation the
senate will adjourn over until 1
pm
on monday
[Applause]
if there's no objection the journals of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date
person to the order of february 4th 1999
the managers on the part of the house of
representatives and the council for the
president each have three hours to make
their presentations
the chair recognizes mr manager rogan to
begin the presentation on the part of
the house of representatives
[Applause]
mr chief justice distinguished counsel
for the president
members of the united states senate
this is the first
and only chance you will have in this
historic impeachment trial
to consider the evidence from a few of
the actual witnesses
after weeks of proceedings
the day has finally arrived when the
united states senate
will listen not just to lawyers talk
about the evidence
but to witnesses with direct knowledge
of the unlawful conduct
of the president of the united states
today in particular
you will have your only opportunity to
hear from the one person
whose testimony invariably leads to the
conclusion that the president of the
united states committed perjury and
obstructed justice in a federal civil
rights action
that person is monica lewinsky
a bright lady whose life has forever
been marked
by the most powerful man
on the earth
if her testimony is truthful
then the president committed the
offenses
alleged
in the articles of impeachment
many different opinions have been formed
about her over the last year
nearly all of this has been fueled by
spin and by propaganda
rather than by truth
today the analysis
and the speculation ends
there is only one judgment the senate
must make for history about monica
lewinsky
do you believe her
you monica s lewinsky do swear or affirm
that the evidence you shall give in the
case now pending between the united
states and william jefferson clinton
president of the united states shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you god i did
house managers may now begin your
question
who is this former intern who swore
under oath to tell the truth the whole
truth
and nothing but the truth
monica lewinsky
is an intelligent
articulate young woman
who until recently
held untarnished hopes for tomorrow like
any other recent college graduate
that hope was drastically altered
when she was subpoenaed in a lawsuit
against the president of the united
states
but for the record would you state uh
your name once again your full name yes
monica samia lewinsky and you're uh are
you arrested in california
i'm not sure exactly where i'm at
resonate now but that's where i'm living
right now okay
do you uh
did you grow up there in california yes
i'm not going to go into all that but i
thought of just a little bit
of background here
you
went to college where lewis and clark in
portland oregon and you majored in
majored in psychology
uh tell me about your your work history
briefly from the time you left college
until uh let's say you started as an
intern at the white house
um i i wasn't working from the time i
okay i graduated college in may of 95.
did you work part-time there in in
oregon with a with a district attorney
at his office somewhere
during i had an internship or a
practicum when i was in school i had two
practicums and one was at the public
defender's office
and the other was at the southeast
mental health network
and those were in portland yes
what uh you received a
bachelor of science in psychology
correct
as a part of your duties at the
southeast health network uh
[Music]
what did you
what did you do in terms of working did
you have direct contact with with people
there patients yes they did um they
referred to them as clients there and uh
i
worked in what was called the phoenix
club which was a socialization
area for the clients uh to
really to just hang out and
sort of work on their social skills
okay
after your work there
you obviously had occasion to come to
work at the white house
uh
how did
uh how did you come to decide you wanted
to come to washington and in particular
work at the white house
there were a few different factors
my mom's side of the family had moved to
washington during my senior year of
college
and
i wanted
i wasn't ready to go to graduate school
yet so i wanted to get out of portland
and
a friend of our families had a grandson
who had had an internship at the white
house and had
thought it might be something i'd enjoy
doing
had you ever worked around in politics
and campaigns or been very active no
you had to go through the normal
application process of
submitting a written application
references and so forth to
the white house
did you do that while you were still in
oregon or were you already in d.c no the
application process was while i was a
senior in college in oregon
had you ever been to washington before
yes
obviously you were accepted and you
started work when
july 10 1995.
that image
the image of a young woman very much
like a family member or friend that we
might know
is an image that the president did not
want america to see
when his indiscretions with her became
public
when that happened
the president painted monica lewinsky
in a very different
and callous light
but i want to say one thing to the
american people
i want you to listen to me i'm going to
say this again
i did not
have
sexual relations with that woman
miss lewinsky
i never told anybody to lie not a single
time never
these allegations are false
and i need to go back to work for the
american people thank you
that woman
with that subtle description
the president invited a waiting america
to adopt a totally false impression
of monica lewinsky
that was not fair
yet with his close aides
aides that he later testified he knew
would be witnesses before the grand jury
he went much further
than a subtle snare
hear the words of sidney blumenthal
assistant to the president
recount how the president
painted this vulnerable young intern who
made the tragic mistake
of becoming involved with him
so
did the president then give you his
account of what happened
between him and monica lewinsky
uh as i recall he did
what did the president tell you um
he uh
he spoke uh fairly rapidly as i recall
at that point
and said that um
she had come on to him
and uh
made a demand for sex
that he had rebuffed her turned her down
and
that
she threatened him
and
he said that she said to him
that
she was
called the stalker by her peers
and that she hated the term
and that
she would claim
that they had
had an affair whether they had or they
hadn't and that she would tell people
do you remember him also saying
that
the reason monica lewinsky would tell
people that is because then she wouldn't
be known by her peers as the stalker
anymore
yes that's right
do you remember the president also
saying that and i'm quoting i've gone
down that road before i've caused pain
for a lot of people i'm not going to do
that again
yeah he told me that
and that was in the same conversation
that you have with president right
in that sequence
can you describe for us the president's
demeanor when he shared this information
with you
yes
he was
very upset
i thought he was a man in anguish
he was a man in anguish
this was more than rakish behavior
when the president used his aides as a
conduit to impart false information to a
federal grand jury in a criminal
investigation
his behavior graduated from the
unconscionable
to the illegal
members of the senate
your task is to determine
who is telling the truth and who is
lying
as you weigh that option
consider mr blumenthal's conclusion
drawn on the very subject
thank you it's where you start talking
about the story that the president told
you
knowing what you know now
do you believe the president lied to you
about his relationship with ms lewinsky
i do
to just avoid to justify a vote of not
guilty for the president you certainly
have the right to reject monica
lewinsky's testimony as untruthful
however i trust your sense of fairness
will dictate that you will listen to all
of her testimony before you dismiss it
outright
if you believe her
you will see this morning how the
president wove a web of perjury and
obstruction of justice
you will see why he was impeached by the
house of representatives
and you will see why a just and proper
verdict in this body
would be to replace him
as president
with vice president al gore
consider for example ms lewinsky's
testimony
regarding witness tampering one element
of the obstruction of justice charge
against the president the president
stands charged with illegally
encouraging a witness in a federal civil
rights suit
brought against him to give perjured
testimony in that proceeding
did he do this
listen to monica lewinsky
we're
at that point we've got a telephone
conversation in the morning with you and
the president
and he has among other things mentioned
to you that
your
name is on the jones witness list
he has also mentioned to you that
perhaps you could file an affidavit to
avoid
possible testifying in that case
that's what is that right correct
and he's also
i think now at the point that we were in
our questioning
uh and referenced the
uh the cover story that
that you and he had had that perhaps you
could say that you were
coming to my office to deliver papers or
to see betty curry is that right
correct that it was from the entire
relationship that story now when he
alluded to that cover story
was that
instantly familiar to you yes you knew
what he was talking about yes
and why was this
familiar to you
because it was part of the pattern of
the relationship
it was a part of the pattern
of the relationship
during ms lewinsky's testimony earlier
this week under oath pursuant to a
senate deposition order
she further elaborated
on this critical piece of evidence
did you discuss uh
anything else that night
in terms of
i would draw your attention to uh the
cover stories i've alluded to that
earlier but
did you did you talk about cover story
that night yes sir
and what was said
um
i believe that
the president said something
you can always say you were coming to
see betty or bringing me papers
i think you've testified that you're
sure he said that that
that night
you aren't sure he said that not
yes
consider also ms lewinsky's testimony
regarding concealing subpoenaed evidence
namely the gifts he gave her this is yet
another element in the obstruction of
justice allegation against the president
the president stands charged with
corruptly engaging in a scheme to
conceal evidence that had been
subpoenaed in a federal civil rights
action brought against him did he do
this
remember
on the morning of december 28 1997 a few
days after miss lewinsky received a
subpoena directing her to turn over any
gifts she had received from the
president the president met with miss
lewinsky
she suggested to him that she could give
the gifts he gave her to betty curry the
president's personal secretary
the president said that he would think
about it listen to what monica lewinsky
said happened next
did you
later that day receive a call from betty
curry yes i did tell us about that
i
received a call from from betty and um
the best of my memory she said something
like i understand you have something for
me or
i know i know i've testified to saying
that that i remember her saying either i
know you have something for me or the
president said you have something for me
and um
to me
and so
she said
i mean this is not a direct quote but
the gist of the conversation was that
she was going to go visit her mom in the
hospital and she'd stop by and get
whatever it was
did you um
question ms corey asked her what are you
talking about or what do you mean no
why didn't you
because i assumed that it meant
the gifts
as you can see
the only way betty curry would have
known to come and get the gifts
would have been for the president
to tell her to do so
finally consider ms lewinsky's testimony
regarding the president's help in
securing a new york job
for her to encourage her silence which
is another element of the obstruction of
justice charge against him
the president is charged with chasing a
job for her in order to prevent her
truthful testimony
did he do this
remember that the president learned on
december 6 1997 that miss lewinsky was
on the paula jones witness list
listen to monica lewinsky
okay uh between your meeting with mr
jordan in early november and december
the 11th when you met with mr jordan
again you did not feel that mr jordan
was doing much to help you get a job is
that correct
i hadn't seen any progress
after you met with mr jordan in early
december you began to interview in new
york
and were much more active in your job
search
correct yes
in early january you received a job
offer from revlon with the help of
vernon jordan is that correct yes
members of the senate these are but a
few highlights of a broad tapestry of
corruption that mr manager hutchinson
and i will develop for you this morning
through videotape testimony and through
other evidence
before we proceed to that
it is worth briefly recounting the
circumstances that elevated the
president's initial indiscretions to the
level of impeachable defenses
the lesson is not complex
it's quite elementary
in all the things we do in life
life is about making choices
parents teach children that bad choices
bring sorrow and consequences we do that
because the failure to impose meaningful
consequences for bad choices
brings about more bad choices
that simple primer on life
encapsulates the political and personal
legacy of bill clinton
his is a continuing pattern of indulging
all choices
and accepting no consequences
this is demonstrated by the actions he
took leading to his impeachment and
trial before the senate
in may 1991 an incident allegedly
occurred that led the president to make
a bad choice
according to paula jones a subordinate
government employee then governor
clinton made a crude and unwelcome
sexual advance on her she later filed a
legal claim for sexual harassment
against him
in november 1995 the president made
another bad choice he began a physical
relationship with a 22 year old white
house intern
he chose to begin a physical
relationship
with her
this was not as he told the grand jury a
relationship that began
as a friendship only to later blossom
into intimacy
the president impulsively
began using her for his gratification
the very day he first spoke with her
later he made the bad choice of
continuing the relationship
after monica became a paid government
employee
an important note
as regrettable as his choice was here
any accountability
for the private aspect of this
should not be determined by the congress
of the united states
it should be determined
by his family
had the president's bad choice simply
ended
with this indiscretion
we would not be here today
adultery may be a lot of things
but it is not an impeachable offense
unfortunately
the president's bad choices
only grew worse
in december 1997 the president made a
bad choice
in order to avoid any possible legal
accountability to paula jones
he chose to destroy her lawful right to
proceed with her case
and this is how he did it
during the so-called discovery portion
of paula jones case federal judge susan
wright ordered the president to answer
questions under oath about any intimate
relationships he may have had with
subordinate female government employees
while he was governor or president
why did judge susan wright order him to
answer these questions
she did it because sexual harassers in
the workplace usually do not commit
their offenses in the open
typically they get their victims alone
and isolated
predators know that if they can do this
one of two things generally will happen
out of fear and intimidation
the victim will submit
or out of fear and intimidation
the victim will not submit
but the victim will not tell anybody
about it
there usually is no other way for a
sexual harassment victim to learn if
there is evidence of a pattern of
similar conduct by a predator
without being able to ask these sort of
questions in a sexual harassment case
without this information
a harassment victim in the workplace
generally would not be able to prove her
case
this is why courts routinely order
defendants to answer these kind of
questions in almost every sexual
harassment case in the country
now president clinton vigorously pursued
legal arguments and motions to avoid
answering these questions about his
sexual relations with subordinate
government employees
yet after hearing his arguments judge
susan wright ordered the president to
answer under oath
these routine questions
and by the way
paula jones
also was required to provide truthful
answers under oath as part of the trial
discovery process
had paula jones lied
in providing such answers she would have
been liable for criminal prosecution
it was while the paula jones case was
proceeding
in the summer of 1995
that a 22 year old named monica lewinsky
went to work as an intern
at the white house shortly thereafter in
november 1995
the president began his physical
relationship with monica lewinsky
and this continued from 1995
until the early part of 1997.
in order to shield him
monica lewinsky promised the president
that she would always deny
the sexual nature of their relationship
she said she would always protect him
the president spoke words of approval
and encouragement to this pledge of
secrecy
monica and the president even agreed to
cover stories
to disguise the true nature of their
relationship
in april 1996
monica was transferred against her will
from a white house job to a job at the
pentagon
after she left employment at the white
house she frequently returned there to
continue her secret relationship with
the president under the guise of
visiting betty curry the president's
personal secretary
after working at the pentagon for over a
year
monica became disheartened
despite the president's promises to the
contrary
monica was not returned to work at the
white house
in july 1997
she began looking for a job in new york
she wasn't having any luck despite the
president's promise to help her with
this too by early november 1997
monica became frustrated with the lack
of assistance
finally betty curry arranged a meeting
for monica with vernon jordan
one of the president's closest friends
they sought to enlist his help in her
new york job search
on november 5th 1997
monica met for 20 minutes with mr jordan
in his office
no job referrals followed no job
interviews were arranged
and there were no contacts from mr
jordan
in short mr jordan made no effort to
find monica a job
indeed getting her a job was so
unimportant to him that mr jordan later
testified that he didn't even remember
meeting her on november the 5th
nothing happened on her job search
through the month of november because mr
jordan was either gone or he simply
wasn't returning monica's phone calls
all that changed on december 5th 1997
that was the day monica lewinsky's name
appeared on the paula jones witness list
members of the senate
this is how the whole thing started
a lone woman in arkansas
felt that she had been wronged by the
president of the united states
the law said that she had a right to
have her claim heard in a court of law
at each stage the president could have
chosen to uphold the law
instead he chose to obstruct justice
and to commit
perjury in his presentation
mr manager hutchinson will show you
through videotaped words of the key
witnesses how the president used his
position to obstruct justice as set
forth in the articles of impeachment i
will then return to make the same
showing respecting the allegations of
perjury in the articles
throughout all of this
throughout this presentation
it is important to keep in mind
that we seek no congressional punishment
for a man who chose
to cheat on his wife
however we have a legal obligation
to expect constitutional accountability
for a president
who chooses
to cheat the law
the chair recognizes mr manager
hutchinson
thank you mr chief justice
um
ladies and gentlemen the senate
i want to continue the presentation that
was commenced this morning by mr rogan
let me continue with the path of
obstruction the obstruction for our
purposes began on december 5 1997
when the witness list came out in the
civil rights case it was faxed to the
president's lawyers it was later given
to the president at that point
the administration of justice became a
threat to the president of the united
states
he determined that the truth would be
harmful
to the case that he was trying to defend
and the president made a decision to
take whatever steps were necessary to
suppress the truth rather than to uphold
the law
the acts of obstruction included
attempts to improperly influence the
testimony of witnesses in the case
against him
the procurement of a false affidavit in
the case
the willful concealment of evidence that
was under subpoena
and efforts to illegally influence the
testimony of witnesses before the
federal grand jury
you have heard these areas of
obstruction presented to you before
by managers behalf of the house but
today it is important that you hear this
case from those who have testified by
deposition at your direction
and as you hear their testimony
you will see that the president may have
been the only individual who had the
complete picture
he had all the facts and he did not
always share those facts with others he
did not share those facts with mr vernon
jordan
nor did he share all the facts with miss
monica lewinsky until he determines
that the time is right to do so
for example he knows that miss lewinsky
is a witness but does not tell miss
lewinsky that fact until the time is
right and whatever the job search is
proceeding
he asked mr jordan to get miss lewinsky
a job but he does not tell mr jordan the
essential facts first of all that miss
lewinsky is a witness and secondly that
there is a dangerous relationship
between them
in which if she testifies her testimony
would be harmful
the president was obviously concerned
about the truthful testimony miss
lewinsky he would have been harmful to
his interest in the case and as a result
the president
personally instructed and directed the
efforts of mr jordan to secure miss
lewinsky a job and to urge the filing of
the affidavit
now what is the president's defense
to this charge let's listen
was your assistance to ms lewinsky which
you described
in any way depended upon her doing
anything whatsoever in the paul jones
case
no
and you've heard that before
as you can see mr jordan defends his
actions and
my implication defends the actions of
the president
well you can weigh his attentions but
his intentions are not the issue
because regardless of your view of mr
jordan and his motivations they are
irrelevant his view as to whether there
is a connection between the job and the
testimony is not an issue
it is not an issue as to whether miss
lewinsky thought there was a connection
between
the job and the testimony it's not an
issue as to whether revlon thought there
was a connection between
the job and the testimony there is only
one issue and that is whether the
president
viewed that there was a connection
between those two and it is the
president who under the law had to have
the corrupt intent and that is the
question that you must have to answer
and i believe that the evidence will
show that regardless what anyone else
believed he knew the direct connection
now after each of you hear the testimony
of miss lewinsky and mr jordan some of
some of you will conclude
that surely he had to know
that there was an inappropriate
relationship between the president and
miss lewinsky and why do i say that
well miss lewinsky will testify that he
made it clear
that she made it clear to mr jordan that
there was that type of relationship at
first she sort of is careful about it
but then she just ultimately tells him
as you will see from her testimony but
mr jordan also for those who have
listened to his testimony refers to
mother witt
and his off relied upon mother wit would
have told him as well under the
circumstances that there's something
more going on
and if he knew about the relationship
he had to know that all was not as it
should be and what the president was
asking him to do
the president requesting a job for miss
lewinsky at the same time he is
monitoring the filing of a false
affidavit and knowing she was a witness
in a case against him all indicated that
the job was not a favor for a young
friend but it was a favor for someone in
high office that had to be accomplished
in order to assure the cooperation of a
dangerous witness
that evidence will show that it is the
president who suggested
the assistance for miss lewinsky and is
the president who suggested the false
affidavit now let's listen to the
testimony step by step through the job
search through the signing of the false
affidavit to the encouragement to file
the false affidavit on december 17th to
the discussion of the gifts on december
28 through the tampering of the
testimony of betty curry on two
occasions and then with the president's
aid when they were called before the
federal grand jury or prior to that
first let's go to the job benefit to ms
lewinsky how involved was the president
in this activity let's first listen
to the president as to what he says when
he testified under oath in his
deposition
you know a man named vernon jordan
you've known him for a long time a long
time
has it ever been reported to you that he
met with monica lewinsky
and talked about this case
i knew that he
met with her
and i think betty suggested he meet with
her anyway she met with her
i thought that he talked to her about
something else i didn't know that that i
thought he had
given her some advice
about her move to new york
it seems like that's what betty said
brother vague
attributes all of his knowledge about
vernon jordan
to
about reference to miss lewinsky to
betty to betty
and let's go on and hear more of what
the president has to say on this
connection
have you ever had a conversation with
vernon jordan in which monica lewinsky
was mentioned
i have he told me that he talked
he mentioned in passing to me that he
had talked to her
and she had come to him for advice about
moving to new york
she had come to him for advice
she'd come to him to it for advice about
moving to new york she had called him
and asked if she could come see him
betty i think he maybe said something to
him about talking to her and he'd given
her some advice about moving to new york
that's all i know about that
that's all i know about that
diminished knowledge diminished
responsibility
but let's see what his good friend and
confidant mr jordan says about what the
president knew when he knew it and to
what extent he controlled this effort
now is it true that uh your efforts to
find a job for miss lewinsky that you
referenced in that meeting with mr
giddis
were your efforts carried out at the
request of the president of the united
states there's no question but that
through betty curry
i was acting on behalf of the president
to get
mr lewinsky a job i think that's clear
from my grand jury testimony
and
i just want to make sure that
that's
firmly established
uh
and it refers to your previous grand
jury testimony
you indicated i believe on may 28 1998
at page 61 that she referring to betty
curry was the one that called me at the
behest of the president that is correct
and i think
congressman if in fact the president of
the united states secretary calls and
asked for a request
that you try to do the best you can to
to make it happen and you receive that
request as a request coming from the
president i i interpret it as a request
for the president and then later on in
june of 98 in your grand jury testimony
at page 45
did you not reference or testify that
the president asked me to get monica
lewinsky a job there was no there was no
question but that he asked me to help
and that he asked others to help i think
that is clear from everybody's grand
jury testimony and just one more point
in that regard and the same grand jury
testimony is it correct that you
testified that he referring to the
president was the source of it coming to
my attention in the first place
i mean if that is
if you if it's
58
i stand on my grand jury testimony
[Applause]
as mr jordan testified the president was
a source of it coming to his attention
in the first place
mr jordan the president's friend
testified that this was not a casual
matter for the president
he was interested he was directing the
show and as we'll be clear he was
consumed with preventing the truth from
coming out in the civil rights case but
let's start back for a moment at the
beginning
in the packet that's been provided to
you there's a timeline at the very
beginning and you can see again that
there was the witness list that came out
on december 5th and that triggered the
action in this case
but if but as we know
there was a meeting on november 5th
between ms lewinsky and mr jordan in mr
jordan's office miss lewinsky wanted a
job before the witness list came out but
not a whole lot was happening on that
regard and let's look at the testimony
of mr jordan in regard to this november
5th meeting that he was first asked
about that he had no recollection about
when the records were reproduced
produced for him he had a recollection
let's listen to mr jordan
well regardless of whether you met with
her in november
or not
uh the fact is you did not do anything
in november to secure a job to ms
lewinsky
until your activity is on december 11 of
97. i think that's correct
and
the on december 11
i think you made some calls for miss
lewinsky on that particular day i
believe i did
there will be a pattern developed as you
can see mr jordan had no recollection of
the november 5th meeting when he
originally testified before the grand
jury no recollection whatsoever
of that meeting
basically said it didn't happen
the second time he testified for the
grand jury the record was produced it
was substantiated and
he recalls that
the second thing you can see from this
is the meeting was absolutely no
consequence to him because this was not
a priority issue with him he was not
going to do anything and
it started happening of course when the
witness list came out the president met
with the attorneys in the witness list
and then december 7th the president and
mr jordan meet
december 8th the meeting is set up
by ms lewinsky with mr jordan for the
11th and the 11th when they met is when
thanks
started moving calls were being made of
course that was done at the direction of
the president but let's look at ms
lewinsky's recollection of that same
november 5th meeting
okay uh between your meeting with mr
jordan in early november and december
the 11th when you met with mr jordan
again you did not feel that mr jordan
was doing much to help you get a job is
that correct
i hadn't seen any progress
you met with mr jordan in early december
you began to interview in new york
and were much more active in your job
search correct
yes
in early january you received a job
offer from revlon with the help of
vernon jordan is that correct yes
ms lewinsky at this point is at their
mercy she doesn't know what the
communication is she doesn't know what
the president knows
the witness list has come in and
she hope things are moving but she
doesn't know it but finally they start
moving after the witness list comes in
and december 11 she has the meeting in
which things start moving
was this a typical referral
each of you in this body
you have had occasions where friends
acquaintances at different level
previous employees come to you and say
i'm going to be applying for a job with
such and such a company will you be a
reference for me sometimes even go so
far as to ask you to make a call to that
company that they're applying a job for
but this is not a typical referral as
you'll see from the testimony a few days
prior to the december 11 meeting miss
lewinsky sends a wish list to vernon
jordan of the company she wanted to
apply for mr jordan quickly said i'm not
concerned about your wish list i've got
the people i want to deal with and he
took control of the job search and let's
listen to the testimony of mr jordan as
he emphasizes that point
now you mentioned that she had sent you
a uh
i guess some people refer to it a wish
list or a list of jobs that she got jobs
companies companies that she would be
interested in seeking employment with
that's correct and you looked at that
and you
determined that you wanted to go with
your own list of
friends and
companies that you had better contacts
with and
i'm sure congressman that you too have
been in this business and you do know
that you can only call people that you
know or feel comfortable in calling
absolutely no question about it and
uh let me just comment and and ask your
response to this but uh many times uh
i will be listed as a reference and they
can take that to any company you might
be listed as a reference and the name
vernon jordan would be a good reference
anywhere would it know i would hope so
and uh and so even though it was a
company that you might not have the best
contact with
you know
you could have been helpful in that
regard well the fact is i was running
the job search not miss lewinsky and
therefore
the companies that she brought or listed
uh were not of interest to me i
knew where i would need to call
and that
is exactly
the point uh that
uh
you looked at getting miss lewinsky a
job as an assignment
rather than just something that you are
going to be a reference for
i don't know what i looked upon it as an
assignment uh
i
getting jobs for people is not unusual
for me so i don't view it as an
assignment
i just view it as something that is part
of what i do
you're acting on behalf of the president
when you're trying to get miss wilminski
a job
and you were in control of the job
search
uh yes
testimony is very clear as to mr
jordan's
running the
job search in essence a job placement
in behalf of the president and let's go
again to that meeting of december 11 in
which mrs lewinsky goes
for the first time that mr jordan
remembers
for that meeting about the jobs ms
lewinsky's view of this meeting
again jordan's list
he was the one that was controlling the
job search
and also you'll see that mr jordan
acquires some knowledge from ms lewinsky
as to the relationship
all right let's go
forward another week or so to uh
december the 11th and
uh lunch
that you had with vernon jordan i
believe in his office yes
how did how was that meeting set up
through his secretary
did you instigate that or did he call
through his secretary
i don't remember
what was the purpose
of that meeting
um was to discuss my job situation
and what uh what
how was that discussed
um
mr jordan gave me a list of three names
and suggested that i contact these
people
in a letter
that i should see him
on and
that's what i did
did he ask you to copy him on the
letters
that you sent out
yes
during this meeting did he make any
comments about uh your status as a
friend of the president
yes
what what did he say
in one of his remarks he said something
about
me being a friend of the
president
did you respond
yes how
i said that i didn't um i think my grand
jury testimony i know i talked about
this is probably more accurate
my memory right now is i said something
about
seeing him more as
a man than is a president and i treated
him accordingly
did you express your frustration to mr
jordan with
with the president
i expressed that sometimes i had
frustrations with him yes
and what was his response to you
about
after you
talked about the president
uh
he sort of uh
jokingly said to me
you know what your problem is and don't
deny it
you're in love with him but it was a
sort of lighthearted
nature did you did you have a response
to that
i probably blushed or giggled or
something
that was on december 11th and i'm sure
mr jordan's mother wit was starting to
kick in at this point
understanding that there's something a
little bit more involved in the
relationship between miss lewinsky
and the president but let's go to
another aspect of the relationship on
the job search let's look how
information is controlled mr jordan
learns ultimately on december 19th
clearly that miss lewinsky is on the
witness list
because she presents the subpoena to him
but whenever he pursues the jobs later
on and makes the call to mr pearlman he
does not pass that information along to
the company does that make a difference
to revlon
you will hear some references to mr
halperin who's one of the uh executives
at
mcandrews and forbes the parent company
of revlon and mr pearlman who is the ceo
of mcandrews and forbes as well let's
listen to the testimony of mr jordan on
how information is controlled
now the second piece of information was
the fact that you knew and the president
knew that miss lewinsky was under
subpoena in the jones case
and that information was not provided to
either mr halperin or to mr pearlman
is that correct that's correct
now
i wanted to read you a question and
answer
uh of mr howard giddis and his grand
jury testimony of april 23 1998
and the question
was
now you had mentioned before that one of
the responsibilities of director is to
have a fiduciary duty to the company if
it was the case that miss lewinsky had
been noticed as a witness in the paula
jones case and vernon jordan had known
that is that something that you believe
as a person who works for mcandrews and
forbes is that something that you
believe that mr jordan should have told
you or someone in the company not
necessarily you but someone in the
company when he referred her for
employment his answer was yes
do you disagree with mr gettys
conclusion that that
was important information for mcandrews
and forbes i obviously didn't think it
was important at the time and i didn't
do it
why would revlon want to know
that miss lewinsky was on a witness list
and under subpoena in a case that was
adverse to the president and the fact
that the president was really the one
that was wanting the job placement for
miss lewinsky
i think everyone understands the
extraordinary conflict the extraordinary
impropriety of that circumstances as mr
jordan himself testified previously
that whenever the subpoena was issued it
changed the circumstances and yet that
information was not provided
to revlon and uh mr
giddis certainly would have thought that
it should have been
and so he
revlon wanted to know for the same
reason really that mr jordan would have
liked to have had that information
but whenever the president learned
that mr whitsey was on the witness list
he did not share that information with
mr jordan himself
and so
it's explosive information that the
president does not make available to him
until the right time and let's listen to
mr jordan
and so
uh there's two conversations after the
witness list came out one that you had
with the president on december 7th and
then a subsequent
conversation with him after you met with
mr lewinsky on the 11th
now
in your subsequent conversation after
the 11th did you discuss with the
president united states monica lewinsky
and if so can you tell us what that
discussion was if there was a discussion
subsequent to monica lewinsky's visit to
me on december the 11th with the
president of the united states it was
about the
job search
and
during that
did he indicate that he knew about the
fact that she had
lost her job in the white house and she
wanted to get a job in new york he was
aware that he was obviously aware that
she had lost a job in the white house
because she was working at the pentagon
he was also aware that she wanted to
work in new york in the private sector
and understood that that is why she was
having conversations with me there's no
doubt about that
and he thanked you for helping her
there's no question about that either
and on either of these conversations
that i've referenced that you had with
the president after the witness list
came out your conversation on december
7th and your conversation sometime after
the 11th
did the president tell you that
missalanika lewinsky was on the witness
list in the jones case he did not
the president knew
it was not disclosed to mr jordan
according to his testimony now mr jordan
has to be reminded as to how important
this information was
because he previously testified that he
expected to be told it was significant
enough information that if miss betty
curry knew that miss lewinsky was under
subpoena that betty curry should tell
him he expected the president to tell
him
and that was his expectation for natural
reasons that this is extraordinary
conflict whenever the president knows
there's a relationship she's an adverse
witness she's under subpoena we're
providing a job benefit but he kept some
of those details to himself without
disclosing it let's listen again to mr
jordan
precisely she disclosed to you of course
when she received the subpoena and
that's information that you expected uh
to know and to be disclosed to you
all right
and in fact if miss curry
i'm talking about betty curry uh if she
had known that miss lewinsky was under
subpoena you would have expected her to
tell you
that information as well since you were
seeking employment for ms lewinsky well
[Music]
it would have been fine that she told me
i do make a distinction between being a
witness on the one hand and being a
defendant
in some sort of criminal action on the
other she was a witness in the civil
case
and i don't believe witnesses on in
civil cases don't have a right for
employment okay
i refer you to page 95 of your grand
jury testimony
in which you said
i believe that had ms curry known that
she
would have told me
and the next question let me ask the
question again though would you have
expected her to tell you if she knew
and you recall your answer i don't uh
yes sure i stand by that answer and so
it's your testimony that if miss curry
had known that miss lewinsky was under
subpoena you had expected her to tell
you that information it would have been
helpful
and
likewise would you have expected the
president to tell you if he had any
reason to believe that miss lewinsky
would be called as a witness in the
paula jones case that would have been
helpful too
and that was your expectation that he
would have done that
in your conversation it would certainly
have been helpful but it would not have
changed my mind
well
being helpful and that being your
expectation is a little bit different
and so i want to go back again to your
testimony on march 3 page 95
and when
the question has asked to you
uh
question if the president had any reason
to believe that miss lewinsky could be
called as a witness in the paula jones
case would you have expected him to tell
you that when you spoke with him between
the 11th and the 19th about her
and your answer
and i think he would have
my answer was yes and the grand jury
testimony my answer is yesterday all
right
so it would have been helpful and it was
something you would have expected yes
and yet according to your testimony the
president did not so advise you of that
fact in the conversations that he had
with you on december 7th and december
11th after he learned that miss lewinsky
was on the witness list is that
testifying objection misstates the
record with regard to december 11th
i i
will restate the question i believe it
accurately reflects the record
and i'll ask the question
and yet according to your testimony
the president did not so advise you of
the fact that miss lewinsky was on the
witness list
despite the fact that he had
conversations with you on two occasions
on december 7th and december 11th i have
no recollection of the president telling
me about the witness list
i'm providing some long snippets
because i want you to see
uh the testimony of the witnesses and i
think it is very important as you piece
it together you might say well there's
nothing explosive here
whenever you're talking about
obstruction of justice it ties together
it fits together information is
controlled and that's what we see in
this particular case
clearly mr jordan expected information
because he knew that something that the
president should have shared it was not
shared according mr jordan's testimony
and for natural reasons if you look at
the exhibit that i passed out on the
timeline
we've talked about when the witness list
came out on the 7th and on the
11th or sometime thereafter the
president and mr jordan meet
uh and that information is not disclosed
despite the fact that the president
knows she's on the witness list and now
let's go to the 17th because now the
president is ready to share some
additional information with miss
lewinsky
now that he has got the job search
moving perhaps she's in a more receptive
mood so that she can handle the news
that she is on the witness list so let's
listen to ms lewinsky's testimony as to
this december 17th 2 a.m telephone
conversation from the president of the
united states
sometime back in the december of 1997 in
the morning december the 17th
did you receive a call from the
president yes
what was the
purpose of that call
what did you talk about it was threefold
first to tell me
that ms currie's brother had been killed
in a car accident
second to tell me
that my name was on a witness list for
the paula jones case
and
thirdly
he mentioned that hit the christmas
present he had for me
this telephone call was somewhere in the
early morning hours of two o'clock to 2
30. correct did it surprise you that he
called you so late
no
was this your first notice
of your your name being on the paula
jones witness list
yes
again and
i'll try to ask sharper questions and
avoid these objections
uh we're
at that point we've got a telephone
conversation in the morning with you and
the president and he has among other
things mentioned to you that
your
name is on the jones witness list
he has also mentioned to you that
perhaps you could file an affidavit to
avoid
possible testifying in that case
that's what is that right correct
and he's also
i think now at the point that we were in
our questioning
and referenced the
cover story that
that you and he had had that perhaps you
could say that you were coming to my
office to deliver papers or to see betty
curry is that right
correct that it was from the entire
relationship that story now when he
alluded to that cover story
was that
instantly familiar to you yes you knew
what he was talking about yes
and why was this familiar to you
because it was part of the pattern of
the relationship
as i understand your testimony
to the the cover stories uh were
reiterated to you by the president
that night
on the telephone
correct
after
he told you you would be a witness or
your name was on the witness list i
should say correct okay
and did you understand that
since your name was on the witness list
that there would be a possibility that
you could be subpoenaed to testify in
the paul jones case
i think i understood that i could be
subpoenaed and there was a possibility
of testifying i don't know if i
necessarily thought it was the subpoena
to testify
but
were you in fact subpoenaed to testify
yes
let me let me ask it did you understand
in the context of the telephone
conversation with the president that
early morning
of december the 17th that you understand
that you would deny
your relationship with the president to
the jones lawyers
through use of these cover stories
from what i learned in that conversation
through those cover stories i don't know
but from what i learned in that
conversation
i thought to myself i knew i would deny
the relationship
and you would deny the relationship to
the jones lawyers yes correct
do you believe monica lewinsky
i believe her testimony is credible
she is not trying to hammer the
president she is trying to tell the
truth as to her recollection of this 2
a.m call to her by the president united
states on december 17th the news is
broken to her that she's on the witness
list it puts it in a legal context this
is a 24 year old ex-intern she might not
have the legal sophistication of the
president but the president certainly
knows the legal consequences as to his
actions what he is telling a witness in
a case that is adverse to him is that
you do not have to tell the truth you
can use the cover stories that we used
before and that might have been in a
non-legal context but now we're in a
different arena and he says continue the
same lies even though you're in a court
of law continue the same pattern
ladies and gentlemen the senate in my
book that's illegal and i hate to say it
but that is obstruction of justice by
the president of the united states and
if you believe miss lewinsky then you
have to accept that fact
otherwise we're saying that it's all
right for someone to take a witness who
is a against them and say don't tell the
truth
don't worry about that use the cover
stories you can file an affidavit you
can avoid telling the truth
ladies and gentlemen this is significant
it is important do not diminish this the
impact of what happened on december 17th
with the obstruction of justice on that
occasion
and now let's move on
that's december 17th we can move on to
december
19th
and this is when
the subpoena is actually delivered
to ms lewinsky she calls vernon jordan
she's in tears she's upset
vernon jordan says come to
over to my office and they have the
discussion and you're going to hear mr
jordan's version of what happens on
december 19th you're going to hear miss
lewinsky's testimony as to what happens
in that office on december 19th as well
let's hear from mr
jordan and during this meeting did she
in fact show you the subpoena that she
had received in the jones litigation i'm
sure she showed me this opinion and the
subpoena
that was presented to you asked her to
give a deposition is that correct is i
recollect but did it also ask miss
lewinsky or direct her to produce
certain documents and tangible objects i
think
if i'm correct in my recollection it
asks that she produced gifts
gifts and some of those gifts were
specifically enumerated i don't remember
that i do remember gifts
and
uh did you discuss any of the items
requested under the subpoena i did not
what i said to her was that she needed
counsel
all right
now
just to help you in reference to your
previous grand jury testimony of march
398
uh i i bel and if you'd like to refer to
that page 121 but i believe it was your
testimony that uh you asked her if there
had been any gifts after you looked at
this i may have done that and if that's
in my testimony i stand by it
and
uh
did she
did from your conversation uh with her
did you determine that in your opinion
there was a fascination on her part with
the president no question about that
and uh
i think you previously described it that
she had a thing
for the president i think yes and did
you make any specific inquiry as to the
nature of the relationship that she had
with the president
yeah at some point during that
conversation i asked her directly if she
and had had sexual relationships with
the president
and
is this not an extraordinary question to
ask a 24 year old intern whether she had
sexual relations with the president of
the united states not if you see it not
if you had witnessed her emotional state
and this thing as i say it was not
and
her emotional state and what she
expressed to you about
her feelings for the president is what
prompted you to ask that question that
plus the question of whether or not the
president at the end of his term
would leave the first lady and that was
alarming and stunning
me and she related that
question to you in that meeting on
december 19th that's correct
now going back to the question
uh
[Music]
in which you asked her if there if she
had had a sexual relationship with the
president what was their response no
and
uh
i'm sure that that was not an idle
question on your part
uh and i presume that you need to know
the answer for some purpose i wanted to
know the answer based on what i had seen
in her expression
obviously based on the fact that this
was a subpoena
about
her relationship with the president
and
so
you felt like you needed to
know the answer to that question to
determine how you were going to handle a
situation no i thought it was a factual
data that i needed to know and i asked
the question
and why did you need to know the answer
to that question i am referring this
lady
miss lewinsky
to various companies for jobs
and it seemed to me that it was
important for me to know in that process
whether or not there had been something
going on with the president based on
what
i saw and based on what i heard
why was it important
why was it important for mr jordan to
know whether she was under subpoena why
was it important for mr jordan to know
whether there was a sexual relationship
why was it important because those would
be incredible explosive ingredients in a
circumstance that is fraught with danger
and impropriety and he knows that and he
asks the right questions but he doesn't
listen to the right answer nor does he
take the right steps because
he is acting at the direction of the
president
and as you will see that during this
meeting on december 19th
he was keeping the president very
closely informed you'll see in your
packet of materials that
the call as soon as he was notified mr
jordan was notified that ms lewinsky was
under subpoena he tries to get a hold of
the president exhibit age 25 a 351 call
to the president he didn't make contact
at that point
miss lewinsky came into his office about
447 it was at
501
that he received a call from the
president so the president actually
called him at the same time miss
lewinsky was in the office
let's look at miss lewinsky's testimony
as to her recollection of that december
19th meeting with mr jordan
he went to see mr jordan and you were
inside his office
after five o'clock and you
did uh
is that correct yes okay or were you
interrupted
in the office yes you received a phone
call and you testified that you didn't
know who that was
did you excuse yourself yes okay what uh
after you came back in
uh
what what occurred
did he tell you who you'd been talking
to no okay what happened i know i've
testified about this um so
i stand by that testimony and my
recollection
uh right now is um
when i came back in the room at i think
shortly after he
had placed a phone call to mr carter's
office
and
told me to come to his office at 10 30
monday morning
did you know who mr carter was no
did mr jordan tell you who he was
i don't remember
did you understand that
he was going to going to be your
attorney
yes
did you express any concerns about this
subpoena
i think that happened before the the
phone call came
okay
what did you express concerns about this
yes yes and what were those concerns um
in general i think i was just concerned
about being dragged into this and um
i was concerned because um
the subpoena had
called for a hat pin that i turned over
a half pin and
that was an alarm to me
how in what sense was it in what sense
was it an alarm to you
um
the hat pin being on the subpoena was
evidence to me that someone
had
given that information
to the paula jones people
what did mr jordan say about the
subpoena
that it was standard
did he have income did he have any
comment about
the specificity of the hat pin
no he just kept telling me to calm down
did you raise that concern with mr
jordan
um
i don't remember if i
if i've testified to it then yes if i i
don't remember right now
did would you remember then if he made
any comment or answer about the hat pin
i mean i think i would
and you don't i remember him saying
something that it was you know calm down
it's a standard subpoena vanilla
subpoena something like that
what we see here is another example of
compartmentalization of information
during this meeting with ms lewinsky mr
jordan receives a call from the
president presumably in response to the
call that he had placed to the president
to tell him that ms lewinsky had been
subpoenaed
when the president calls mr jordan takes
that call in private it's about miss
lewinsky it's about the subpoena and
that information is not shared with ms
lewinsky
it's of interest to her
let's go on and hear some more about ms
lewinsky's version of that
conversation on december
19th did mr jordan during that meeting
make an inquiry about the nature of the
relationship between you and the
president yes he did
what was that inquiry
uh
i don't remember the exact wording of
the questions but there were there were
two questions and i think they were
something like did you
have sex with the president
or
did he and if or did he ask for it or
some something like that
at this point
miss lewinsky denies the relationship
she thinks this is some type of a test
she's not sure of the reason for the
question she thinks he knows there's a
little confusion on that but clearly mr
jordan is not satisfied with the answer
mother witt is still around
as he indicated but he feels so
concerned about it that that night he
goes to see the president that we'll
later see and ask that same question to
the president
and now let's talk
to president clinton and see what he
testifies to
about when this information was reported
to him on the subpoena let's listen to
the testimony of president clinton
did anyone other than your attorneys
ever tell you that monica lewinsky had
been served with a subpoena in this case
i don't think so
did you ever talk with monica lewinsky
about the possibility that she might be
asked to testify in this case bruce
lindsay i think bruce lindsay told me
that she was i think maybe that's the
first person
this this is the january deposition
the manager uh answer the question and
then show that again that this is the
second time
to take the president without indicating
which deposition it was
yes i i think it would be a good idea if
the manager would
indicate what deposition it was if
you're showing the deposition
of the president
thank you mr chief justice and i thank
the senator for the question that's a
very fair question and i will try to
be more clear in the identification of
that
this is the testimony of
william jefferson clinton before the
deposition the jones case in january
january 17th
and i believe
uh am i able to say we're going to
replay that
no we're going we're not going to replay
that
let me go on
but the the testimony that he gave at
that time was that uh
did anyone other than your attorneys
ever tell you that monica lewinsky had
been served with a sabine in that case
the answer was i don't think so
and clearly mr jordan was
keeping close contact with miss with the
president
telling him every step of the way when
there's subpoena the calls he's placing
a call back
the information is there but of course
the president tries to diminish that
now let's go on with the uh some more
testimony for mr winston did you ask mr
jordan to call the president and advise
him of the subpoena
um
i think so yes
i asked him to inform the president i
don't know if it was through telephone
or not
and you did that because
the president had asked you to make sure
you let betty know that well sure
with betty not being in the office i
couldn't
there wasn't anyone else that i could
call
to get through to him did mr jordan say
to you when he might see the president
next
i believe he said he would see him that
evening at a holiday reception
mr chief justice could i inquire
was the
manager thinking in terms of
concluding this portion it's uh in 15
minutes or do you want to take a break
now and then
this would be a good time for a break
miss chief justice eyes consent would
take a 15-minute break at this time
without objection so ordered
if both sides in the impeachment trial
the president used their full three
hours each today's session including
breaks could last until about five or
six pm
in each of our breaks we're going to
open our phone lines for your thoughts
on whether you think the president
should be found guilty or not guilty
convicted or acquitted those phone
numbers 202 624 11 11 if you are for
acquittal if you think you're for a
conviction after hearing the testimony
202 624 eleven good morning
hi in in view of the
the the relative recent iran contra
things i'm i'm amazed that the these
callers
thank you mr chief justice
i was going to take advantage of the
opportunity to replay the videotape
uh in fact i will now
that
i did not properly explain before this
is the videotape of president clinton
in his testimony before
the civil deposition the jones case in
january 1997 and so let's go ahead
you say before you actually mean during
don't you
it's not before the deposition it was
during the his testimonies during the
deposition mr chief jesse sir absolutely
correct excuse me
thank you
anyone other than your attorneys ever
tell you that monica lewinsky had been
served with a subpoena in this case
i don't think so
did you ever talk with monica lewinsky
about the possibility that she might be
asked to testify in this case bruce
lindsay i think bruce lindsay told me
that she was i think maybe that's the
first person
i want to be
accurate as i can
and now let's go to what mr jordan has
to say in reference to his contacts to
the president
when he learned of the subpoena on
december 19th
and so let's play that tape
now mr jordan
uh you indicated you had this
conversation with the president
at about 501 pm
uh out of the presence of ms lewinsky
now during this conversation with the
president what did you tell the
president in that conversation
exceptional area that she had a subpoena
and that i was going to visit with her
and did you advise the president as well
that you were going to recommend frank
carter as an attorney i may have
and why was it necessary to tell the
president these facts
i don't know why i was not unnecessarily
telling these facts i was keeping him
informed about what was going on and so
i told him
why did you make the judgment
that you should call the president and
advise him of these facts i just thought
he ought to know he was interested in it
he was obviously interested in it and i
felt some responsibility to tell him and
i did
and what was the president's response
he said thank you okay
subsequent to your conversation with the
president
uh about monica lewinsky did you advise
ms lewinsky of this conversation with
president i doubt it
once again mr jordan testifies that the
president
was obviously interested in it this was
not a matter of casual interest to him
it was a matter of deep concern that
jeopardized
what he saw as his position in that
lawsuit now let's go back again to the
testimony of president clinton this time
before the grand jury
in august
of 1998.
we're familiar weren't you mr
president that she had received the
community party acknowledged yes sir i
was and mr jordan informed you of that
is that right
no sir
well the the clear that
uh perhaps they will be able to correct
that but let me just read the answer
again
uh and mr jordan informed you of that is
that right and his answer is no sir
now in fairness to the president he
gives a longer answer than that that
uh i would welcome anyone to read but it
appears rather convoluted
but i think that you can see the
contrast there's no question in mr
jordan's mind as to the
details that he is providing to the
president on a regular basis we're on
december 19th the subpoena is issued
he notifies the president he notifies
the president how the job search is
going he notifies the president that
they got representation through mr
carter and so the details are provided
to the president and contrast that with
the president's recollection as to
did he have any contact with mr jordan
once again diminishing that
and now let's uh
go still to december 19th going back to
the chart where we are time wise
december 19th when the subpoena is
issued mr jordan meets
with
monica lewinsky
he confronts her about the relationship
now he goes that evening
to see the president at the white house
to confront him personally about it to
discuss this with him and let's hear
from mr jordan
this is at the white house
now would you describe your conversation
with the president
we were upstairs
in the white house mrs jordan
we came in by way of the southwest gate
into the diplomatic entrance we left the
car there
i took the elevator up and missed to the
residents and mrs jordan went and
visited at the at the party
and uh the president was already
upstairs i had ascertained that from the
usher
and i went up and i raised with him the
whole question of monica lewinsky and
asked him directly
if he had had sexual relations with
monica lewinsky and the president said
no never all right
now during that conversation did you
tell the president
again that monica lewinsky had been
subpoenaed
well we'd established that all right
and did you tell him that you were
concerned about her fascination i did
and did you describe her as being
emotional in your meeting that day i did
and did you relate to the president
that miss lewinsky asked about whether
he was going to leave the first lady at
the end of the term i did
and as
and then you concluded that
with the question as to whether he had
had sexual relations with ms lewiston
and he said he had not and i was
satisfied in no conversation all right
now once again just as i asked the
question in reference to ms lewinsky it
appears to me that this is an
extraordinary question to ask the
president of the united states
what led you to ask this question to the
president well first of all
i'm asking a question of my friend
who happens to be the president of the
united states
and did you expect your friend the
president united states to give you a
truthful answer i did
did you rely upon the president's answer
and your decision to continue your
efforts to seek ms lewinsky a job i
believed him and i continued to do what
i had been asked to do well my question
was more did you rely upon the
president's answer and your decision to
continue your efforts to seek ms
lewinsky a job i did not rely on his
answer i was going to pursue the job in
any event
but i got the answer to the question
that i'd asked mr lewinsky earlier
from her and i got the answer from him
that night as to the sexual
relationships and he said no
now you'll have to judge for yourself as
to why
mr jordan felt compelled to ask the
question he's asking the right questions
it was important information
if the president had said yes there is
then it had certainly been inappropriate
to continue providing a job benefit for
a witness that you're seeking an
affidavit from denying a relationship
when you know the relationship exists
when that witness would be adverse to
the president's interest who's seeking
the job now
to some that might be convoluted and
perhaps i didn't explain it as best it
can be
but it looks to me like that's why mr
jordan is asking the questions because
he know it would be inappropriate if
that in fact did exist now he got an
answer no i don't know what he thought
in his mind but clearly as you see this
uh conversations developed with miss
lewinsky that she eventually made it
totally clear to him without any
question that there was that
relationship but still the job benefit
was provided now we're not going to have
time to go through it all but
sequentially the next thing that happens
is that december twenty second
uh miss lewinsky goes to mr jordan's
office where
mr jordan drives her in the
chauffeur-driven ache and gum vehicle to
mr frank carter's office
where
the attorney is provided for miss
lewinsky
and that is the only time that has
happened in the referrals that
mr jordan took it upon himself to
personally deliver a client
to mr carter and during that
conversation ms lewinsky tells mr jordan
more of the details of their
relationship but let's go to another
element of obstruction on december 28th
a few days after christmas you're very
familiar with this
episode in which
ms lewinsky and the president meet
they exchange gifts the testimony in the
jones case is discussed
there's concern expressed about the
gifts
she asked the president
in essence
should i
get him out of my house and you'll hear
her answer her testimony is very clear
on this and that's what i would like to
listen to there's no ambiguity there's
no what ifs it is very clear
and
let's move now to the testimony miss
lewinsky
let's uh go back now
and resume where we were before
the lunch
break we were
talking about the december
visit to the white house and
the
conversation with the president
you had uh
discussed uh
well i i think we're to the point where
perhaps you
i'll ask you to bring up your discussion
with the president about the subpoena
and the requested production
part way into my meeting with the
president i
brought up
the concern i had as to how i would have
been put
how i might have been alerted or not
alerted but how i was put on the witness
list and how i might have been alerted
to the paula jones attorneys and that
that was
i sort of concerned about that so i
discussed that a little and then i um
said um that i was concerned about the
hat pin
and
to the best of my memory he said that
that had concerned him as well
and
um could he have said that bothered him
he could have i i mean i don't i know
that sometimes in the um
in my grand jury testimony they've put
quotations around things when i'm
attributing statements to other people
and i didn't necessarily mean that those
were direct quotes that was the just of
what i remembered him saying
um so concerned bothered
was it doesn't
was there discussion at that point as to
how
someone might have may have
discovered that they had pen and paper
he asked me if i had told anybody about
it and i said no
but
the two of you reached no conclusion as
to how that
pin came to appear on the motion no
did he
appear at all
i think probably surprised that that you
had received a request for production of
documents
or the hat pin was on that document i
didn't discuss
we didn't discuss documents
requests for documents but with regard
to the hat pin
i don't remember him being surprised
how long did the discussion last about
the
this a request for production
the topic of the paula jones case may be
in five minutes
not very much
what else was said about that
about the case yes
there was then at
some point in this discussion i think it
was after the hat pin stuff i had said
to him that i was concerned
about the gifts and maybe i should
put them away or possibly give them to
betty
and
as i've testified numerously
his response was either
ranging from no response to
i don't know or let me think about it
i have a long segment at that point but
we're going to stop in the interest of
time but i encourage you to listen to
all of that discussion of miss lewinsky
about the december 28th but what you
just heard was that
she discussed the concern about the
gifts the subpoena with the president of
the united states and that she asked him
or pose the possibility perhaps i should
put them away or possibly give them to
betty and her answer
as to what the president said was i
don't know or let me think about it now
i would agree with you that that's not
enough to convict someone for
obstruction of justice taking it uh
by itself alone but if you take that
statement and one thing
uh
you know that statement troubles you and
whenever you're talking about the
chief executive of the united states
saying i don't know or let me think
about it when you're talking about
evidence that is under subpoena in a
court proceeding that's not the answer
you'd like to hear
but regardless you take that statement
combined with the fact that that miss
lewinsky says unequivocally that it was
betty curry that called subsequent to
that
which is documented by a cell phone call
and then betty curry comes out
in which to pick up the package of gifts
she later places under her bed
everyone knowing this is evidence that's
under subpoena in a case
that
combination of facts gives you the
circumstantial evidence combined with
the direct evidence and testimony that
it had to be the president of the united
states that directed betty curry
that monica lewinsky has something for
you now let's hear what the president
has to say
about what he recalls and this is from
his grand jury testimony august 17 98
after
you gave her the gifts of december 28th
did you speak with your secretary mr
curry
and ask her to pick up the classic gifts
i hope there's any questions on the
compilation of gifts that mr whiskey
would have no sir i didn't do that
i did not do that all right
well that is a different uh uh is not as
sophisticated as a sound collection
system as the united states senate used
and the depositions here and so it i
apologize for the fact that that was
inaudible but the question that was
asked the president after you gave her
the gifts on december 28th did you speak
with your secretary miss curry and ask
her to pick up a box of gifts that were
some compilation of gifts that miss
galenski would have his answer no no sir
i did not do that
now his denial and then you have the
facts that has been presented by the
testimony ms lewinsky and the
circumstantial evidence
the question that was asked to miss
lewinsky did the president ever tell you
to turn over the gifts her answer not
that i remember but she's when i say
that she testified unequivocally
whenever miss lewinsky was asked did you
later that day receive a call from betty
curry the answer was yes i did and she
goes ahead and explains it there is no
hesitation there is no question but the
remember is clear that the call came
from betty curry now how could betty
curry know to go pick up the gifts i
think that you understand how that
there's only one way that could have
come about and that would been through a
communication
from the president to her
and now
let's go on down the path
after we see
the meeting on december 28th there was a
meeting at the hyatt on december 31st
now we could play this video i would
like to with vernon jordan and with miss
lewinsky and this is a meeting at the
hyatt that mr jordan totally denied ever
happened in his first few testimonies
before the grand jury but in his most
recent testimony before the senate in
the deposition
he was confronted with receipts from the
hyatt
and the testimony ms lewinsky which was
clear and the corroboree facts and he
said yes in fact it did happen and not
only did he recall the meeting but then
he recalled what was discussed that yes
in fact notes were discussed there and
miss lewinsky testifies that she raised
the issue of other evidence that would
be possibly
in her apartment notes
to the president and according to her
testimony
she was told that you need to get rid of
those
now mr jordan clearly denies that but
the point is there's more evidence at
risk for the president mr jordan who is
doing the work for the president has
this conversation with ms lewinsky that
he earlier denied ever happening
and so i think you look at the
credibility there do you believe miss
lewinsky if you accept the testimony of
miss lewinsky then you have more
evidence that is issue at issue and that
is being urged to be destroyed and not
available for the truth-seeking endeavor
in the civil rights case i think that is
significant now you say well that's not
the president that is mr jordan you have
to put this in context ms lewinsky who
says that she believes she's talking to
the president when she's talking to mr
jordan and i'm paraphrasing that but
that is what she was seeing in her
seeing mr jordan as a conduit to the
president
and then we go on
after the meeting in the hyatt uh we go
into january where the job search
continues but it is tied directly to the
signing of the affidavit which is false
by its nature
and if we look
at the testimony of mr jordan in the
january 5 time frame where the affidavit
is prepared and discussed with mr jordan
do you know why you would have been
calling mr carter
on three occasions the day before the
affidavit was signed
yeah my recollection is is that
uh
i was
exchanging a sharing mr carter what had
gone on what she had asked me to do what
i refused to do
uh
reaffirming to him that he was a lawyer
i was not the lawyer
uh
i mean it would be so
presumptuous of me to try to advise
frank carter as to how to practice law
would you have been relating to mr
carter your conversation with miss
lewinsky
i may have
and if ms lewinsky expressed to you any
concerns about the affidavit would you
have relayed those to mr carter yes
and
if mr carter was a good attorney that
was concerned about the economics of law
practice he would have likely billed
miss lewinsky for some of those
telephone calls you have to talk to mr
carter about this billy
and so you have mr jordan
discussing the affidavit with both
ms lewinsky and her attorney mr carter
and if you look at the testimony of mr
carter he talks about the fact that he
did bill
some time for his conversations mr
jordan certainly there are matters of
substance in relation to the affidavit
that was being discussed between the
three ms lewinsky mr jordan and mr
carter
and now let's hear what miss lewinsky
has to say on the changes that were made
in the affidavit
okay have you had an opportunity to
review the draft of your affidavit
um i
yes
okay what uh do you have any any comment
or response
um
i received it i made the um
suggested changes
and um
i believe i spoke with mr jordan about
the changes i wanted to make
the last video
now i'm because of time and not going to
be able to go completely through all of
their testimony but let me just take you
time sequentially through what is
happening here and this is the second
page of the time chart that you have
with january 5th and 6th the affidavit
was repaired discussed with mr jordan
and with the president on the 7th the
affidavit is signed and you recall mr
jordan
lets the president know that the
affidavit was signed and he says he was
interested
he was obviously interested in this
on january 8th the job came through the
day after the affidavit is signed and of
course it had to come through with a
personal call from mr jordan to mr
pearlman to make it happen if it can
happen once that job is secured the
president is informed mission
accomplished
uh january 15th there's some inquiries
in the news media about
the gifts that had been delivered to the
white house this makes betty curry
nervous enough that he she has to go see
mr jordan about it
17th the president gives his deposition
in which that false affidavit is
presented
in behalf of miss lewinsky and the
president's attorney
and then the next day after
that deposition is given you go to
january 18th where he is very concerned
because he mentions betty curry's name
so many times
now
we were not able to we did not ask for
the deposition of betty curry we wish
that we had had that opportunity we'd
like to call her here but that is one of
the most critical and most important
elements of instruction in which the
proof is so critically clear
because it happened not just on one day
but it happened on a couple of days
we see on the 17th the president is
deposed
and this is the third chart that you
have the 18th the president coaches
betty curry going through the series of
questions on the 19th there is this
dramatic search for miss lewinsky on the
20th the washington post story becomes
known because the president's counselors
get calls and the oic investigation
becomes known on the 21st at 12 30 a.m
the post story appears on the internet
at 12 41 the president calls bruce
lindsay at 1 16 a.m after the post story
appears the president calls betty curry
for 20 minutes discusses the post story
and then according to betty curry on the
20th or the 21st it was that was the
second incident of coaching that took
place where the president calls her in
and goes through that series of
questions i did nothing wrong she came
on to me
we were never alone
and so that was the second time that it
happened
and that
ladies and gentlemen the senate is
another example of witness tampering a
known witness clearly going to be
testifying a subordinate employee who is
called in
and coached now the president says i was
trying to gain facts you determine that
you are the ones that have to defend
that question as to whether under common
sense the president was gaining
information on two separate occasions or
whether he was actually trying to tamper
with the testimony of a witness the 21st
she's subpoenaed by the oic the 23rd
she's added to the jones witness list
and now i want to play the last
video clip that i'm going to move to
on ms lewinsky and some things that she
said that are
different in regard to the president
the president did not in that
conversation on december the 17th
of 1997 or any other conversation for
that matter instruct you to tell the
truth is that correct
that's correct
but the the pattern
that you had had with the president the
to conceal this relationship it was
never a question that
for instance at that given day that he
gave you gifts you were not going to
surrender those to the jones attorneys
because that would in my mind there was
never a question no
we have one more here i would like you
to listen to
sure gosh i think to me that if if the
president had not said the betty and
letters cover let's just say if we refer
to that which i'm talking about in
paragraph four page four i would have
known to use that so to me encouraging
or asking me to lie would have you know
if the president had said now listen you
better not say anything about this
relationship you never you better not
tell them the truth you better not for
me the best way to explain how i feel
what happened was you know no one asked
or encouraged me to lie but no one
discouraged me either
it's very important to understand
that
we want you to know very clearly miss
lewinsky says that the president never
told her to lie there's no question
about that there's no dispute about that
either i think you have to look at all
the context of this now what the
president did suggest to her was to use
a fault an affidavit to avoid truthful
testimony to
stick with the cover stories under legal
context is the issue here whether miss
lewinsky
believed the president was encouraging
her to lie that what the president was
trying to do here
or is the issue what the president was
trying to do it is your determination
you have to make the decision whether
the president and talking to a 24 year
old
ex-employee
whether he is encouraging her to come
forward and to tell the truth or in a
legal context to use the old cover
stories to lie
to use false affidavits to avoid the
truth from coming out
it's not
mr lewinsky's viewpoint that's important
it is what the president intended what
did the president intend by this
conversation when he told her on
december 17th guess what bad news you're
a witness then he proceeded to suggest
to her ways to avoid truthful testimony
i really don't care what is in miss
lewinsky's mind at that point the
critical issue is what is in the
president's mind at that point as to
what he intended was it an
innocent conversation or was it a
conversation with corrupt intent and i
believe that if you put all of this in
context
from the affidavit to the job search to
the coaching of miss betty curry to all
of the other conversations with the
aides that it was the president's intent
to avoid the workings of the
administration of justice to impede the
flow of the truth in the administration
of justice for his own benefit and that
is what obstruction of justice is about
that is what people go to jail about and
that is what
we are presenting to you as a factual
basis for this case and now i yield to
my fellow manager mr robin
mr chief justice uh i think it would be
appropriate that we uh take a break at
this time for lunch and then we return
at 1 15. i ask consent could that be the
case without objection it's so ordered
the senate now taking a recess until one
good afternoon yes good afternoon hi um
i'm for conviction uh uh
during this i think that demand has lied
obstructed will be in order
the chair recognizes the majority thank
you mr chief justice i believe we are
ready to presume the presentation by the
house managers and manager rogan
is prepared to receive the chair
recognized mr manager rogan
members of the senate before the break
you had the opportunity to hear the
variable presentation from mr manager
hutchinson relating to the article of
impeachment alleging obstruction of
justice against the president of the
united states
i would like to use my portion to
discuss very briefly article 1 of the
impeachment resolution that alleges on
august 17 1998 the president committed
perjury
before a federal grand jury conducting a
criminal investigation
he did this in a number of ways
embarking on a calculated effort to
cover up illegal obstruction of justice
first the president lied
about statements he made to his top
aides regarding his relationship with
monica lewinsky
this is significant
because the president admitted under
oath that he knew these aids were
potential witnesses before a criminal
grand jury
well you knew that
and so i said to them things that were
true about this relationship
that i used in the in the language i
used i said there's nothing going on
between us that was true
i said
i have not had sex with her as i define
it that was true
and did i hope
that i would never have to be here on
this day giving this testimony of course
but i also didn't want to do anything to
complicate
this matter further so i said things
that were true
they may have been misleading and if
they were i have to take responsibility
for it and i'm sorry it may have been
misleading sir and you knew though after
january 21st when the post article broke
and said that judge starr was looking
into this he knew that they might be
witnesses
he knew that they might be called into a
grand jury didn't you that's right
do you recall
denying
any sexual relationship
with
monica lewinsky to the following people
harry thompson erskine bowles
harold ickes
mr podesta mr blumenthal
mr jordan miss betty curry do you recall
denying
any sexual relations
the question to the president
you knew they might be called into a
grand jury didn't you
answer by the president
that's right
the president's testimony that he said
things that were misleading but true to
his aides
was perjury
just as the president predicted
several of his top aides later were
called to testify before the grand jury
as to what the president told them and
when they testified before the grand
jury they passed along the president's
false account
just as the president intended
the president's former chief of staff
erskine bowles and his current chief of
staff john podesta
went before the grand jury and testified
that the president told them
he did not have sexual relations with
monica
and he did not ask anybody to lie
mr podesta had an additional meeting
with the president two days after the
story broke
mr podesta testified that at that
meeting with the president
the president was extremely explicit in
saying he never had sex with her in any
way whatsoever and that he was not alone
with her
in the oval office
the most glaring example
of the president using an aide as a
messenger of lies to the grand jury
was his manipulation of presidential
assistant sydney blumenthal mr
blumenthal has been assistant to the
president since august of 1997.
mr blumenthal testified
that dealing with the media was one of
his responsibilities on january 21st
1998 the day the monica lewinsky story
broke
mr blumenthal testified under oath that
once the story became public he attended
twice a day white house strategy
sessions called to deal with the
political legal and media impact
of the clinton scandals on the white
house
in his deposition testimony taken just
this week by authority of the united
states senate
mr blumenthal shared
in chilling detail
the story of how the president responded
to the public discovery of his
long-standing relationship with a young
woman who had shared tearful and
emotional descriptions of her love for
him
mr clinton responded not in love
not in friendship not even with a grain
of concern for her well-being or
emotional stability instead the
president took the deep
and apparently unrequited emotional
attachment monica lewinsky had formed
for him
and prepared to summarily take her life
and throw it on the ash heap
the date is january twenty first
nineteen ninety eight
the lewinsky scandal had just broken in
the newspapers that morning
mr blumenthal met initially with the
first lady mrs clinton to get her take
on the growing political firestorm
later that day mr blumenthal is summoned
to the oval office
listen as sidney blumenthal describes
step by step
the destructive mechanism
of the man who twice was elected
president under the banner of feeling
other people's pain
mr blumenthal specifically
inviting your attention
to january 21st
1998.
you testified before the grand jury
that on that date you personally spoke
to the president regarding the monica
lewinsky mata correct yes
thank you
you are familiar with the washington
post story that broke that day
i am
the story stated that the office of
independent council was investigating
whether the president made false
statements about his relationship with
ms lewinsky in the jones case
right
and also that the office of independent
council was investigating whether the
president obstructed justice in the
jones case is that your
best recollection of what that story was
about
uh yes
and so you now remember that the
president asked to speak with you
yes
did you go to the oval office yes
during that conversation were you alone
with the president i was
do you remember the door was closed
uh it was
when you met with the president
did you relate to him a conversation you
had with the first lady earlier that day
i did
what did you tell the president
the first lady told you earlier that day
i believe that i told him that the
first lady had called me
earlier in the day
and
in the
light of the story in the post
had told me that
the president
had
helped troubled people in the past
and that
he had done it many times
and that he was a compassionate person
and that
he helped people also out of his
religious conviction
and that
this was a part of
part of his nature
and did she also tell you that one of
the other reasons he helped people was
out of his personal temperament
yes that's what i mean by that
you remember telling the president that
the first lady
said to you that she felt that with in
reference to the story that he was being
attacked for political motives
i remember her saying that to me yes and
you relayed that to the president i'm
not sure i relayed that to the president
i
may have just relayed the gist of the
conversation to him
i don't i'm not sure whether i relayed
the entire conversation
inviting
the senators and counsel's attention to
the june 4
1998
testimony of mr blumenthal
page 47.
beginning at line five
mr blumenthal let me just read a passage
to you and tell me if this helps to
refresh your your memory
yes i do thank you
reading at the line at line five i was
in my office and the president asked me
to come to the oval office i was seeing
him frequently in this period about the
state of the union
blair's visit that was prime minister
tony blair is on the side correct that's
right thank you
and then again reading at line seven
so i went up to the oval office and i
began the discussion and i said that i
had received that i had spoken to the
first lady
that day in the afternoon about the
story that had broken the morning
and i related to the president my
conversation with the first lady and the
conversation went as follows
the first lady said that she was
distressed that the president was being
attacked
in her view
for political motives
for his ministry of a troubled person
she said that the president minister is
a troubled people all the time and then
it goes on to relate to the substance of
the answer you just gave does that help
to refresh your recollection with
respect to what you told the president
the first lady had said earlier
yes thank you and do you now remember
that the first lady had indicated to you
that she felt the president was being
attacked for political motives
i remember she said that to me
and just getting us back on track a few
moments ago i think you
you shared with us that
the first lady said that the president
helped troubled people and he had done
it many times in the past yes do you
remember testifying before the grand
jury
uh on that subject saying that the first
lady said he has done this dozens if not
hundreds of times with people
i recall that
after you related
the conversation that you had with the
first lady to the president
what do you remember saying to the
president next
about the subject that monica lewinsky
well i recall
telling him
that
i understood he felt that way
and that
he did help people
but that um
he should stop trying to help troubled
people personally
that
troubled people are troubled
and that they can get you in a lot of
messes
and that you had to cut yourself off
from it
and you just had to do it
that's what i recall saying to him
do you also remember in that
conversation saying to him
you really need to not do that at this
point that you can't get near anybody
who is even remotely crazy your
president
yes i think that was a little later in
the conversation but i do recall saying
that
when you told the president that he
should avoid contact with troubled
people what did the president say to you
in response
trying to remember the sequence of it
he uh he said that was very difficult
for him
he said
he uh he felt a need to help troubled
people
and
it was hard for him to
to cut himself off from doing that
do you remember him saying specifically
it's very difficult for me to do that
given how i am i want to help people
i recall i recall that
and when the president referred to
trying to help people did you understand
him in that conversation to be referring
to monica lewinsky
i think it included monica lewinsky but
also
many others right but it was your
understanding that he was all he was
specifically referring to monica
lewinsky in that list of people that he
tried to help
uh i believe that
that was implied
do you remember being asked that
question before the grand jury and
giving the answer
i understood that
uh if you could point it out to me and
be happy to see it uh inviting the
senators and counsel's attention to the
june 25th 1998 grand jury
page five
i believe it's at lines six through
eight
yes i see that
thank you you recall that now yes thank
you
following this conversation
where mr blumenthal told the president
about his conversation with the first
lady that day
the president told mr blumenthal
about the president's own conversation
he had earlier that day with his
pollster dick morris
mr blumenthal did the president then
relate a conversation he had with dick
morris to you
uh he did
what was the substance of that
conversation as the president related it
to you
uh he said that he had spoken to dick
morris earlier that day
and that
dick morris had told him
that
if nixon richard nixon had given a
nationally televised
speech at the beginning of the
watergate affair
acknowledging everything he'd done wrong
he
may well have survived it
and
that was the conversation
that dick morris
that's what dick moore said to the
president did it sound to you like the
president was suggesting perhaps he
would go on television and give a
national speech
i don't know i didn't know and when the
president related
the substance of his conversation with
dick morris to you how did you respond
to that
i said to the president
uh well what have you done wrong
did he reply he did what did he say he
said i haven't done anything wrong
and what did you say to that response
well
i said as i recall that's one of the
stupidest ideas i ever heard if you
haven't done anything wrong why would
you do that
after denying to mr blumenthal any
wrongdoing with monica lewinsky
the president then struck the harshest
of blows
against her
he launched a preemptive strike
against her name and her character to an
aide that he expected would be
and very shortly became
a witness before a federal grand jury
investigation
did the president then give you his
account of what happened
between him and monica lewinsky
uh as i recall he did
what did the president tell you um
he uh
he spoke uh fairly rapidly as i recall
at that point
and said that
she had come on to him
and
made a demand for sex that rebuffed her
turned her down
and
that
she threatened him
and
he said that she said to him
that
she was
called the stalker by her peers
and that she hated the term
and that
she would claim
that they had
had an affair whether they had or they
hadn't
and that she would tell people
you remember him also saying
that
the reason monica lewinsky would tell
people that is because then she wouldn't
be known by her peers as the stalker
anymore
yes that's right
do you remember the president also
saying that and i'm quoting i've gone
down that road before i've caused pain
for a lot of people i'm not going to do
that again
yeah he told me that and that was in the
same conversation that you have with
president right and
in that sequence
can you describe for us the president's
demeanor when he shared this information
with you
yes
uh he was
very upset
i thought he was a man in anguish
and at that point did you repeat your
earlier admonition to him
as far as not trying to help troubled
people
i did i i think that's when i told him
that you can't get near crazy people
uh or troubled people
you're president you just have to
separate yourself from this
and i'm not sure based on your testimony
if you gave that admonition to him once
or twice let me let me clarify for you
why my questioning suggested it was
twice
in your grand jury testimony on june the
4th
at page 49
beginning at line 25
[Music]
you began the sentence by saying and i
quote and i repeated to the president
right that he really needed never to be
near people who were troubled like this
and so forth
do you remember now if you
if that was correct did you did you find
yourself in that conversation having to
repeat the admonition to him that you'd
given earlier i'm sure i did um
i felt
i felt that pretty strongly you
shouldn't
be involved with troubled people
do you remember the president also
saying something about being like a
character in a novel to do what did he
say
uh he said to me um that
uh he felt like a character in a novel
uh he felt like somebody
uh surrounded by an oppre an oppressive
environment that was creating a lie
about him he said he felt like
the character in the novel darkness at
noon
did he also say
he felt like he can't get the truth out
yes i believe he said that
politicians are always loathed to
confess their ignorance particularly on
videotape i will do so uh i'm unfamiliar
with the novel darkness at noon did you
have do you have any familiarity with
that or did you understand what the
president meant by that
i understood what he meant i i was
familiar with the book what what did he
mean by that for your understanding
um
the book is
by arthur kessler who was somebody who'd
been a communist and had become
disillusioned with communism and it's an
anti-communist novel
it's about um
the stalinist purge trials and somebody
who was a loyal communist
who
then is put in a
one of stalin's prisons and
held on trial and executed
and it's about his trial
did you understand what the president
was trying to communicate when he
related his situation to the character
in that novel
i think he felt that the world was
against him
i thought only members of congress
touched that way
the president continued to pass along
false information to mr blumenthal
regarding the substance of his
relationship with monica lewinsky
mr blumenthal did you ever ask the
president if he was ever alone with
monica lewinsky
i did what was his response
i asked him a number of questions that
appeared in the press that day
i asked him uh if he were alone and he
said that
he was within
eyesight or earshot of someone when he
was with her
what other questions do you remember
asking him um there was a story in the
paper that there were recorded
messages
left by him on her voicemail and i asked
him if that were true
what did he say
he said
that it was that
he called her
you had asked him
about a press account that said there
were
potentially a number
of telephone messages left by the
president for monica lewinsky
and he relayed to you that he called her
did he tell you how many times he called
her he did he said he called once
he said he called when betty curry's
brother had died to tell her that
and other than that one time that he
shared that information with you he
shared no other information respecting
additional calls
no
he never indicated to you
that there were
over 50 telephone conversations between
himself and monica lewinsky no
based on your conversation with the
president at that time would it have
surprised you to know that there were
over 50 there were records of over 50
telephone conversations with monica
lewinsky and the president
would i've been surprised at that time
yes um
i to see those records and if he i don't
fully grasp the question here could you
would i've been surprised based on the
president's response to your question at
that time
would it have surprised you
to have been told or to have later
learned that there were over 50
recorded
50
conversations between the president and
ms lewinsky i didn't later learn that
as the whole country did
and i was surprised
when the president
told you that monica lewinsky threatened
him
did you ever feel compelled to report
that information to the secret service
no
the fbi or any other
law enforcement
organization
now
i'm assuming
that a threat
to the president from somebody in the
white house would normally
send off alarm bells among staff
well i'd like to object to the question
senator there's no testimony that that
mr blumenthal learned of a threat
contemporaneously was it being made by
someone in the white house
this is a threat that was relayed to him
sometime afterwards
by someone who was no longer employed in
the white house so i think the question
uh doesn't relate to the testimony of
this witness respectfully i'm not sure
what the legal basis of the objection is
the the evidence before us is that
the the president told the witness
that monica lewinsky threatened him well
i think the answer is that he would say
it was all contemporaneous and i didn't
uh think it appropriate so i gotta
answer
we've conferred and uh overruled the
objection on the ground that
uh it calls for an answer
that uh however the witness chooses to
answer it
was not a contemporaneous threat or he
thought it was stale or whatever he
thinks but the injection is overruled
thank you let me let me restate the
question if i may
uh mr blumenthal what a threat
senator specter the ruling is just fine
by my life i'm just going to try to
simplify the question for the witness as
a benefit
we'll hold an advanced decision on
whether to reinstate
maybe i should just quit while i'm ahead
and
have the question right back basically
mr blumenthal what i'm asking is i mean
normally
would a threat from somebody against the
president in the white house
typically require
some sort of report being made to a law
enforcement agency uh in the in the
in the abstract yes
this conversation that you had with the
president
on january the 21st 1998
how did that conversation conclude
uh i believe we
um
well i believe it after that i said to
the president that
was
seemed to me to be upset
that you needed to find some sure
footing
and
to be confident
and
we went on i believe to discuss the
state of the union you went on to other
business yes we went on to
talk about public policy
when this conversation
with the president concluded as it
related to monica lewinsky what were
your
feelings toward the president's
statement
[Music]
well they were complex um
i believed him
but i was also
i thought he was very upset
that troubled me
and i also was
troubled by his association
with
troubled people
and
thought this was
not a good story
and uh thought he shouldn't be doing
this
do you remember also testifying before
the grand jury
that you felt that the president's story
was a very heartfelt story
and that he was pouring out his heart
and i believed him
yes that's what i told the grand jury i
believed right that was that was how you
interpreted the president's story
yeah
i did he was
he seemed
he seemed emotional
when the president told you he was
helping monica lewinsky did he ever
describe to you how he might be helping
or ministering to her
no
did he ever describe how many times he
may have tried to help her minister to
her no
did he tell you how many times he
visited with monica lewinsky
no
did he tell you how many times
monica lewinsky visited him in the oval
office complex
no
did he tell you how many times
he was alone with monica velinski
no he never described to you any
intimate physical activity he may have
had with monica
oh no
did the president ever tell you
that he gave any gifts to monica
lewinsky no
does he tell you that monica lewinsky
gave him any gifts no
based on the president's
story as he related on january 21st
would it have surprised you to know at
that time that there was a repeated gift
exchange between monica lewinsky and the
president
well
i learned later about that
and i was surprised
the president never told you that he
engaged in occasional sexual banter with
her on the telephone now
he never told you about any cover
stories that he and monica lewinsky may
have developed to disguise a
relationship no
he never suggested to you that there
might be some physical evidence
pointing to a physical relationship
between between himself and monica
lewinsky now
did the president ever discuss his grand
jury test or strike that the president
ever discussed his deposition testimony
with you in the paul jones case
on that date oh no
did he ever tell you that he denied
under oath in his paula jones deposition
that he had an affair with monica
lewinsky no
did the president ever tell you that he
ministered to anyone else
who then made a sexual advance toward
him
no
one of the things that the president's
council
has continually urged upon
this body as they did over in the house
of representatives
is to look
committed the crime of perjury
we hope that you will do that
because nowhere is the president's state
of mind more evident than it is in the
manner
in which he dealt with sydney blumenthal
at this point
remember
the date of this conversation that
sydney blumenthal just related to you
was january the 21st the day the monaco
lewinsky story broke
about a month later
sydney blumenthal was called to testify
as a witness before the grand jury that
was the first time
five months later or four months later
sydney blumenthal was called back to
testify to the grand jury not once
but two more times
from january 21st until the end of june
1998
the president had almost six months
in which to tell sydney blumenthal after
he was subpoenaed but before he
testified
not to tell the grand jury information
that was false the president had the
opportunity to not use his aid as a
conduit of false information
listen to what sidney blumenthal said
the president
failed to tell him
after you were subpoenaed to testify but
before you testified before the federal
grand jury
did the president ever recant his
earlier statements to you about monica
lewinsky
no
after you were subpoenaed but before you
testified before the federal grand jury
did the president ever say that he did
not want you to mislead the grand jury
with a false statement
no we didn't have any subsequent
conversation about this matter
so it would be fair also to say that
after you were subpoenaed but before you
testified before the federal grand jury
the president never told you that he was
not being truthful with you
in that january 21st conversation about
monica lewinsky
he never spoke to me about that at all
the president never instructed you
before your testimony before the grand
jury
not to relay
his false account of his relationship
with monica we didn't speak about
anything
president of the united states
used a special assistant one of his
aides as a conduit to go before a
federal grand jury and present false and
misleading information and preclude the
grand jury from being able to make an
honest determination in their
investigation he obstructed justice when
he did it and when he denied that
activity he committed the offense of
perjury
in response to a question from mr
manager graham
mr blumenthal candidly addressed the
president's claim under oath that he was
truthful with his aides
that he knew would be future grand jury
witnesses
knowing what you know now
do you believe the president lied to you
about his relationship with ms lewinsky
i do
appreciate your honesty
is it a fair statement giving your
previous testimony concerning your
30-minute conversation
that the president was trying to portray
himself
as a victim
of a relationship with monica lewinsky
i think that's the import of his whole
story
in an earlier presentation the
president's attorney mr ruff
said that the very same denial the
president made to his family and his
friends
was the same one he made to the american
people mr ruff said
having made the announcement to the
whole country it is simply absurd i
suggest to you to believe that he
somehow
was attempting corruptly to influence
his senior staff when he told them
virtually the same thing
at the same time
members of the senate mr ruff's
conclusion is wrong
because his premise is wrong
the president didn't tell the american
public and his aides the same thing
nor did he make the very same denial
on the contrary the president went out
of his way with his aides to make
explicit denials coupled with character
assassination
against monica lewinsky why the
distinction
because the american public was not
destined to be subpoenaed as a witness
before the grand jury
and the president's aides were
members of the senate our time draws
short the record is replete
with other examples which i have
addressed and mr manager hutchinson has
addressed dealing with the president's
perjuries in other areas for instance in
the paula jones deposition where he
emphatically
denied
having a relationship with monica
lewinsky that we now know to be true a
relationship that a federal judge
ordered him to discuss with paula
jones's attorneys because it was
relevant information and the sexual
civil harassment
lawsuit
the president's perjuries with respect
to petty curry and using betty curry as
somebody to be
brought into the oval office
so that he could coach her as a witness
and doing everything he could in his own
testimony to ensure that the jones
attorneys would subpoena her as a
witness to once again use the white
house aid as a conduit of false
information before the grand jury i
don't feel the need to have to go over
this ground with you any further in my
final couple of minutes
before i reserve time
i do want to raise one last point
because i think it's a valid one and it
perhaps in the long run is the most
important point
that this body should consider
in coming to their verdict
we have heard an awful lot
throughout this entire episode
about the idea of proportionality of
punishment
we've also heard that lying about sex
somehow minimizes the perjury
because everybody does it
many people
in everyday life
under the stress of ordinary relations
may well lie about personal matters
when confronted with embarrassing
situations
but no
everybody doesn't commit perjury under
oath in a court proceeding having been
ordered by a federal judge to answer
questions
and if they do they generally don't
expect to keep their job or their
liberty if they get caught
the dispensation this president wants
for himself is not the same dispensation
he grants
as head of the executive branch to
ordinary americans when they lie about
sex under oath
bill clinton wants it both ways
the question before this body is whether
you're going to give it to him
during our committee hearings
we learned the clinton administration
had no shyness
in prosecuting other people for lying
under oath about consensual sex and
civil cases even when the underlying
civil case was dismissed
for instance
dr barbara battalino
was an attorney and a va doctor
when she began a relationship with one
of her counseling patients at a va
hospital
on a single occasion
she performed an inappropriate sexual
act with him in her office
the patient later sued the veterans
administration for among other things
sexual harassment
during a deposition in this civil
lawsuit
dr batolino was asked if anything of a
sexual nature took place in her office
with the patient
fearing embarrassment disgrace and the
loss of her job
dr battalino answered no
later she learned the patient had tape
recorded conversations which proved that
she lied about sex under oath
even though the patient's harassment
case was eventually dismissed
the clinton justice department
prosecuted dr battalino
she lost her medical license
she lost her right to practice law
she was fired from her job
she later agreed to a plea bargain she
was fined three thousand five hundred
dollars and sentenced to six months of
imprisonment under electronic monitoring
listen to the words of dr battalino as
she testified before the house judiciary
committee and then explain to her the
theory of proportionality
if you can
dr
batalin catalino uh your your case
intrigues me
i want to make sure i understand the
factual circumstances you lied about a
one-time act of consensual sex with
someone on federal property is that
correct
absolutely correct and this act of
perjury was in a civil lawsuit not in a
criminal case that's also correct and in
fact the civil case eventually was
dismissed correct
yet despite the dismissal you were
prosecuted by the clinton justice
department for this act of perjury is
that correct that's correct what i want
to know
dr batolino
during your ordeal
during your prosecution
did anybody from the white house
from the justice department did any
members of congress did any
academics from respected universities
ever show up at your trial and suggest
that you should be treated lenient with
leniency because everybody lies about
sex
no sir did anybody ever come forward
from the white house or from the justice
department and urge leniency for you
because your perjury was only in a civil
case no did they argue for leniency
because the civil case at which you
committed perjury was ultimately
dismissed no
did anybody from the white house ever
say that leniency should be granted to
you because you otherwise did your job
very well no did anybody ever come
forward from congress to suggest that
you were the victim of an overzealous or
sex obsessed prosecutor no
now
according to the new york times
they report that
you lied when your lawyer asked you at a
deposition
whether quote anything of a sexual
nature unquote occurred is that correct
yes that's correct did anybody from
congress or from the white house come
forward to defend you saying that that
phrase was ambiguous or it all depended
what the word anything meant
no sir may i just uh i'm not sure if it
was my lawyer that asked the question
but that is the exact question that i
was asked question that you were asked
that caused your prosecution
for perjury that's correct no one ever
argued that that phrase itself was
ambiguous didn't they no
uh regrettably my time is limited uh and
i will not yield for that purpose
now
doctor
you lost two licenses you lost a law
license well i have a law degree i i was
not a member of any bar your conviction
precludes you from practicing law that's
correct sir you also had a medical
degree that's correct you lost your
medical degree yes i am no longer
permitted to to practice medicine either
did anybody from the white house or from
congress come forward during your
prosecution or during your sentencing
and suggest that rather than you suffer
the incredibly
uh difficult
uh punishment of no longer being able to
practice your profession perhaps you
should simply just receive some sort of
rebuke or censure
no one came to my aid or defense nobody
from the justice department suggested
that during your sentencing hearing now
has anybody come forward from the white
house
to suggest to you that in light of
circumstances
as we now appear to see them unfolding
you should be pardoned for your for your
offense nobody has come now
that's how the clinton administration
defines proportionality in punishment mr
chief justice we reserve the balance of
our time
very well
the uh
chair recognizes the majority leader mr
chief justice uh i believe now we would
be prepared to go to
up to three hours by the white house
council and
how much time is remaining for the house
managers
31 minutes
would the chief justice
suggested we take a brief break here
let's keep going all right sir
i guess that settles that way i'll ask
you again later
the chair recognizes uh miss council
seligman
mr chief justice ladies and gentlemen of
the senate the house managers have
suggested to you that the deposition of
ms lewinsky helped their case
the opposite is true
ms lewinsky undermined critical aspects
of the house manager's obstruction case
as those of you who watched the entire
video are well aware the managers have
cleverly snipped here and there in an
effort to present their story
even if as a result
the story they are telling you is not ms
lewinsky's story
they have distorted
they have omitted and they have created
a profoundly erroneous impression
so let's look at the facts
in her deposition this week ms lewinsky
reaffirmed her previous testimony and
provided extremely useful supplements to
that testimony
we asked her no questions
why
because there was no need her testimony
exonerated the president
in four areas in particular what she
said demonstrates that the allegations
in the articles cannot stand
first she refuted the allegations in
article 2 subpart 1 with respect to
alleged efforts to obstruct
and influence ms lewinsky's affidavit
second she contradicted the allegations
in article two subpart two with respect
to alleged efforts to influence ms
lewinsky's testimony as distinct from
her affidavit
third she undermined the allegations in
article 2 subpart 3 with respect to
alleged efforts to conceal gifts
and fourth she rebutted
the allegations in article 2 subpart 4
with respect to ms lewinsky's job search
i will discuss each briefly
let's begin with the december 17 phone
call between the president and ms
lewinsky which is at the heart of
article two's first two subparts
the managers have consistently
exaggerated the facts
the impact and the import of this
conversation
they have relentlessly argued that you
should draw inferences and conclusions
that are not supported by the evidence
ms lewinsky's testimony this week should
put an end to these inflated claims
about that call
article 2 charges in subpart 1 that the
president
on or about december 17 1997
corruptly encouraged a witness in a
federal civil rights action brought
against him to execute a sworn affidavit
in that proceeding that he knew to be
prejudious false and misleading
on or about december 17.
in other words the allegation is firmly
grounded in the december 17 phone call
that's where the house of
representatives charged the deed was
done
that's the single event on which the
managers base the first obstruction of
justice charge
indeed mr manager mccollum made this
point emphatically before the senate he
claimed and i quote in this context the
evidence is compelling that the
president committed both the crimes of
obstruction of justice and witness
tampering right then and there on
december 17.
he went on now monica lewinsky
lewinsky's testimony is so clear about
this that the president's lawyers
probably won't spend a lot of time with
you on this they didn't in the judiciary
committee i could be wrong and they
probably will just to show me i am wrong
well mr mccollum was wrong in one
respect we do plan to spend time on that
call but he was absolutely right in
another respect
he was correct that ms lewinsky's
testimony is so clear on this issue
it is so clear it exonerates the
president
the managers asked this body to permit
the deposition and later the live
testimony of ms lewinsky to complete
their proof
as mr manager bryant stated an
appropriate examination and an
appropriate cross-examination i might
add let's don't limit the white house
attorneys here of ms lewinsky on the
factual disputes of the affidavit and
their cover story wouldn't that be nice
to hear
well the managers got their examination
of ms lewinsky about the december 17
phone call
and it defeated the charge
it showed that she and the president
did not discuss the content of an
affidavit
never
ever again the managers ask you to
convict the president and remove him
from office for what turns out to be his
silence
no discussion of content
let's listen to the testimony of monica
lewinsky about that december 17 phone
call
it's critically important and we're
showing it to you unvarnished not in
snippets because the snippets you have
seen are terribly misleading
the tape you will hear establishes
beyond doubt
that she and the president did not
discuss the content of the affidavit in
that call
or ever
it establishes beyond doubt that what
happened is not obstruction of justice
sometime back in the december of 1997 in
the morning december the 17th
did you receive a call from the
president yes
what was the
purpose of that call
what did you talk about it was threefold
uh first to tell me uh that miss curry's
brother had been killed in a car
accident
second to tell me
that my name was on a witness list for
the paula jones case
and
thirdly
he mentioned that hit the christmas
present he had for me
this telephone call was somewhere in the
early morning hours of two o'clock to 2
30. correct did it surprise you that he
called you so late
no
was this your first notice
of your your name being on the paula
jones witness list
yes
i realize he commented about some other
things but i do want to focus on the
witness list
did he say anything to you about how he
felt
concerning this witness list
[Music]
he said it broke his heart
that well that my name was on the
witness listener though
can i take a sure
sure we'll take it we'll take
did we get your response we were talking
about the
discussion you were having with the
president uh over the telephone early
morning of the december 17 phone call
and he had uh mentioned it it broke his
heart that
you were on that list correct
and
i think you were about to comment
on that further and then you needed the
break no no
i just wanted to be able to focus i know
this is an important date so i felt i
need a few minutes to be able to focus
on it
and you're comfortable
now with that with your
you're ready to talk about it
comfortable i don't know but i'm ready
to talk about it comfortable that you
can focus yes sir okay
um
now with this discussion of the fact
that your name appeared as a witness
had you
had you been asleep that night when the
phone rang yes so were you were you wide
awake by this point it's the president
calling you so i guess you're
you know you wake up
[Music]
i wouldn't say wide awake
uh
he expressed to you that your name you
know again you talked about some other
things but he told you your name was on
the list correct
what was your reaction to that
i was scared
what other
discussion did you have
regard to
the fact that your name was on the list
you were scared he was disappointed or
it broke his heart what other other
discussion did you have uh i believe he
said that
um
and these are not necessarily direct
quotes but to the best of my memory that
he said something about that
just because my name was on the list
didn't necessarily mean i'd be
subpoenaed
and at some point i asked him
you know what i should do if i
received a subpoena
he said i should
i should let ms curry know um
did he say anything about an affidavit
yes
what what did he say
he said that um
that i could possibly file an affidavit
if i if i were subpoenaed that i could
possibly file an affidavit maybe to
avoid being deposed
how did he tell you you would avoid
being deposed
by filing an affidavit
i don't think he did
you just accepted that statement
yes yes sorry
[Music]
are you
did he make it strike did he make any
representation to you about
what you could say in that affidavit or
no
what did you understand you would be
saying in that affidavit to avoid
testifying
uh i believe i've testified to this in
the grand jury uh
the best of my recollection it was uh
to my mind it came was a range of things
i mean could either be
um
something innocuous or
could go as far as having to deny the
relationship
not being a lawyer nor having gone to
law school was
i thought it could be anything
did he
at that point suggest one version or the
other version
no i didn't even mention that
so that there wasn't a further
discussion there was no discussion of
what would be
in an affidavit
when you say um
it would be it could have been something
that where the relationship was denied
what what was your thinking at that
point
i i i think i don't understand what
you're asking me i'm sorry
well
based on prior
uh
relations with the president the
concocted stories and those things like
that did this come to mind
was there some discussion about that or
did it come to your mind about
not in connection with this not not in
connection with the affidavit
how would uh it was any discussion on
how you would accomplish uh
preparing or filing an affidavit at that
point
no
why why didn't you want to testify
why would not
why would you wanted to avoid testifying
first of all i thought it was nobody's
business
second of all i didn't want to have
anything to do
with paula jones or her case
and
i guess those two reasons
you you've already mentioned that you
we're not a lawyer you've not been to
law school those kinds of things
did
did you understand uh when you
the potential legal problems that you
could have caused yourself
about allowing a false affidavit to be
filed with a court
in a court proceeding
during what time i mean
can you be
well at this point i may ask it again at
later points but are you referring to
december 17th the night of the phone
call he's suggesting you could file an
affidavit
did you
appreciate the implications of filing a
false affidavit with the with the court
i don't think i necessarily thought at
that point it would have to be false
so
no probably not i don't i don't remember
having any thoughts like that so
i
imagine i would remember something like
that and i don't but
did you know what an affidavit was
sort of
of course you're talking at that time
i telephoned to the president and he's
he is a lawyer he
taught law school i don't know did you
know that did you know he was a lawyer
i think i knew it but it wasn't
something that was present
in my in my thoughts
as in he's a lawyer he's telling me you
know something
did the president president ever tell
you caution you that you had to tell the
truth in an affidavit
not that i recall
it would have been against his interest
in that lawsuit for you to have told the
truth would it not
i'm not really comfortable i mean i can
tell you what would have been in my best
interest but
i
but you didn't file the affidavit for
your best interest did you
um
actually i did
to avoid testifying yes
but had you testified truthfully
you would have had no
certainly no legal implications it may
have been embarrassing but you would
have not had any legal problems with you
that's true
did you discuss
anything else that night
in terms of
i would draw your attention to uh the
cover stories i've alluded to that
earlier but
did you did you talk about cover story
that night yes sir
and what was said
um
i believe that
the president said something
you can always say you were coming to
see betty or bringing me papers
i think you've testified that uh you're
sure he said that that
it that night
um
you are sure he said that that night
yes now what was that in connection with
the affidavit i don't believe so
no
why would he have told you you could
always say that
i don't know
uh we're
at that point we've got a telephone
conversation in the morning with you and
the president and he has among other
things mentioned to you that
your
name is on the jones witness list
he has also mentioned to you that
perhaps you could file an affidavit to
avoid
possible testifying in that case
that's what is that right correct
and he's also
i think now at the point that we were in
our questioning
uh had referenced the
uh the cover story that
that you and he had had that perhaps you
could say that you were
coming to my office to deliver papers or
to see betty curry is that right
correct that it was from the entire
relationship that story now when he
alluded to that cover story
was that
instantly familiar to you yes you knew
what he was talking about yes
and why was this familiar to you
because it was part of the pattern of
the relationship
had you actually had to use
elements of this cover story in the past
i think so
yes okay
now let me go back again to the december
11th date uh
that's i'm sorry the 17th
this is a conversation in the morning uh
what else was there anything else you
talked about in terms of uh
other than your name being on the list
and uh
the affidavit and the cover story
yes
i had
i had had my own
thoughts
on
why and how he should settle the case
and i expressed those thoughts to him
and at some point he
mentioned that he still had this
christmas present for me and that maybe
he would ask miss curry to come in
that weekend and i
i said
not to because she was obviously going
to be in mourning because of her brother
what as i understand your testimony
too the the cover stories
were reiterated to you by the president
that night
on the telephone
correct
after
he told you you would be a witness or
your name was on the witness list i
should say correct
and did you understand that that since
your name was on the witness list that
there would be a possibility that you
could be subpoenaed to testify in the
paula jones case
i think i understood that i could be
subpoenaed and there was a possibility
of testifying i don't know if i
necessarily thought it was a subpoena to
testify
but
were you in fact subpoenaed to testify
yes
and that was what december 19th 1997.
now you have testified
in the in the grand jury
i think your closing comments was that
no one ever
asked you to lie
uh but yet in that very conversation
of december the 17th 1997 when the
president told you that you were on the
witness list he also suggested that you
could sign an affidavit
and use misleading cover stories isn't
that correct
um
well i guess in my mind i separate
necessarily signing affidavit and using
misleading cover stories so
um
well those two those three events
occurred but they don't they weren't
linked for me but they were in the same
conversation yes they were
did you understand in the context of the
conversation that you would deny
the relate the president your
relationship to the jones lawyers
do you mean from what was said to me or
in the context of that in the context of
that conversation december the 17th i i
don't i didn't
let me let me ask it did you understand
in the context of the telephone
conversation with the president that
early morning
of december the 17th did you understand
that you would deny
your relationship with the president to
the jones lawyers
through use of these cover stories
from what i learned in that conversation
through those cover stories i don't know
but from what i learned in that
conversation
i thought to myself i knew i would deny
the relationship
and you would deny the relationship to
the jones launcher yes correct good if
that's what it came to
and in fact you did deny the
relationship to the jones lawyers in the
affidavit that you signed
under penalty of perjury is that right i
denied a sexual relationship
the president did not in that
conversation on december the 17th
of 1997 or any other conversation for
that matter instruct you to tell the
truth is that correct
that's correct
and prior to being on the witness list
you you both i guess any any
conversation in relation to the paula
jones case i can't say that any
conversation from the
the entire relationship that he didn't
ever say
you know are you mad tell me the truth
so
and prior to being on the witness list
you both spoke about
denying this relationship if asked
yes that was discussed
he would say something to the effect
that uh
or you would say that you would you
would deny anything if it ever came up
and he would not or say that's good
something to that effect is that right
yes i believe i testified to that
in his uh
uh answer
uh to this uh proceeding in the senate
he has indicated that
he thought he had might have had a way
that he could have you
get you to finally basically a true
affidavit but yet still skirt these
issues enough
that you wouldn't be called as a witness
did he offer you any of these
suggestions at this time
he didn't discuss the content of my
affidavit with me at all
ever
now there's a lot there but that's the
testimony i'd like to go quickly through
some parts of it
first let's be very clear
as you saw ms lewinsky repeatedly told
mr manager bryant that she and the
president did not discuss the content of
the affidavit in that phone call
let's listen quickly again
are you
did he make it strike did he make any
representation to you about uh
what you could say in that affidavit or
no
what did you understand you would be
saying in that affidavit to avoid
testifying
uh i believe i've testified to this in
the grand jury uh in the best of my
recollection it was uh
to my mind it came was a range of things
i mean could either be
um
something innocuous or could go as far
as having to deny
the relationship
not being a lawyer nor having gone to
law school was
i thought it could be anything
did he uh at that point suggest one
version of the other version
no i didn't even mention that
so that there wasn't a further
discussion there was no discussion of
what would be
in an affidavit
in his
uh answer
uh to this uh proceeding in the senate
he has indicated that
he
thought he had might have had a way that
he could
have you
get you to follow basically a true
affidavit but yet still skirt these
issues enough
that you wouldn't be called as a witness
did he
offer you any of these suggestions at
this time
he didn't discuss the content of my
affidavit with me at all
ever
now ladies and gentlemen the managers
skipped these excerpts
they hid from you this key fact about
the call
to borrow a phrase they want to win too
badly
in that excerpt ms lewinsky also made
clear that the president only suggested
she might be able to file an affidavit
that might enable her to avoid
testifying let's listen
did he say anything about an affidavit
yes
what what did he say
he said that
that i could possibly file an affidavit
if i if i were subpoenaed that i could
possibly file an affidavit maybe to
avoid being deposed
how did he tell you you would avoid
being deposed
by filing an affidavit
i don't think he did
you just accepted that statement
yes yes sorry
and in that same telephone conversation
he encouraged you to file an affidavit
in the jones case he suggested i could
file an affidavit
she also made clear that the president
was not certain she even would be
subpoenaed and have to confront the
issue
what other discussion did you have uh
regard to
the fact that name was on the list
you were scared he was disappointed or
it broke his heart what other other
discussion did you have
uh i believe he said that
um
and these are not necessarily direct
quotes but to the best of my memory that
he said something about that
just because my name was on the list
didn't necessarily mean i'd be
subpoenaed
and at some point i asked him
you know what i should do if i
received a subpoena
he said i should
i should let ms curry know
um
[Music]
how would uh there was any discussion on
how you would accomplish uh
preparing or filing an affidavit at that
point
no
now where does this leave us
ms lewinsky described a brief
conversation in which the president
mentioned the possibility that an
affidavit might enable her to avoid
testifying if the need for it arose and
they left the subject
no discussion of content
no discussion of logistics no discussion
of timing virtually no discussion at all
and that very brief exchange is the
heart of the case
now the managers contend that because ms
lewinsky also recalls a reference to
cover stories in that call it is clear
beyond doubt that the president
instructed her to file a false affidavit
but for at least two reasons this claim
fails also
first ms lewinsky repeatedly told mr
manager bryant that the mention of cover
stories in that call was not connected
to the mention of a possible affidavit a
position i must note that she had taken
with the independent counsel for a very
long time
and second ms lewinsky has insisted for
more than a year that the cover stories
were not in any event false
a position she reasserted this week in
explaining why an affidavit didn't
necessarily have to be false let's look
quickly at ms lewinsky's testimony first
with respect to the alleged connection
between cover stories and the affidavit
well
based on prior
uh
relations with the president the
concocted stories and those things like
that did this come to mind
was there some discussion about that or
did it come to your mind about
not in connection with not not in
connection with the affidavit
did you discuss
anything else that night
in terms of
i would draw your attention to the cover
stories i've alluded to that earlier but
did you did you talk about cover story
that night yes sir
and what was said
um
i believe that um
the president said something
you can always say you were coming to
see betty or bringing me papers
i think you've testified that you're
sure he said that that
that night
uh
you are sure he said that
yes now
was that in connection with the
affidavit i don't believe so
no
now you have testified uh
in the in the grand jury
uh i think your closing comments was
that no one ever
ask you to lie
but yet in that very conversation
of december the 17th 1997 when the
president told you that you were on the
witness list he also suggested that you
could sign an affidavit
and use misleading cover stories isn't
that correct
um
but i i guess in my mind i separate
necessarily signing affidavit and using
misleading cover stories so
well those two those three events
occurred but they don't they weren't
linked for me
again the managers did not play these
excerpts for you either
they don't want you to know
ms lewinsky's recollection which is that
the cover stories and the affidavit were
not connected in that telephone call
and that's the call that's at the heart
of that first obstruction charge
the managers have suggested to you that
ms lewinsky for the first time this week
offered responses responses concerning
literal truth for example of the cover
stories designed to help the president
that was a suggestion a few days ago
concerned that her testimony might now
undermine their case they suddenly did
an about face
and attacked her on thursday
through this proceeding the managers
have consistently told you how credible
a witness ms lewinsky is and they have
invoked her immunity agreement as the
reason that she must be honest
and today they again credit her
testimony but carefully only in snippets
only when it suits their purposes
the responses ms lewinsky provided about
the cover stories that were mentioned on
thursday by mr manager bryant are not
new
they are the same responses ms lewinsky
gave to the independent council for
example when asked about the so-called
cover stories ms lewinsky testified as
follows this week
would you agree that these
cover stories that you just testified
too
if they were told to the attorneys for
paul and jones that they would
would be misleading to them and not be
the whole story the whole truth
they would
yes i guess misleading i mean they were
literally true
but they would be misleading
so incomplete
now the manager suggests
that this testimony may be new
different
tinted and tainted i think they said on
thursday but they don't tell you that ms
lewinsky said the very same thing to the
independent council she did so
repeatedly and she did so and this is
key before the president testified she
didn't know what he would say
he didn't know what she had said
for example ms lewinsky referred to the
two cover stories in her february 1998
proffer more than a year ago
remember one such cover story concerned
the reasons for visiting the president
before she left the white house that was
to bring papers to him and the other
concerned her reasons for visiting the
president after she left the white house
and that was to visit betty curry
ms lewinsky was asked and said that
neither of these statements was untrue
and also that there was truth to both of
these statements
in her proffer a year ago
she repeated this testimony in july to
the independent council telling an fbi
agent that quote these statements were
not untrue but were misleading in that
some facts were omitted from this
statement
that's what she said this week the cover
story's testimony is consistent and it
is consistently exculpatory
now of course it was easy for mr manager
bryant
to stand before you on thursday
reminiscing about the open and
forthcoming ms lewinsky that he had met
during the informal interview
it was easy for mr manager bryant to
complain that the ms lewinsky of the
deposition was i believe he said not
open to discussion or fully responsive
to fair inquiry i will let the
questioning and the answers and let you
be the judge of that
it was easy for him to say that because
the house managers had refused senator
daschle's request that they'd be allowed
to make a transcript of the interview
that absence of a transcript
allowed them this unverifiable fallback
if their examination was disappointing
oh she changed on us
the truth is that she didn't tell the
story that the managers wanted to hear
to remember those stubborn
facts
so we know that the managers are
disappointed and want to blame their
disappointment on ms lewinsky but when
you get to the substance today's
presentation by the house managers shows
that they have not in fact identified
any significant area where ms lewinsky's
testimony on monday differs from her
earlier testimony in the grand jury her
view of the cover stories has been
consistent from day one
now mr manager mccollum has also
insisted that in the december 17 call it
was clear both to the president and ms
lewinsky that the affidavit had to be
false as he put it and i quote can there
be any doubt that the president was
suggesting that she file an affidavit
that contains lies and falsehoods that
might keep her from ever having to
testify in the jones case and give the
president the kind of protection he
needed when he testified
yes there surely is doubt
ms lewinsky herself explained this week
that she did not discuss the content of
the affidavit with the president we've
played those portions already and i will
not again
but also that in her mind an affidavit
presented a whole range of possibilities
that were not necessarily false
the night of the phone call he suggested
you could file an affidavit
did you
appreciate the implications of filing a
false affidavit with the with the court
i don't think i necessarily thought at
that point it would have to be false
so
no probably not i don't i don't remember
having any thoughts like that so
i
imagine i would remember something like
that and i don't but
thus as we have seen and heard ms
lewinsky testified that there was no
discussion of what would be in an
affidavit and also that to her thinking
the affidavit would not necessarily have
been false
now that the december 17 call has fallen
short
the managers have tried to transform the
articles as drafted by asserting that
the alleged obstruction occurred also on
another date january 5 in a call that
took place then even though the articles
pinned everything on december 17.
with respect to a january 5 call mr
manager hutchinson made the following
claim to you
he asserted and i quote
well the record demonstrates that monica
lewinsky's testimony is that she had a
conversation with the president on the
telephone in which she asked questions
about the affidavit
she was concerned about signing that
affidavit and and this is still a quote
according to ms lewinsky the president
said well you could always say the
people in legislative affairs got it for
you or helped you get it
and this is still in the quote and that
is in reference to a paragraph in the
particular affidavit
those were mr manager hutchinson's words
but the record unequivocally
demonstrates that ms lewinsky and the
president did not ever discuss the
content of that affidavit in this
january 5 call or otherwise
and i challenge you to find any
paragraph in ms lewinsky's affidavit
either her draft or the final reflecting
this conversation there isn't one the
call wasn't about the affidavit he
didn't tell her what to say in the
affidavit it's just not there
in fact mr manager hutchinson repeatedly
represented to you that ms lewinsky
reviewed the content of her affidavit
with the president
he had to say that because he's asking
you to remove the president
from office for getting her to file a
false affidavit
that's a tough sell if they never talked
about the content of the affidavit
that's why he told you and i quote that
on
january six fifth or sixth she discussed
that with the president signing that
affidavit and the content of the
affidavit
that's why mr manager hutchinson also
told you and i quote again she went over
the contents of that even though she
might not have had it in hand with the
president
that's just not true
it's not true
to borrow a phrase again it's wanting to
win too much
what is clear from ms lewinsky's
testimony is that she never went over
the contents of the affidavit with the
president on january 5 or at any other
time
let's watch a brief excerpt about this
matter
did the subject of of the affidavit come
up for the president
yes towards the end of the conversation
and how to tell us how that occurred
i believe i asked him if he wanted to
see a copy of it and he said no
well i mean how did you introduce that
into the subject
into the conversation
i don't really remember
did he ask you well how's the affidavit
coming or no i don't think so
you told him that you had one being
prepared or something
i think i said i think i said you know
i'm gonna sign an affidavit or something
like that
did he ask you what are you gonna say no
and this is the time when he said
something about
15 half a day other affidavits correct
and tell us as best as you can call
how that how that part of the
conversation went
i think that was sort of the other half
of his sentence of no you know i don't
want to see it i don't need to or i've
seen 15 others
it was a little flippant his uh
answer
uh to this uh proceeding in the senate
he has indicated that
he
thought he had might have had a way that
he could
have you
get you to finally basically a true
affidavit but yet still skirt these
issues enough
that you wouldn't be called as a witness
did he
offer you any of these suggestions at
this time
he didn't discuss the content of my
affidavit with me at all
ever
in fact ms lewinsky made clear that she
did not have any indication whatsoever
that the president learned of the
content of the affidavit from mr jordan
either
the fact that
you assume that mr jordan was in contact
with the president
and and i
believe the evidence
would support that
through his own testimony that he had
talked to the president about
the signed affidavit and
that he had kept the president updated
on the subpoena issue in the job search
sir i'm not sure that i knew he was
having contact with the president about
this i
i think what i said was that i felt that
it was getting his approval it didn't
necessarily mean that i felt he was
going to get a direct approval from the
president
uh did did you have any indication from
mr jordan that he
uh
when he discussed the after the signed
affidavit with the president they were
discussing some of the contents of the
affidavit
did you before i signed
and finally lacking direct evidence of
any kind that there was a discussion
about the content of the affidavit the
managers have argued again and again
that the president must have told ms
lewinsky to file a false affidavit
because it was in his interest
not hers to avoid her testifying in the
jones case
mr manager bryant argued to you at the
start of these proceedings and i quote
when everything is said and done ms
lewinsky had no motivation no reason
whatsoever to want to commit a crime by
willfully submitting a false affidavit
with a court of law she really did not
need to do this at that point in her
life
mr manager brian also argued that only
the president would benefit from a false
affidavit so he must have instructed her
to do it as he put it
ms lewinsky files a false affidavit in
the jones case what is the result of
filing that false affidavit and who
benefited from that
but he was wrong he was wrong as ms
lewinsky made very clear when mr manager
brian asked her about this very subject
this week let's listen to what she said
but you didn't file the affidavit for
your best interest did you
um
actually i did
to avoid testifying yes
why why didn't you want to testify
why would not you why would you wanted
to avoid testifying
first of all i thought it was nobody's
business
second of all i didn't want to have
anything to do
with paula jones or her case
i guess those two reasons
in short ms lewinsky concedes that she
had a reason to act on her own
now we've been discussing subpart one of
article two the affidavit allegation
but this testimony also undermines
subpart 2 of article 2 which alleges
that the president obstructed justice in
that very same phone call by encouraging
miss lewinsky to lie in any testimony
that she might give
ms lewinsky previously denied that she
and the president ever discussed the
content of any deposition testimony in
that conversation that happened before
this week indeed she had told the fbi
that she and the president never
discussed what to say about her visits
to the white house in the context of the
paula jones case
and the managers themselves said in a
press release on january 19 of this year
that the president and ms lewinsky quote
did not discuss the deposition that
evening because monica had not yet been
subpoenaed
so it's not entirely surprising that the
managers did not ask ms lewinsky to
confirm that she and the president
talked about the testimony in this call
even though that's where the obstruction
allegedly occurred
they didn't ask her about that this week
because they knew the answer they knew
the answer was no
they knew there was no discussion about
the content of her testimony during that
call
and the testimony you have seen today
confirms that answer resoundingly there
is no evidence to support the charge in
subpart two either the managers did not
even try to elicit it
the president did not obstruct justice
ms lewinsky's testimony explodes these
two claims arising out of the december
17 telephone call
now let's turn to the allegation in
article 2 concerning gifts
subpart 3 charges that honor about
december 28 1997 the president corruptly
engaged in encouraged or supported a
scheme to conceal evidence that had been
subpoenaed in a federal civil rights
action brought against him
now the managers have indicated to you
that ms lewinsky provided testimony
useful to their case with respect to the
president's involvement in the transfer
of gifts to ms curry
we must have attended a different
deposition
in fact ms lewinsky's testimony provides
powerful support for the position that
ms lewinsky decided on her own to keep
from the jones lawyers the gifts she had
received from the president it provides
powerful support for the position that
she had her own reasons and concerns for
keeping the gifts from them and it
provides powerful support for the
position that she never discussed either
the topic of gifts or her own reasons
for concern with the president before
making her own independent decision on
how to handle the gifts
perhaps most notably her testimony also
provides corroboration for the
president's testimony that he told her
she had to turn over to the jones
lawyers what gifts she had
that's new evidence but it undermines
the manager's case it doesn't help it
in one of the most extraordinary points
in the deposition and we'll get to this
in a moment
we learned that the
office of independent council
failed to disclose to the house to the
senate to the president ms lewinsky's
exculpatory statement on this point
since the oic evidently had chosen not
to share the information with us
with the house or with this body we owe
the managers a small debt of gratitude
for allowing us to learn of it here
now let's look at the record with
respect to the phone calls giving rise
to the gift pickup
the managers repeatedly asserted at the
outset that they could prove miss curry
called ms lewinsky and not the other way
around
they claimed they had found a cell phone
record documenting that initial call to
arrange to pick up the gifts
as mr manager hutchinson
excuse me hutchinson said tantalizingly
at the start of these proceedings and i
quote well it was not known at the time
of the questioning of monica lewinsky
but since then the cell phone record was
retrieved
and you don't have it in front of you
but it will be available
the cell phone record was retrieved that
showed on betty curry's cell phone calls
that a call was made at 3 32 pm from
betty curry to monica lewinsky
and this is still under quotes and this
confirms
the testimony of monica lewinsky that
the follow-up to get the gifts came from
betty curry
that's what mr manager hutchinson
promised the record would show
but that's not in the end what the
record now shows
there's no evidence that the cell phone
call initiated the process as the
managers claimed and since there's no
evidence
that that call from miss curry was the
call initiating the process there's no
documentary evidence that ms curry
initiated the process
it's that simple the proof has failed
what the record does show
is that there was a cell phone call that
day
a proposition that no one has ever
disputed
ms lewinsky testified to the managers
that she recalls a cell phone call that
day
let's look at the testimony this past
passage that you will about to see
addresses the calls between ms lewinsky
and ms curry on december 28th
ms lewinsky has just described miss
curry's call to her about picking
something
straining for something beyond this
absolutely unresolvable conflict the
managers promised evidence to tip the
balance and they produced none
the much touted cell phone call utterly
fails to establish who initiated the
gift pickup by ms curry
it's therefore clear that the deposition
testimony does not advance the manager's
case with respect to the gifts
but it sure advances the defense case
remember ms lewinsky received a subpoena
on december 19 requesting gifts she had
received from the president
she met with her lawyer frank carter on
december 22
and she did not speak to the president
in the interim
in her deposition this week ms lewinsky
testified at some length about how she
decided what to bring her attorney frank
carter in response to that request for
gifts
as we will see she decided on her own
that she would bring only innocuous
things to produce things that any intern
might have in his or her possession
again this was on december 22
well before the december 28 meeting with
the president at which the managers and
the articles say the plan to hide the
gifts was hatched
ms lewinsky explained to the managers
what she did and why she did it let's
listen
did uh
did you bring with you to to the meeting
with mr jordan
for the purpose of carrying it i guess
to mr carter
uh items
that uh in response to this request for
production yes
did you discuss those items with mr
jordan i think i showed them to him but
i'm not a 100 percent sure
if i've testified that i did then i'd
stand by that
how did you select those items
uh
actually kind of in an obnoxious way i
guess i
um
they
i felt that it was important to
take the stand with mr carter
and then
i guess to the jones people that this
was ridiculous that they were
they were looking at the wrong person to
be involved in this and in fact that was
true i know and knew nothing of sexual
harassment
so
um i think i brought the uh
the christmas cards that i'm sure
everyone in this room has probably
gotten from the president and first lady
and considered that correspondence
and some innocuous pictures and they
were innocuous
were they the kind of items that
typically an intern would would receive
or said any one of us might receive
something i think so
in other words
it wouldn't give away any kind of
special relationship exactly
was that your intent
yes
did you discuss how you selected those
items with anybody
i don't believe so
did mr jordan make jordan make any
comment about those items
no
uh were any of these
items eventually turned over
to mr carter yes
as an aside contrary to the assertion of
mr manager rogan it is also clear from
that excerpt that ms lewinsky knew
nothing of sexual harassment that was
what she said
so it's clear from this tape that well
before december 28 ms lewinsky had made
her own decision for her own reasons not
to produce the gifts
she remained firm in this decision for
her own reasons on december 28 when the
president gave her more gifts
let's watch again
did uh
he gave you some gifts that day and my
question to you is
what went through your mind when he did
that uh when you knew all along you had
just received a subpoena to produce
gifts
did that not concern you
no
that didn't
i was happy to get them
i wanted it beyond your happiness and
receiving them wanted the subpoena
aspect of it not not concerned
i think
at that moment i mean you asked me when
he gave me those gifts so at that moment
when i was there i was happy to be with
him i was happy to get these christmas
presents so
i was nervous about the case
but i had made a decision that i wasn't
gonna
get into it too much
discussion
have you um
in regards to that
you've testified in the past that from
everything that the president had told
you about things like this there was
never any question
that you were going to keep everything
quiet
and turning over all the gifts would
prompt the jones attorneys to question
you so you had no doubt in your mind did
you not that you weren't going to turn
these gifts over
think the latter half of your statement
is correct i don't know if you're
reading from my direct testimony but
because you said your first statement
was from everything the president had
told you so i don't know if that was if
those were my words or not but um
i no i was i if
i was concerned about the gifts i was
worried someone might break into my
house or concerned that they actually
existed but i wasn't concerned about
turning them over because i knew i
wasn't going to for the reason that you
stated
[Applause]
now when ms lewinsky raised the issue of
gifts with the president on december 28
she cannot say he even answered
her recollection of whether he said
anything has been murky as we've heard
discussed here and in her recent
deposition she declined to resolve the
inconsistencies in favor of the version
the managers have advanced
and then what happened after she left on
december 28th as ms lewinsky recounted
the subsequent events miss curry later
called and arranged to pick up something
but what
according to ms lewinsky ms curry never
said gifts when she called ms lewinsky
assumed that's what she was calling
about that's her testimony
no doubt because they had been on her
mind for the reasons we have just heard
explained
now the manager's attempt to respond to
all this by saying over and over
yes but the president never told ms
lewinsky she had to produce the gifts he
had given her
they attempt to convert his silence into
a failure to perform a legal duty and
then to convert that failure to perform
a legal duty
into a high crime
but are we really sure that he didn't
tell her to produce the gifts
remember the president volunteered on
his own in the grand jury
that ms lewinsky had raised the subject
of gifts with him
that was long before he knew she had
said it
and remember he said what his response
was
quote you have to give them whatever you
have close quote
now the managers would have you believe
ms lewinsky rejected that recollection
wholesale that she said he never said
any such thing they need that to be the
case
but it's not so we now learn no thanks
to mr starr's agents
let's watch
now
were you
ever under the impression from anything
that the president said that you should
turn over all the gifts to the jones
lawyers
no but
where this is a little tricky and i
think i might have even mentioned this
last weekend was
that i had an occasion in an interview
with one of the
with the oic where i was asked a series
of statements if the president had made
those and and there was one statement
that agent fallon said to me
there was other people and they said
they asked me these statements this was
after the president testified they asked
me some statements did he say this did
he say this i said no no no and agent
fallon said something and i think it was
we have to turn over whatever you have
and i said to him you know that sounds a
little bit familiar to me
so i
that that's what i can tell you on there
that's in the 302 exam i don't know if
it's in the 302 or not but that's what
happened
this is extraordinary testimony
why
because ms lewinsky apparently
corroborated the president
she recognized those words when she
heard them
she didn't refute the president
and the oic never told us that that's
what she'd said never told the house
never told this body
we had no idea about ms lewinsky's
recollection
until we heard her testimony
we can only wonder
in troubled disbelief
how much more
we still don't know
the president did not obstruct justice
ms lewinsky's testimony seriously
undermines the gift claim that is before
you
we've reviewed the first three subparts
of article two
now looks let's look quickly at the
fourth
ms lewinsky's testimony also confirms
what has been clear throughout these
proceedings that her new york job search
efforts began in october 1997 well
before ms lewinsky was ever named a
potential witness in the jones case and
that mr jordan first became involved in
the job search effort in november early
november also before she became a
witness that ms lewinsky had received a
job offer in new york from the united
nations in november also
and also well before there was any
indication she would be a witness
and that mr jordan and ms lewinsky had
several contacts related to her job
search in november despite the fact that
both of them were traveling extensively
including out of the country in that
period
in fact ms lewinsky makes it clear in
this testimony that she and mr jordan
began arranging the meeting that took
place on december 11 before thanksgiving
before anyone knew ms lewinsky's name
would be on a witness list
all of this of course before anyone knew
ms lewinsky's name would be on a witness
list if the fact that the assistance to
ms lewinsky preceded her appearance on
the witness list needed confirmation
it's been confirmed again
but there's more
what has also been confirmed is ms
lewinsky's grand jury testimony that no
one ever asked me to lie and i was never
promised a job for my silence
we have repeatedly reminded this body of
these plain and simple words with their
plain simple and exculpatory meaning
the house managers repeatedly have tried
to suggest
that these words must mean something
else
but at no time in their hours of
questioning ms lewinsky did they
question her about this pivotal
assertion regarding the job search
allegation they did not ask her to
explain it to amend it to qualify it
they did not challenge it they did not
confront it
they
didn't
dare
they knew the answer
they knew there was no quid pro quo
and their failure to elicit a response
speaks volumes
the president did not obstruct justice
ms lewinsky's testimony undermines this
job search claim as well
plain and simple the evidence is to the
contrary
now mr manager bryant remarked on
thursday that after deposing ms lewinsky
he felt like the actor charles lawton in
the film witness for the prosecution
as counsel for the president i would
respectfully submit that another famous
role of charles lawton might be the more
fitting reference
it is that of the dogged
tireless
obsessed inspector javert
once played by mr lawton in the 1935
movie version of les miserables
the most recent testimony
of ms lewinsky has seriously damaged the
manager's case
and has confirmed
that it is time for this tireless
pursuit of the president
to come to an end
[Applause]
i turn now to my partner mr kendall who
will discuss mr jordan's recent
testimony
the chair recognized the majority leader
i think i see in the chief justice's
eyes the desire for uh 15
a 15-minute break let's let's return it
uh shortly after 3 30 as is possible
without objection it's so ordered
i am calling to say that i'm very much
for acquittal because
i think congress is violating
the senate will be in order the chair
recognizes the majority leader thank you
miss chief justice i believe the white
house counsel uh has a an additional a
presenter at this time
the chair recognizes mr white house
counsel kendall
mr chief justice
ladies and gentlemen of the senate
distinguished house managers
i'm going to deal with the vernon jordan
videotape deposition
now that deposition was taken on
february 2nd
this last tuesday
and it produced nothing at all which was
significantly new
time and again
mr manager hutchinson
cited mr jordan's previous grand jury
testimony
and time and again
mr jordan confirmed and recited his
previous grand jury testimony
the managers had a full and fair
opportunity to take mr jordan's
testimony and they indeed had time to
spare
they used just about three hours of
their allotted four hours time
and they discovered nothing that was not
contained in the previous 900 pages of
mr jordan's grand jury testimony uh
which had been taken in his march 3rd
march 5
may 5
may 28 and june 9 appearances before the
oic grand juries
assertion by council
is not the same thing as proof
and i think that's clear when you watch
the actual videos as we've done today of
the three witnesses whose testimony the
managers took earlier this week
for example with respect to mr jordan mr
manager hutchinson who did a first-rate
job of interrogation as you can see from
the video
i told you last thursday that he needed
to have in evidence the videotape and
you admitted it into evidence because
and i quote mr jordan's testimony goes
to the connection
the connection between the job search
the benefit provided to a witness and
the solicited false testimony from that
witness
mr manager hutchinson also asserted more
than once
last thursday that mr jordan's testimony
will prove that the president was
controlling the job search
there's only one problem with these
assertions when you actually look at the
videotape and listen to what mr jordan
testified to there's no support for
these propositions there's no direct
evidence and there's no circumstantial
evidence
it's plain that helping somebody find a
job
is an acceptable activity it's only when
this is tied as the second article of
impeachment alleges it's tied to some uh
obstruction in the paula jones case that
it becomes illegal and when fairly
considered mr jordan's testimony
provides no evidence whatsoever of that
now mr jordan was a long time and close
personal friend of the president
it's probably not bad for washington
standards
would you describe the nature of your
relationship with president clinton
uh president clinton has been a friend
of mine since
approximately
1973 when i came to your state arkansas
to make a speech as
president of the national urban league
about race and equal opportunity
in our nation
and we met then and there and
our friendship has grown and developed
and matured and
he is my friend
and will continue to be my friend
and just to further elaborate on that
friendship
it's my understanding that he
and his
the first lady has had christmas eve
dinner with you and your family for a
number of years every year
since his presidency
the jordan family has been privileged to
entertain the clinton family on
christmas eve
and uh has there been any exceptions in
recent years to that every year that he
has been president
he has had he and his family christmas
eve with my family
and uh have you vacationed together with
the clinton family
yes i think you've seen
reels of us playing golf and having fun
at martha's
vineyard and
so you vacation together you play golf
together
on a semi-regular basis whenever we can
we've done
it's been well known since the start of
this investigation
that mr jordan was active in helping ms
lewinsky secure employment in new york
and also that he construed this request
which came to him through betty curry as
having come from the president himself
uh in his may 28th deposit grand jury
testimony for example mr jordan
testified that betty curry was the
president's secretary she was the person
who called me at the behest of the
president i believe to ask me to look
into getting monica lewinsky a job and
again on june 9 mr jordan testified to
the grand jury that the president asked
me to help get monica lewinsky a job now
mr manager hutchinson played an excerpt
which i will not play again which once
more repeats that testimony
uh mr jordan however made clear
that while he recommended
ms lewinsky for a job at three new york
firms which he had some connection with
the decision to hire her was the
companies and he put no pressure of any
kind on these companies to hire ms
lewinsky indeed she received an offer at
one company revlon and failed to obtain
one from
american express or burst and marsteller
do you believe that you were acting the
company's interest or the president's
interest when you were trying to secure
a job for miss lewinsky well what i knew
was that the company would take care of
its own interests
this is not the first time that i
referred somebody and what i know is is
that if
a person being referred
does not meet the standards required for
that company i have no question but that
that person will not be hired and so the
referral
is
is an easy thing to do
the judgment about employment is not a
judgment as a person referring that i
make
but i do have confidence
in all of the companies on whose boards
that i said that regardless of my
reference
that as to their needs and as to their
expectations for their employees that
they will make the right decisions as
happened in the american express
situation american express called and
said we will not hire miss lewinsky i
did not question it i did not challenge
it because they understood their needs
and their needs in comparison to her
qualifications they made a judgment
revlon on the other hand made another
judgment
i am not the employer i am
the referrer and there is a major
difference
now going back to
what you knew
as far as information and what you
conveyed to
revlon
you indicated that
you did not tell mr halperin that
you were making this request or referral
at the request of president united
states yeah and i didn't see any need to
do that and then when you talk to me or
do i believe not saying that counselor
was a breach of some fiduciary
relationship
and when you had your conversation
uh with mr pearlman right at a later
time right uh
you do not remember whether you told him
you do not believe you told him you are
i believe that i did not president but
you
assumed that he knew no
uh
i did not make any assumptions let me
say i said ronald here is a young lady
who's been interviewed she thinks that
the interview has not gone well
see what you can do to make sure that
she is properly interviewed and
evaluated
in essence
and
did you reference her as a former white
house intern
uh probably i don't i i do not have a
recollection of whether i described her
as a white house intern whether i
described her as a person who worked for
the pentagon
uh i said this is a person that i have
referred
i think
ms hutchinson
that i have sufficient
influence shall we say sufficient
character shall we say that people have
been
throughout my career able to take my
word at face value
and so you didn't need to reference the
president uh the fact that you were
calling mr pearlman and asking for a
second interview for miss lewinsky that
that should be sufficient i thought it
was sufficient and obvious it was
department thought it was sufficient and
so there's no reason based on what you
told him for him to think that you were
calling at the request of the president
united states i think that's probably
right
and so
at least with the conversation with mr
halpern and mr uh
perlman
you did not reference that you were
acting at behalf of the
president united states and was there
anyone else that you talked to at
revlon in which they might have acquired
that information
the only person that i talked to in this
process as i explained to you was mr
halpern
and uh and mr pearlman
about this process and it was mr halpern
who put the
to who who got the process started
and so those are the only two you talked
about and you made no reference that
you're acting behalf of the president
right
now the second piece of information was
the fact that you knew and the president
knew that miss lewinsky was under
subpoena in the jones case
and that information was not provided to
either mr halperin or to mr pearl
is that correct that's correct
the most critical thing about this
deposition is it contained no evidence
of any kind which supports the central
allegation of article two the
obstruction of justice alec uh article
that mr jordan's job search assistance
was tied to ms lewinsky testifying in a
certain way
or that the president intended mr
jordan's assistance to
corruptly influence her testimony
mr jordan was unequivocal about the fact
that he had frequently helped other
people and that here there was no quid
pro quo no tie-in of any kind indeed he
provided direct evidence
of this fact
mr jordan you were asked questions about
job assistance
would you describe the job assistance
you have over your career given
to people who come to you requesting
help
finding a job or finding a plan
well
i've known about job assistance
and helped for a very long time
learned about it dramatically when i
finished howard university law school
1960
to return home to atlanta georgia
to look for work in the process of my
during my senior year it was very clear
to me
that no law firm in atlanta would hire
me
it was very clear to me that
i could not get a job as a black lawyer
in the city government
the county government
the state government
or the federal government
and thanks to my
high school band master
mr kenneth days
who called his fraternity brother
donald l hollowell a civil rights lawyer
and said that jordan boy is a fine boy
and you ought to consider him for a job
at your law firm
that's when i learned about job referral
and that
that job referral by kenneth day has now
gone to don hollowell
got me a job as a civil rights lawyer
working for don hollowell for 35 dollars
a week
i have never forgotten kenneth dayz's
generosity
and given the fact that all of the other
doors for employment as a black lawyer
graduating from howard university were
open to me that's always
that's always been
etched in my heart and my mind and as a
result
because i stand on mr daisy's shoulders
and
to the extent that i could be helpful
or got in a position to be helpful that
i would do that
and there is
i think ample evidence
both in the media and by individuals
across this country that at such times
that i have been presented with that
opportunity
that i have
taken advantage of the opportunity and i
think that i have been successful at it
was your assistance to ms lewinsky which
you've described
in any way dependent upon her doing
anything whatsoever in the paul jones
case
no
that's direct evidence that's not
circumstantial evidence that's unimpuned
direct evidence
uh mr manager hutchinson emphasized that
mr jordan now admits that he met with ms
lewinsky for breakfast
on december 31
but mr jordan also conceded in his
deposition that while he has no direct
recollection of it he also met with ms
lewinsky on november 5 a date well
before any of the many managerial
selected dates for the beginning of the
corrupt conspiracy here
now when was the first time that you
recall that you met with monica lewinsky
if you've read my grand jury testimony i
have and i'm sure that you have there is
testimony in the grand jury that uh she
came to see me on on about the 5th of
november i have no recollection of that
it was not in my calendar
and i just i just have no recollection
of her visit
there is a letter here that you have in
evidence and i have to assume that in
fact that happened
but as i said in my grand jury testimony
i'm not aware of it i don't remember it
but i do not deny that it happened
and
miss lewinsky has made reference to a
meeting that occurred in your office on
november 5
and that's the meeting that you have no
recollection that is correct that we
have we have no record of it in my
office
and i just have no recollection of it
and
in your first grand jury appearance
you were
firm shall i say that uh the first time
you met with miss lewinsky that it was
on uh december 11th yeah it was firm
based on what my calendar told me and
substitute
to that there's been a refreshing of my
recollection and i do not deny that it
happened by the same token i will tell
you as i said in my grand jury testimony
that i did not remember that i had met
with her
and
in fact today
the fact that you do not dispute that
that meeting occurred is not based upon
your recollection but it's simply based
upon you've seen the
records and it appears that meeting
occurred that is correct
uh the manager's theory is that it
wasn't the original job
assistance which constitutes obstruction
of justice it was rather the
intensification of it which
began at a certain point and that point
has varied uh when you boil it all down
when you look at mr uh
jordan's deposition or read his grand
jury testimony you see that he acted for
ms lewinsky on two different occasions
on december the 11th he made three phone
calls to her
for her to new york firms and then on
january the 8th when she thought an
interview had gone badly he made another
phone call this time to mr pearlman uh
that's all he did
now you also will recall i think that
the manager's original theory
was that what catalyzed this job search
intensification what really kick-started
it was the entry of an order in the
paula jones case by judge wright on
december the 11th
mr manager hutchinson told you on
january the 14th
that what triggered let's look at the
chain of events the judge the witness
list came in the judge's order came in
that triggered the president into action
and the president triggered vernon
jordan into action that chain reaction
here is what moved the job search along
remember what else happened on that day
december 11th again that was the same
day that judge wright ruled that the
questions about other relationships
could be asked by the jones attorneys
that was the theory then this is now
we demonstrated in our own presentation
of course that that order was entered
late in the day uh at a time when mr
jordan was high in the atlantic in an
airplane on his way to amsterdam and uh
mr hutchinson's manager hutchinson's
very able examination uh did not try to
resuscitate that theory uh he didn't
even make the attempt he didn't ask mr
jordan about the december 11th order
so today we have a different timeline
uh we have a new chart and a new
timeline let's let's look at this this
was mr manager hutchinson's chart this
morning what is critical here
well we learned today that it's the
december 5 date that is critical that's
when the witness list was faxed to the
president's council
and that's what triggers the succeeding
chain of events
uh
mr manager hutchinson remarked if i
heard him correctly that whenever you're
talking about obstruction of justice it
ties together it all fits together
well let's look at his chart you see
that
december 11th is on here but
judge wright's order has dropped off
entirely unless it's there where i don't
see it judge wright's order is now not
part of the chain of causation uh we
look at december 7th we ask ourselves
what happened then this is two days
after the witness list came in must have
been something nefarious because the
president and jordan meet but
mr manager hutchinson did not represent
to you that they even talked about the
jones litigation or ms lewinsky because
they didn't the managers told you that
in their trial brief and it's been mr
jordan's consistent uh testimony
now the uh
on december 11th mr jordan did have a
meeting with ms lewinsky that was
originally set up not on december 8th
you'll recall but back in november when
ms lewinsky had agreed to call
mr jordan when he re returned from his
travels so the chronology here produces
no even circumstantial evidence of some
linkage between the paula jones case and
mr jordan's job search uh it's also
significant i think that while the
witness list came in on december the 5th
the president met with his lawyers on
december the 6th
the president doesn't call ms lewinsky
until december the 17th and mr jordan
doesn't learn about the fact that ms
lewinsky is on the witness list until
december 19th there does not seem to be
a lot of urgency here
well let's review the nefarious
conspiracy that we've heard about today
to get ms lewinsky a job
we're told today that vernon jordan had
no corrupt intent
that miss lewinsky had no corrupt intent
and that revlon had no corrupt intent
rather it was the president who somehow
spun out this uh uh conspiracy but i ask
you where in all this voluminous record
is there any evidence either direct or
circumstantial that the president
somehow tied these things together
through mr jordan it's a shell game but
the game doesn't have any shell in it
and i think that this is the uh
loneliest conspiracy in human history if
it was a conspiracy but it wasn't
now
on the subject of quid pro quo
i want to play two excerpts and part of
these i ask your indulgence they were
played in part by mr manager hutchinson
but i think they deserve to be seen in
their full context in one of them you're
going to hear mr jordan say that he was
running the job search he was in control
of the job search well i think that's
true about the vernon jordan job search
ms lewinsky's job search had also been
proceeding with ambassador richardson mr
jordan wasn't involved in any way in
that and through one of her superiors at
the pentagon mr ken bacon but let's
listen to the full context and
listen for any evidence of a quid pro
quo
mr jordan
let me go back to that meeting on
december 11th i believe we were
discussing that uh
my question would be how did the meeting
on december 11 of 1997 with ms lewinsky
come about
mr winsky called my office and asked if
she could come to see me all right and
was that preceded by a call from betty
curry
at some point in time betty curry had
called me
and uh the miss lewinsky followed up on
that call
and she came to my office and we had a
visit miss lindsay called set up a
meeting
uh and at some point sent your resume i
believe uh i believe so and did you
receive that prior to the meeting on
december 11th
i i have to assume that i did but i i do
not know whether she brought it with her
or whether there was at some point that
she brought with her or sent to me
somehow it came into my possession a
list of various
companies in new york with which she
uh had which were her preferences by the
way
most of most of which i did not
did not know well enough to make any
calls for
all right and i want to come back to
that but
i believe would you dispute uh if the
record shows that you received the
resume for mr lewinsky on december 8th i
would not and
presumably the meeting on december 11th
was set up somewhere around december 8th
by the call from miss lewinsky
i
i would not dispute that sir all right
now you mentioned that she had sent you
a uh
i guess some people refer to it a wish
list or a list of jobs that she
got jobs companies companies that she
would be interested in seeking
employment with that's correct and you
looked at that and you
determined that you wanted to go with
your own list of
friends and
companies that you had better contacts
with uh
i'm sure congressman that you too have
been in this business and you do know
that you can only call people that you
know or feel comfortable in calling
absolutely no question about it and uh
let me just comment and ask your
response to this but uh many times uh i
will be listed as a reference and they
can take that to any company you might
be listed as a reference and the name
vernon jordan would be a good reference
anywhere would it not i would hope so
and uh and so even though it was a
company that you might not have the best
contact with
you know
you could have been helpful in that
regard well the fact is
i was running the job search not mr
lewinsky and therefore
the companies that she brought or listed
were not of interest to me i
knew where i would need to call
and that
is exactly
the point
that
you looked at getting miss lewinsky a
job as an assignment
rather than just something that you were
going to be a reference for
i don't know what i looked upon it is an
assignment uh
i
getting jobs for people is not unusual
for me so i don't view it as an
assignment
i just view it as something that is part
of what i do
you're acting on behalf of the president
when you're trying to get ms lewinsky a
job
and you were in control of the job
search
uh yes
now going back going to your meeting
that we're talking about on december
11th
prior to the meeting did you make any
calls to prospective employers on behalf
of ms lewinsky
i don't think so i think i think not i
think i wanted to see her before i made
any calls
and so
if they were not before uh after you met
with her you made some calls on december
11. i believe that's correct
and
uh you called mr richard halperin of
mcandrews and forbes that's right he
called mr
peter jojesco george jesco
and he is with what company he is
chairman and chief executive officer of
young and rubicam
and the leading advertising agency on
madison
and uh did you make one other call yes i
called ursi fairburne who
runs human resources at american express
at the american stress company where i
am the senior director
and what did you basically communicate
to each of these officials in in behalf
of ms lewinsky i essentially said that
you're going to hear from ms lewinsky
and i hope that you will afford her an
opportunity to come in and be
interviewed and look favorably upon her
if she meets your qualifications and
your needs for work okay
and at what level did you try to
communicate
this information about what do you mean
by what level uh
in the company that you were calling did
you call the chairman of human resources
did you call the ceo
uh who did you call or what level were
you seeking to talk to richard halpern
uh
is sort of uh the utility man he does
everything at
mcandrews and forbes he's very close to
the chairman he's very close to mr
gettys and so at mcandrews and forbes i
call him a and as i said to you and as
my granddaughter testimony shows
i called young and rubicam
peter giorgesco as its chairman and ceo
i have had a long-term relationship with
with young and rubicam going back to
three of its ceos the first being edward
nay
who was chairman of young and rubicam
when i was head of the united negro
college fund
and it was during that time that we
developed the great theme of mind is a
terrible thing to waste so i've had a
long-term relationship with young in
rubicam
and with peter georgesko and so i called
the chairman in that instance at
american express
i call miss ursey fairborne who is
as i said before in charge of human
resources
so that is the level in one instance the
chairman
in one instance uh a utilitarian person
and then another instance the head of
the human resources department and the
utilitarian uh connection mr richard
halperin
was
sort of an assistant to mr ron perlman
that's correct he's a lawyer
now
going to your meeting on december 11th
with ms lewinsky about how long of a
meeting was that i don't i don't
remember
you you have a record of
congressman
and
actually i i think you've testified it
was about 15 to 20 minutes but
don't hold me to that either
during the course of the meeting with ms
lewinsky what did you learn about her
enthusiastic
uh
quite taken with herself and her
experience
um
bubbly effervescent uh bouncy
um
confident
uh
actually i sort of had the same
impression that your house managers had
of her when you met with you came out
and said she was impressive and we said
we come out about the same place
and did she relate to you the fact that
uh she liked being an intern because it
put her close to the president
uh i have never seen a white house
intern who did not like being a white
house intern
and so her enthusiasm for being a white
house intern was about like the
enthusiasm of white house interns they
liked it
she was not happy
about not being there anymore she did
not like being at the defense department
and i think she actually had some
some desire to go back
but when she actually talked to me she
wanted to go
to new york
for a job in the private sector
and she thought that i could be helpful
in that process did she make reference
to someone in the white house being
uncomfortable
when she was an intern
and she thought the people did not want
her there she felt unwanted there's no
question about that as to who did not
want her there and why they did not want
her there that was not my business and
she related that
she talked experience or feeling to you
yes
now
your meeting with miss lewinsky was on
december 11th
and i believe that miss lewinsky has
testified that she met with the
president on december 5
excuse me on december 6 at the white
house
and complained that her job search was
not going anywhere
and the president then talked to mr
jordan
do you recall
the president talking to you about
that after not having a specific
recollection of of the president saying
to me
anything about having met
uh with miss lewinsky
the president has never told me that he
met with miss lewinsky as a as best as i
can recollect
i i am aware that she was
in a state of anxiety about going to
work
she was in a state of anxiety
in addition because her lease at
watergate at the watergate uh was to
expire december 31st
and
there was a part of mr winsky i think
that thought that because
she was coming to me
she could come today and that she would
have a job tomorrow
that is not an unusual
misapprehension
and it's not limited to white house
intern
i mentioned her meeting with the
president
on the same day december 6th i believe
the record shows the president met with
his lawyers and learned that miss
lewinsky was on the jones witness list
now did you subsequently meet with the
president on the next day december
i may have met with the president i'd
have to i mean i'd have to look
did
i i'd have to look i don't know whether
it did not if you would like to confer i
believe the record shows that but i'd
like to establish that for your
testimony
yeah all right so you met with the
president on december 7th
uh and was it the next day after that
december 8th ms lewinsky called to set
up the job meeting with you on december
11. i believe that is correct
and sometime after your meeting on
december 11th with ms lewinsky did you
have another conversation with the
president
uh
you do understand that
conversations
between me and the president
was not an unusual circumstance
and i understand that and so let me
be more specific i believe your previous
testimony has been that uh sometime
after the 11th you spoke with the
president about miss lewinsky i stand on
that testimony
and so uh there's two conversations
after the witness list came out one that
you had with the president of december
7th and then a subsequent
conversation with him after you met with
mr lewinsky on the 11th
now
in your subsequent conversation after
the 11th did you discuss with the
president united states monica lewinsky
and if so can you tell us what that
discussion was if there was a discussion
subsequent to monica lewinsky's visit to
me on december the 11th with the
president of the united states it was
about the job
search
and
during that uh did he indicate that he
knew about the fact that she had
lost her job in the white house and she
wanted to get a job in new york she was
aware that he was obviously aware that
she had lost a job in the white house
because she was working at the pentagon
he was also aware that she wanted to
work in new york in the private sector
and understood that that is why she was
having conversations with me there's no
doubt about that
and he thanked you for helping her
there's no question about that either
and on either of these conversations
that i've referenced that you had with
the president after the witness list
came out your conversation on december
7th and your conversation sometime after
the 11th
did the president tell you that miss
velanika lewinsky was on the witness
list in the jones case he did not
and did you consider this information to
be important in your efforts to be
helpful to ms lewinsky i never thought
about it
mr jordan found out about ms lewinsky's
subpoena on december the 19th when a
weeping miss lewinsky telephoned him and
came to his office mr manager hutchinson
played that excerpt from the testimony
this morning i won't replay it
mr jordan then did what i think is best
called due diligence he talked to miss
lewinsky got her a lawyer asked her
whether there was any sexual
relationship with the president and was
assured that there was none
that same evening
he went to the white house and made a
similar inquiry of the president and
received a similar response
and
still on december 19th after
you're meeting with miss lewinsky
did you subsequently see the president
of the united states later that evening
i did
and
is this when you went to the white house
and saw the president yes
now at the time that miss lewinsky came
to see you on december 19th
did you have any plans to attend any
social function at the white house that
evening i did not
and in fact there was a social
invitation that you had at the white
house i had i had declined it that's
correct
and subsequent to mrs lewinsky visiting
you did you change your mind and go see
the president that evening
after the
a social engagement that mrs jordan and
i had
we went to the white house for two
reasons
we went through our house to see some
friends who were there two of whom were
staying
in the in the white house
and secondly i wanted to have a
conversation with the president
and
this conversation that you wanted to
have with the president was one that you
wanted to have with him alone i describe
it and did you let him know in advance
that you were coming and wanted to talk
to him i told him i would see him
sometimes that night after dinner
did you tell him why you want to see him
no
now was this
what you told him that you wanted to see
him
did it occur the same time that you
talked to him while miss lewinsky was
waiting outside
it could be
i made it clear that i would come by
after dinner and he said fine
now
let me backtrack for just a moment
because whenever you talk to the
president mr lewinsky was not inside the
room that's correct and therefore you
did not know
the details about her questions on the
president might leave the first lady and
those questions that set off all these
alarm bells
uh and so you're having is that the
answer yes that's correct
and and so you're having this discussion
with the president
not knowing the extent of miss
lewinsky's
fixation
um is that correct right
and
regardless uh you wanted to see the
president that night and so you went to
see him and was he expecting you
i believe he was and did you
have a conversation with him alone i did
no one else around no one else around
and i know that's a redundant question
it's okay
now would you describe your conversation
with the president
uh we were upstairs uh in the white
house mrs jordan we came in by way of
the southwest gate into the diplomatic
entrance we left the car there
i took the elevator up and missed to the
residents and mrs jordan went and
visited at the at the party and
the president was already upstairs i had
ascertained that from the usher
and i went up and i raised with him the
whole question of monica lewinsky and
asked him directly
if he had had sexual relations with
monica lewinsky and the president said
no never all right
now during that conversation did you
tell the president
again that monica lewinsky had been
subpoenaed
well we'd established that all right and
did you tell him that you were concerned
about her fascination i did
and did you describe her as being
emotional in your meeting that day i did
and did you relate to the president
that miss lewinsky asked about whether
he was going to leave the first lady at
the end of the term i did
and as
and then you concluded that
uh with the question as to whether he
had had sexual relations with ms leski
and he said he had not and i was
satisfied in the conversation all right
now once again just as i asked the
question in reference to ms lewinsky it
appears to me that this is an
extraordinary question to ask the
president of the united states
what led you to ask this question to the
president well first of all i'm asking a
question of my friend
who happens to be the president of the
united states
and did you expect your friend the
president united states to give you a
truthful answer i did
did you rely upon the president's answer
in your decision to continue your
efforts to seek miss lewinsky a job i
believed him and i continued to do what
i've been asked to do
this morning a very short portion of the
president's grand jury testimony was
played the sound was not very good it
was a very short snippet
but it relates to what happened between
mr jordan and
the president in that december 19th late
night meeting at the at the white house
the snippet that was played for you was
question
and mr jordan informed you of that is
that right that being the subpoena
answer no sir
and that leaves the misleading
impression that in his grand jury
testimony the president did not
acknowledge this visit with mr jordan
the question right above the one that
was quoted however was the following you
were familiar weren't you mr president
that she had received a subpoena you've
already acknowledged that the answer was
yes sir i was and then two pages later
the president was asked by the oic
did you in fact have a conversation with
mr jordan on the evening of december 19
1997 in which he talked to you about
monica being in mr jordan's office
having a copy of the subpoena and being
upset about being subpoenaed and the
president's answer was
i remembered that mr jordan was in the
white house on december 19th and for an
event of some kind that he came up to
the residence floor and told me that he
had that monica had gotten a subpoena or
that monaco is going to have to testify
and i think he told me he recommended a
lawyer for her i believe that's what
happened but it was a very brief
conversation so i think it's absolutely
clear that there's no conflict between
the president's testimony and mr
jordan's testimony about this
uh mr jordan had recommended miss
lewinsky and he took her to the lawyer's
office to a lawyer mr frank carter
a respected washington d.c lawyer to
whom mr jordan had recommended other
clients
now you have referred other clients to
mr carter during your course of practice
here in washington d.c yes i have uh
about how many of you referred to him oh
i don't know maggie williams one is one
client that i remember
uh very definitely
i like frank hart a lot he's a very able
uh
young lawyer he's a first-class person a
first-class lawyer
and
he's one of my new acquaintances
amongst lawyers in town
and i like being around him we have
lunch and he's a friend and is it true
though
that when you've referred other clients
to mr carter
that you never personally delivered and
presented that client to him in his
office but i delivered mega williams to
him in my office i had megan williams to
come to my office
and it was in my office that i
introduced
mega williams to mr carter and she chose
other council i would have happily taken
mega williams to his office
gary i'm going to skip the next two
video tapes 21 and 22.
i hear a sigh of relief
i want to use the next videotape
and i'm almost through
to correct a record
as to one point that was made by the
managers on thursday and again this
representation was important because it
asserted an interconnection
between the job
search assistance and testimony in the
jones case
you were shown a chart
on
thursday
and it was a chart which was entitled
interconnection between job help and
testimony
manager's version
question
so you talk to her both about the job
and her concern about parts of the
affidavit answer according to manager's
version that is correct
now when we actually look at the
testimony which we're going to see in
just a second
the uh
the question
is did you in fact talk to her about the
job and her concerns about parts of the
affidavit
answer i have never in any conversation
with miss lewinsky talk to her about the
job on the one hand or job being
interrelated with the conversation about
the affidavit the affidavit was over
here the job was over
was over here
i don't suggest any intentional
misrepresentation but i think the record
deserves to be corrected
do you know why you would have been
calling mr carter
on three occasions the day before the
affidavit was signed yeah
my recollection is is that
uh
i was exchanging or sharing mr carter
what had gone on what did she had asked
me to do what i refused to do
uh
reaffirming to him that he was a lawyer
i was not the lawyer
i mean it would be so
presumptuous of me to try to advise
frank carter as to how to practice law
would you have been relating to mr
carter your conversation with ms
lewinsky
i may have
and if ms lewinsky expressed to you any
concerns about the affidavit would you
have relayed those to mr carter yes
and
uh if mr carter was a good attorney that
was concerned about the economics of law
practice he would have likely billed ms
lewinsky for some of those telephone
calls you have to talk to mr carter
about his ability
it wouldn't surprise you if his billing
did reflect a a
charge for a telephone conversation mr
jordan
keep in mind that mr carter spent most
of his time in
being a legal services lawyer i think
his concentration is primarily on
service rather than billy
but again
based upon the conversations you had
with them which sounds like
conversations of substance reference the
affidavit that it would be consistent
with the practice law if he charged for
those conversations
uh
that's a question you'd have to ask mr
carr
they were conversations of substance
with mr carter concerning the affidavit
and there were likely conversations
about more than ms lewinsky
but the answer was yes that there were
conversations of substance and reference
to the affidavit or at least a portion
of it
in other words other things might have
been discussed yes
in your conversation with ms lewinsky
david being signed did you in fact talk
to her about both the job and her
concerns about parts of the affidavit i
have never in any conversation with miss
lewinsky
talk to her about the job on one hand
or job being interrelated with the
conversation about the affidavit the
affidavit was over here the job was over
here but the
in the same conversations both
her interest in a job and her
discussions about the affidavit
contained the same thing i said to you
before council she was always interested
in the job
and she was always interested in the job
and so if she brought up the affidavit
very likely it was in the same
conversation
no doubt
and that would be consistent with your
previous grand jury testimony when you
expressed that you talked to her both
about the job and her concerns about
parts of the affidavit that's correct
now on january 7th the affidavit was
signed
subsequent to this did you notify anyone
in the white house that the affidavit in
the jones case had been signed with ms
lewinsky yeah i'm certain i told betty
curry and i'm fairly certain that i told
the president
and why did you tell betty curry i kept
him informed about everybody else that
was everything else there was no reason
not to tell him about that she had
signed the affidavit
and
why did you tell the president
the president was obviously interested
in
her job search we had talked about the
affidavit he knew that she had a lawyer
it was in the due course of conversation
mr president she signed after david she
signed the affidavit
and what was his response when you
informed him that she had signed the
affidavit thank you very much
and uh
would you also have been giving him a
report on the status of the job search
at the same time
he may have asked about that and and and
part of her problem was that you know
she was
there was a great deal of anxiety about
the job she wanted the job she was
unemployed and she wanted to work
now
i think you indicated he was obviously
concerned about
was it a representation and the
affidavit i told him that i had found
counsel for her
and i told him
that she had signed the affidavit
you indicated he was
concerned obviously about something what
was he obviously concerned about in your
conversations with him
throughout he had been concerned about
her
getting employment in new york
period
and he was also concerned about the
affidavit
i don't know that that was concerned i
did tell him that the affidavit was
signed he knew that she had counsel
and he knew that i had arranged to
counsel
[Music]
in his presentation mr manager
hutchinson discussed the breakfast with
miss lewinsky which mr gern mr jordan
now concedes he had on december the 31st
he showed you the restaurant bill i'm
not going to dwell long on that because
it really is not relevant uh to article
two first of all it is nowhere alleged
as a ground of obstruction of justice mr
manager hutchinson referred to the seven
pillars of obstruction in article two
those are seven different factual
grounds this alleged destruction
is nowhere one of the grounds
there is plainly a conflict in the
testimony between
miss lewinsky and mr jordan although mr
jordan as you recall vehemently denies
ever giving that instruction saying in
the videotape that was played this
morning i'm a lawyer and i'm a loyal
friend but i'm not a fool
that's ridiculous i never did that
the second reason why i think this is
irrelevant is it was not presented as a
separate ground for impeachment by the
independent council uh it was identified
the the the fact of the conflict and
testimony was identified but uh it was
not urged as a separate ground despite
the very very energetic investigation of
mr starr
we've heard a lot in this case about
dogs that won't hunt
in my mind this is like the sherlock
holmes story about the dogs that didn't
bark if the independent council didn't
raise it that is significant and finally
it has nothing whatsoever to do with the
president by anybody's contention
mr chief justice i'd like to raise a
question now which arose
in the final stage of the vernon jordan
deposition
mr manager hutchinson had taken the
deposition i had asked a couple of
questions in response then after i had
concluded mr jordan made a statement
defending his own integrity to which mr
manager hutchinson objected
uh i would propose that since the issue
has arisen of his integrity since mr
jordan is an honorable man and a
distinguished has had a distinguished
career that i'd be allowed to play the
approximately two-minute segment of his
own statement about his integrity
uh do the managers object
mr chief justice my understanding is not
a part of the senate record
and therefore it would not be
appropriate to be played under the rules
of the senate
well but is it a part of his the
deposition of him that was taken
it is not a part of the deposition that
was entered into the senate record under
the senate rule
the the parliamentarian
advises me that division one of the
motion on thursday which was approved uh
would would prevent the playing of that
so the chair will or the chair will rule
that is not not acceptable thank you mr
chief justice mr chief justice um
i was one senator from vermont mr chief
justice i was one of the uh
senators at that deposition i think it
would be extremely
interesting to to hear it it was taken
at the deposition
i would ask unanimous consent that it'd
be allowed this this the senator from
vermont may appeal the decision of the
chair which is there to not be played i
i i'm not asking
consent for further i'm asking unanimous
consent
under the circumstances because it is
such a short one
that the
deposition
and it would clarify that the
part of the deposition that mr jordan
took and which has been videotaped
be allowed to be shown here
on the floor is there objection
there is objection is heard
council may proceed
i'd like to uh recognize my colleague
i think uh that concludes our
presentation we'll yield back the
remainder of our time mr chief
chancellor
very well how much
the managers have 31 minutes remaining
[Music]
the chair recognized mr manager bryant
the senate will be in order
the chair recognizes mr manager brian
thank you mr chief justice
we will conclude our roughly half hour
by
responding to
as many of the contentions and and
statements raised by
council for the white house as we can
and i first want to talk first i suppose
about this statement that we heard
uh back
a couple of weeks ago
and was repeated today by one of white
house counsels that the managers
want to win too much
this is not a game
this is not a game to anyone here
there are extra or extraordinary
consequences
consequences to what we're doing and
what we've been doing
and what your decision will be
the stakes are very high
and
we don't need to take a poll to do what
we did
i'm reminded of the testimony of the
president and dick morris taking a poll
to determine whether to tell the truth
or not
and then after deciding that the public
would not forgive his perjury he said
we'll just have to win
but that's not the attitude this house
has
the managers have been bringing this
case here we fully appreciate the
seriousness of it and the long-term
consequences of it and we want to do the
right thing we're not here just to win
we're here to help the senate
in this constitutional process
do the constitutional thing
not only for the president of this
senate but for the president of the
future generations in terms of how the
courts now and later will view
obstruction of justice and perjury
and we believe this is a constitutional
effort and not a game
the question about snippets that we just
put some snippets on the air today
we wanted to call live witnesses we
wanted ms lewinsky to be here and let
everybody examine her fully and
completely
but we're working within a time frame
and we brought up those points in her
testimony and in mr jordan's testimony
and mr blumenthal's testimony that we
felt proved our case
with regard to
the issue that
ms sulligan raised about
filing the false affidavit
she ran my testimony many times
i thought we ran the president's
testimony earlier in these hearings
several times but i think she beat our
record with my testimony now i
appreciate the exposure
but what that's important for
is not what ms lewinsky felt was going
on that night
but i think it perfectly illustrates
what i told you the other day about her
testimony
while she was truthful and while she
gave us the testimony she had to give us
to keep her immunity agreement where
there were some blanks to fill in
or where there was some something that
could be bent she did so
now as they pointed out the question of
the linkage
the linkage between filing an affidavit
and this cover story
was so obvious that they were connected
that the oic did not ask that question
did you think about this when you when
you and that
it was obvious though
but he did not ask that question she was
right
the question was not asked
so when she miss lewinsky had an
opportunity in these hearings when i
asked her
she said well you know i really didn't
link the two together
now let's don't throw away all our
common sense here
she gets a phone call in the middle of
the night
with the message that you're on the
witness list
and she says these three things occurred
you're on the witness list
you can file an affidavit
and you can
use this cover story why else did the
president raise the issue of the cover
story at 2 30 in the morning if he
didn't intend for her to use that
but keep in mind too it really doesn't
matter how she appreciated this it
really matters what the president
intended and he intended to let her know
that she was on the list she could be
subpoenaed she could file an affidavit
and she could use the cover story
and in fact she did use that cover story
she went to her lawyer mr carter
and told him that and it was
incorporated in the draft affidavit
that she went to take papers to the
president's son and in those occasions
she may have been alone
but they didn't like the the the specter
of of her being alone so they struck
that provision out of the final
affidavit
but they did attempt to use it
but keep in mind also that
it's the president's intent and his
intent was to hinder justice to impede
paula jones case and to have her give a
false affidavit and that's why he so
suggested that on the gift retrieval
is there really an issue is there really
an issue here
uh
some fabulous lawyering over here but
there's no issue here
miss lewinsky testified that there was
no doubt in her mind that miss curry
initiated the call
and that's all there is to this issue
the fact that there were other calls in
the day the fact that one of those other
calls may have been at 3 30.
uh really
our move
our moot point
the issue is if betty curry initiated
that phone call the only impetus for her
to initiate that call had to come from
the president had to come from the
president she was not in that
conversation that morning the president
had to tell her
and
apparently did so because she made the
call
at the end of the examination or her
testimony
or toward the end it was shown several
times we ask her
did the president ever tell you anything
about the gifts
and she said
not that i remember
and then later on the segment you also
saw
she was asked the question again by me
okay were there were you ever under any
impression or the impression that
anything the president from the
president that you should turn over all
the gifts to the jones lawyers and she
said no and then she goes on to say this
is gets a little tricky here and uh it
could be this i've heard this statement
from an agent somewhere along the line
and perhaps it did sound familiar i
would suggest to you what happened there
is that mr carter
and it's clearly in his
testimony before all of us
uh in the records mr carter her own
lawyer told her she had to turn over all
the records and that's that's where she
heard that but it logic
demands you reject that view because
why would the president whose intent it
was to conceal this whole affair
ever think of telling her that you've
got to turn over all those gifts
and if he did tell her that she had to
turn over all those gifts
why would she immediately go out that
afternoon and reject that instruction
just completely say well i'm going to
forget what he told me to do i'm going
to call his secretary and have her come
pick up these gifts and storm for me
that's that's not logical
common sense tells you that didn't
happen that way and ms lewinsky was
absolutely positive that there was no
doubt betty curry initiated the call
and and that's that
job search very quickly this is not a
bribery
case this is not giving her a job
bribing her with a job to get her false
testimony
it's not a bribery case if it was we
wouldn't argue we wouldn't be arguing
about the impeachability of obstruction
of justice it would be clear that
bribery is mentioned in the constitution
it's it's about attempting to corruptly
persuade or influence
the behavior of a witness and that's
exactly what that's about
i would also close very quickly uh by
telling you in the beginning i urged you
to look at in the particularly
obstruction of justice charges the
result benefit analysis and and i don't
i don't ever hear anybody talking about
that but me so maybe i'm off base here
but i ask you to consider each of these
seven pillars of obstruction that mr
hutchinson raised and look at the end
result of of those acts and look at who
benefited from those results and what i
believe you would have found and can
still find is that in each case the
result impeded justice in the paul jones
case in some way
that that favored the president
and the benefit naturally and nearer to
to the president
and i guess if you reject that result
benefit test and if you accept each and
every argument of these
extremely fine defense counsel that
the president wasn't behind any of this
then i guess you just have to reach the
conclusion that
the president was the luckiest man in
the world
that people would commit crimes by
filing false affidavits
by by hiding evidence
by
going out and possibly trashing
witnesses and giving false testimony and
grand jury proceedings
and and that
if that's the way you feel about it then
so be it we will abide by your judgment
but i suggest to you that
the facts of this case really aren't in
context they they've been argued very
very well by defense counsel for the
white house
and i'm about to exhaust my time so i
would yield at this point to mr
hutchison mr manager hutchinson too
the chair the chair recognized mr
manager hutchinson
[Music]
thank you mr chief justice this will be
very brief and then i'll yield to mr
graham let's recall miss monica lewinsky
to the stand for a brief moment let's go
to the park hyatt hotel december 31 1997
breakfast between miss lewinsky and mr
jordan
i gave to mr jordan was that
i was trying to sort of alert to him
that maybe linda tripp might be saying
these things about me having a
relationship with the president and
right now i'm explaining this to you
these aren't the words that i used or
how i said it to him
um
and that
you know maybe she had seen drafts of
notes
trying to obviously given excuses to how
linda tripp could possibly know about my
relationship with the president without
me having been the one to have told her
so
that's what i said to him
and what was his response
i think it was something like
go home and make sure oh something about
him i think he asked me if they were
notes from the president to me and i
said no
i know i've testified to this i stand by
that testimony and i'm just recalling it
that
i said no there were draft notes or
notes that i sent to the president and
then i believe he said something like
we'll go home and make sure they're not
there
and what did you do when you went home
i went home and i searched through some
of my papers and and
the drafts of notes i found i
sort of
i got rid of some of the notes that day
so you threw them away
yes sorry
thank you this goes to the overall
pattern of obstruction it goes to
credibility i believe it's relevant in
this case and i yield to mr graham
the chair recognizes mr magic graham
thank you just how much time
[Music]
[Applause]
point of agreement
rebuttal is to refocus
and the law allows that for the person
or the party with a burden and we do
have that burden
point of agreement
white house counsel says there's much
more that we need to know
there is much more we need to know
the white house council says strongly
when these proceedings opened up the
president is not guilty
of obstruction of justice the president
is not guilty of perjury
refocus
no fair-minded person in my opinion
could come to any other rational
conclusion
that our president
obstructed justice
that our president committed perjury in
front of a grand jury
you vote your conscience
i've told you to do so and if we
disagree at the end of the day
that's america at its best
i have never suggested
that there was any reasonable doubt
that this president committed crimes
i will ask you at the conclusion of this
case to remove him
with a clear conscience you vote your
conscience
and i know it will be clear
refocus the gifts simply put
if you believe the president of the
united states
in his grand jury testimony said
i told her i said look
the way these things work is when a
person get get gets a subpoena you have
to give them whatever you have that's
the way that's what the rule
that's what the law is
if you believe that we need to
congratulate our president because he
did in fact state the law correctly he
fulfilled his obligation as chief
executive officer of the land he
fulfilled his obligation as an honorable
person by telling someone who happened
to be miss lewinsky you're doing a bad
thing here even by suggesting that we do
something with these gifts you need to
turn them over because that's what the
law says
if you believe that that's the only time
he really embraced the law in this case
i can see
everything about him and the way he
behaved was 180 degrees out from that
statement
that is the most self-serving statement
that flies in the face of every action
he took for months
the truth is
that a reasonable person should conclude
that when miss lewinsky approached him
about what to do with the gifts he said
i'll have to think about that
and you know what ladies and gentlemen
he thought about it and you know what he
did after he thought about it betty go
get those gifts
and they wound up under the bed of the
president's secretary and people
wondering what the heck happened here
what the heck happened here is you got a
man trying to hide his crimes
affidavit where i come from you call
somebody at 2 30 in the morning you're
up to no good
that will be borne out if you listen to
the testimony and use your common sense
who is up to no good
he told her my heart is breaking because
you're on this witness list and maybe
here's a way to get out of it that's the
god's truth that's what he did and that
was wrong and that's a crime
the rule of law what does it mean
it means that process and procedure wins
out over politics and personality
that means that subpoenas have to be
honored by the great and the small
that means when subpoenas come you can
as the president try to defeat them
because you're nobody special in the
eyes of the law
except that you're the guardian of the
law if you're special you're special
in a more ominous way not a less way
when you file an affidavit in a court of
law nobody because of their position in
society has the right
to cheat and to get somebody to lie for
them even as the president
that means we're not a nation
of men
or kings we're a nation of laws and
that's what this case has always been
about to me
this affidavit
was false for a reason because the
president and mrs lewinsky wanted it to
be false
the job search
mission accomplished says it all
mission accomplished
it went from being no big deal to the
biggest deal in the world
where the telephone bill i don't know
what the telephone bill was to get this
job but it was huge
mission accomplished
all these are crimes
all these are things that average
americans should not be allowed to do
but i'm going to tell you something
at this point in time what is going on
is that he's trying to conceal a
relationship about the workplace that
would be embarrassing and that would be
illegal that would help ms jones that
would hurt him and it's just not about
his private life
but you can say this about the president
he was trying to get her a job
and he was trying to just get her to
file a false affidavit so this would go
away and he was trying to hide the gifts
and that's bad
but that's not nearly as bad as what was
to come
let me tell you what was to come ladies
and gentlemen
after the deposition
when it was clear that miss lewinsky
may have been talking or somebody knew
something they weren't supposed to know
the alarm bells went off
and
concealing the relationship changed
to
redefining the relationship
that is why he should not be our
president
the redefining of the relationship began
very quickly after that deposition
it started with the president's
secretary
and it goes like this
the president on two occasions under the
guise of refreshing his memory
makes the following statements to his
secretary
you're always there when she was there
right we were never really alone you
could see and hear everything monica
came on to me and i never touched her
right
she wanted to have sex with me and i
couldn't do that
if you believe that's about refreshing
your memory you're not being reasonable
that is about coaching a witness but
here's where it gets to be nasty
here's where it gets to be mean
monica came on to me and i never touched
her right she wanted to have sex with me
and i couldn't do that he didn't say it
once he said it twice
just to make sure miss curry would get
the point
now that miss lewinsky may be a problem
let me tell you how the discussion goes
it's not from concealing now is
redefining
conversation with mr morris
after they did the poll about what to do
here
and we just got a win
the president had a follow-up
conversation with mr morris during the
evening of january the 22nd 1998 the day
after the story broke
when mr morris was considered holding a
press conference to blast miss lewinsky
out of the water
the president told mr marsh to be
careful
to be careful according to mr
morris the president warned him not to
be too hard on mrs lewinsky because
there's some slight chance that she may
not be cooperating with mr star and we
don't want to alienate her about
anything we're going to put out
in other words don't blast her now she
may not be a problem to us
during this period of time it went from
concealing to rita finding
when he knew he had to win what did he
do
he went to his secretary and he made her
a sexual predator and him an innocent
victim
and he did it twice
but did he do it to anybody else
did he redefine his relationship to
anybody else i now would like to have a
clip from mr blumenthal please
you have a conversation with president
on the same day the article comes out
and the conversation
includes a discussion about the
relationship between him and mrs
lewinsky is that correct
yes
next tape
so now you stated i think very honestly
and i appreciate that you were lied to
by the president
is it a fair statement giving your
previous testimony concerning your
30-minute conversation
that the president was trying to portray
himself
as a victim
of a relationship with monica lewinsky
i think that's the import of his whole
story
ladies and gentlemen that is the import
of his whole story that story was told
on the day this broke in the press and
it goes on
that story is very detailed it makes him
the victim of a sexual predator called
miss lewinsky he had to rebuff her he
threatened her she threatened him excuse
me and it goes on and on and on and i
have always wondered
[Music]
how did that story
make it to the grand jury and how did it
make it into the press
we know how it made it to the grand jury
because mr blumenthal told it
and the president told him
and they claimed executive privilege and
the president never straightened it out
your president redefined this
relationship and your president let that
lie be passed to a grand jury your
president obstructed justice
in a mean way
next tape
age 49 yes sir
thank you it's where you start talking
about the story that the president told
you
knowing what you know now
do you believe the president lied to you
about his relationship with ms lewinsky
i do
next tape
do you have any idea
how white house sources are associated
with statements such as
she's known as elvira
she's obsessed with the president
she's known as a
flirt she's the product of a troubled
home divorced parents
she's known as the stalker do you have
any idea how that got in the press i'm
going to object the word document speaks
for itself but it's not clear that the
terms that mr lindsay has used are
necessarily any or all of them are from
a white house source object to the form
and the characterization of the question
the ones that i have indicated
are associated with the white house as
being the source of those statements
is appropriate and the objection is
overruled
i have no idea how
anything came to be attributed to a
white house source
everybody wants us over so bad you can
taste it including me but let's don't
leave a taste behind that history
cannot stand
it was shouted in these chambers for
god's sakes vote
let me
quietly if i can
for god's sakes get to the truth
for god's sakes figure out what kind of
person we have here in the white house
for god's sake spend some time to
fulfill your constitutional duty so that
we can get it right not for just our
political moment but for the future of
this nation
when the president redefined this
relationship
he did so by telling a lie
he told a lie to a key how a white house
aide who repeated that lie to a federal
grand jury in our system ladies and
gentlemen that's a crime
that lie made it into the public domain
that lie was mean
that lie would have the effect to run
this young lady over
and you didn't think what you want to
think too about miss tripp and i agree
she's not going to be in the hall of
fame of friends
but let me tell you the best advice she
ever gave that young lady was to keep
that blue dress
[Music]
the final thing
is that our president and my opinion and
for you to judge
in august of last year
after being begged not to by many
members of this body and prominent
americans
appeared before a federal grand jury to
answer for the conduct in this case his
conduct
we have alleged that with forewarning
and knowledge on his part
that instead of clearing it up to make
america
a better place
instead of fulfilling his role as the
chief law enforcement officer of the
land to do honor to the law
instead of taking this burden off all
americans back
he told a story that defies common sense
that he played a butchery game with the
english language that is maybe is not
his
and alone is not alone and each old told
john podesta my relationship with miss
lewinsky was not sexual including oral
sex
he went on and told an elaborate
authorised a federal grand jury that
they just didn't ask the right question
and really the sexual relationship did
include one thing but not another
and he says he never lied to his aid and
he says he never lied to a grand jury
well god knows he lied to
somebody and he lied to that grand jury
and this whole story is a fraud and a
forest
and the last people in the united states
to straighten it out
is the united states senate god bless
you in your endeavors
mr chief justice
yes the chair recognizes the senator
from california in light of the negative
comments made against mr jordan by
manager hutchinson and manager graham i
asked once again unanimous consent that
in fairness the
regular order of business has been
called for i ask unanimous consent that
in fairness mr jordan's two-minute
testimony regarding his own integrity be
shown to the senate at this time
is there objection i object because the
chief justice uh has all time been uh
used or yielded back
all time has been used or yielded back
then that concludes the presentations
for the day the senate will reconvene as
a court of impeachment on monday
beginning one that time the house
managers in the white house will proceed
with their closing arguments for up to
three hours i ask the court of
impeachment stan adjourn under the
previous order and further sentence
business resume after that without
objection it's so ordered
[Applause]
the senate will please come to order
would senators please take their seats
you see what we have sessions yes
senators please come to order take their
conversations outside the chamber
i think there's a resolution that mr
president i believe we have some routine
business to conclude but i do want to
notify the senators that we have been
notified that scott bates uh wife ricky
uh is undergoing orthopedic surgery uh
that to our knowledge has not been
completed uh but our prayers are with
her and we wish her speedy recovery
the business we had to do is just to
have a reading of a house bill
and to do a resolution
on behalf of our friend scott bates
therefore i understand that h.r 99 has
been received from the house and i asked
to be read for the first time
the clerk will read the bill for the
first time
h.r 99 an act to amend title 49 united
states code to extend federal aviation
administration programs through
september 30th 1999 and for other
purposes
uh mr president i asked for a second
reading and i would object to my own
request
objection is heard
okay
i now ask unanimous consent that the
senate proceed to a senate concurrent
resolution which is at the desk and i
ask that the resolution be read in its
entirety
clerk will read the resolution
senate concurrent resolution six
authorizing flags located in the capitol
complex to be flown at half-staff in
memory of r scott bates
legislative clerk of the united states
senate
resolved by the senate the house of
representatives concurring that as a
mark of respect to the memory of r scott
bates legislative clerk of the united
states senate all flags of the united
states
located on capitol buildings or on the
capitol grounds shall be flown at
half-staff on the day of his internment
mr president i ask unanimous consent
that the current resolution be agreed to
and the motion reconsider be laid upon
the tape without objection so ordered
and i asked the senate standing german
until 1 pm on monday february 8th
senate is adjourned
the senate now adjourned until monday
february 8th back in impeachment trial
at one o'clock eastern time on that day
you'll see live coverage of that here on
c-span 2 in its entirety coming up on
our companion network tonight at 8 p.m
eastern time if you missed any of
today's session of the senate you can
see that again on c-span re-airing at 8
o'clock eastern time this is an
opportunity again for you to give us a
call with the decision that you've made
about what the president should be
acquitted or convicted the area code is
202 624